Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Brittlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zur 119.
Ausgabe von UKW.
Und ja, heute geht es, wenig überraschend, weiter in unserer Berichterstattung
über die Krise in der Ukraine, den Krieg in der Ukraine.
Ich begrüße dazu Pavel heute mal wieder. Hallo.
Ja, hallo Tim.
Es ist jetzt eine Weile her, dass wir uns das letzte Mal über das Thema gebeugt haben.
Tatsächlich hatten wir jetzt unsere letzte Sendung am 23. November.
Jetzt haben wir den 7. März 2024. Das heißt, da ist dann schon mal,
ja, drei Monate sind vergangen.
Ich hatte zwischendurch allerdings jetzt vor einem Monat eine Sendung mit Enno
Lenze gemacht, die letzte, die 118, wo er mal berichtet hat aus seiner Perspektive,
wie es so in der Ukraine aussieht.
Da haben wir uns aber jetzt nicht so sehr an der Chronologie des Krieges selber orientiert.
Das wollen wir nämlich dann heute nachholen und blicken quasi auf die letzten
drei Monate des Konfliktes zurück und was sonst noch so passiert ist.
Konkret möchten wir heute sprechen über die russische Bodenoffensive,
die wir in den letzten drei Monaten gesehen haben. Die ähm...
Angriffe auch mit Drohnen und Raketen auf die Ukraine, die halt zwischendurch weitergegangen ist.
Wir wollen den Bridgehead betrachten, den einzigen Vorstoß über den Dnipro-Fluss,
den die Ukraine bisher in Kherson hat machen können und nach wie vor hält.
Wir schauen auf den Seekrieg im Schwarzen Meer und die Angriffe auf die Krim,
die dort mit zusammenhängen.
Generell den Luftkrieg, den Counter-Luftkrieg, den wiederum die Ukraine gegenüber
Russland macht. Das ist ein sehr interessantes Feld.
Und auch die Versuche der Ukraine, die russische Infrastruktur lahmzulegen.
Wir gucken dann auch nochmal auf sonstige Infrastrukturprobleme,
die Russland ganz unabhängig vom Krieg hat. Dann Fragen der Aufrüstung,
Umbau des ukrainischen Militärs war ein Thema.
Ja und dann werde ich ein bisschen berichten von meiner eigenen Reise in die
Ukraine, da war ich nämlich jetzt gerade in der letzten Woche,
habe dort für acht Tage das Land besucht und bin umhergereist und hatte sehr
sehr interessante Einblicke gewinnen können.
Ja und zum Abschluss wollen wir uns dann noch so ein bisschen über die Politik,
die internationale Politik rund um den Krieg kümmern und speziell dann auch
nochmal auf die deutsche Debatte rund um das Taurus-Waffensystem bzw.
Die generelle Haltung von Deutschland zum Krieg unterhalten.
Ja, das ist so unsere Agenda heute.
Ja, strammer Plan.
Im Client, das ist jetzt so ein neuer Trend, da freue ich mich schon sehr drüber,
also die ganzen Transkripte, die wir hier erstellen, werden auch immer zugänglicher und nützlicher.
Ansonsten haben wir natürlich auch noch die Shownotes, aber wie immer,
es ist sehr schwierig, diesen Krieg mit Meldungen und Links auf Artikeln zu dokumentieren,
einfach weil das alles teilweise einfach aus dass Chatkanälen herauskommt und
die Lage auch so volatil ist und sich permanent immer wieder ändert,
dass das eigentlich schwer nachzulesen ist.
Sehr praktisch habe ich allerdings die Chronikseiten gefunden in der Wikipedia zum Krieg.
Also da kann man nahezu alles, was wir hier erwähnen, in irgendeiner Form nachschlagen,
aber verzeiht es uns bitte, dass wir jetzt nicht wirklich für jeden Aspekt hier
immer einen einzelnen Link parat haben,
was bestimmte Sachen betrifft schon, aber das ist einfach kaum handelbar.
Da fehlen in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch das richtige Werkzeug für Podcaster,
um so etwas mal wirklich gut durchzuautomatisieren. Naja gut,
dann legen wir los, oder?
Ja.
Gut, also wie gesagt, wir wollen erstmal schauen, was ist eigentlich überhaupt passiert.
Und Anfang Dezember hatten wir auch schon ein weiteres Mal auf die Lage in Avdivka geschaut.
Das war bei der vorletzten, also unserer vorletzten Sendung auch dann sozusagen
der Zeitpunkt Anfang Oktober. Ich glaube zum 10.
Oktober ging halt diese Offensive los.
Und Avdivka, das ist so ein Vorort von der Stadt Donetsk.
Und Donetsk ist ja einerseits so ein Oblast, also so eine größere Region,
die dann eben nach der Hauptstadt Donetsk benannt ist und direkt vor den Toren
der Stadt hält oder hielt, vielmehr muss man jetzt sagen, der Ukraine diesen Vorort Avdivka.
Afdivka, eben seit 2014 ist das sozusagen umkämpftes Gebiet gewesen.
Und der Vorstoß auf Afdivka lag Putin offensichtlich sehr am Herzen und die
Ressourcen, die Russland darauf geleitet hat in den letzten Monaten,
also im Prinzip jetzt war das ein Zeitraum von fünf Monaten,
ist irgendwie unfassbar.
Also die Verluste, die die Russen haben hinnehmen müssen, nur um diese paar
Kilometer Land einzunehmen und diese Stadt, die eigentlich gar keine Stadt ist,
sondern eben wirklich nur so ein Vorort.
Ich glaube, Avtivka hatte vor dem Krieg so 30.000 Einwohner,
aber es sind halt jetzt offenbar ungefähr 50.000 Russen allein im Kampf um diesen einen Vorort gefallen.
Die Zahlen sind wie immer so ein bisschen wonky, da liest man halt alles mögliche
und das sind auch Schätzungen.
Teilweise ist es natürlich gedeckt einfach durch Kamerabeobachtung etc.
Aber so in der Größenordnung haut das hin. Also in den ganzen Monaten haben
sie irgendwie 50.000 Leute verloren,
vielleicht bis zu 400 Panzer, nochmal 750 gepanzerte Fahrzeuge,
irgendeiner Art 250 Artilleriesysteme und diverse Flugzeuge auch noch.
Das ist sozusagen allein nur dieser eine einzige Ort, an dem jetzt monatelang gekämpft wurde.
Also die niedrigsten Zahlen, von denen ich gehört habe,
lagen um die 18.000 Toten auf russischer Seite, was immer noch mehr wäre als
im Afghanistan-Krieg, so als in zehn Jahren Afghanistan-Krieg.
Also selbst wenn man jetzt die niedrigsten Zahlen nimmt und die 50.000 sind
vielleicht nicht Tote, aber sagen Verluste im Sinne von Casualties,
also Tote und Verwundete,
die halt einfach raus sind aus dem Kampf.
So und wahrscheinlich, wie gesagt, liegt die Wahrheit irgendwo in der Mitte.
Also sie haben auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, zigtausend Leute verloren dort.
Das ist, glaube ich, eine realistische Einschätzung.
Fünfstellig ist ja auf jeden Fall eine realistische Einschätzung,
weil das einfach, die sind einfach in großen Verbänden vorgestoßen.
Es gibt da am Laufen im Meta-Videos, Da fahren dann einfach mal so zehn Panzer
rein, irgendwie alle voll besetzt.
Da sitzen dann auch die Leute teilweise oben auf den Fahrzeugen oben drauf und
dann macht es Krachbomben, Drohnen von allen Seiten und zehn Minuten später
ist das Ganze halt obliterated und das findet da halt dann mehrmals am Tag statt.
Also das ist so von der Größenordnung alles realistisch.
Und die Bilder, irgendwann habe ich aufgehört, auch überhaupt zu klicken,
weil mir das zu krass wurde,
so wo du wirklich Leichenfelder dort siehst, also mit Dutzenden von Toten, die du...
Da siehst oder teilweise beim Sterben beobachten kannst.
Also das war mir dann auch irgendwie irgendwann zu viel.
Ja, es ist nicht soft on the mind. Aber es dokumentiert das halt.
Gerade diese Überflüge mit irgendwelchen Drohnen, wie du sagst,
wo man also einfach kilometerlang einfach eine Leichenstraße sieht.
Es ist unvorstellbar, was die Russen bereit sind dort zu opfern,
nur um so einen kleinen Ort zu nehmen.
Das war dann allerdings auch nicht der einzige Vorstoß, sondern generell kann
man davon reden, dass es eine Winterboden-Offensive der Russen gegeben hat und auch nach wie vor gibt.
Das heißt entlang der gesamten östlichen Frontlinie haben sich eigentlich mehrere
solche Kampforte ergeben.
Neben Avdivka gab es auch noch entsprechende Vorstöße etwas weiter südlich.
Marinka auch immer mit irgendwelchen Fortschritten, aber nichts,
was in irgendeiner Form groß beunruhigen sollte, was so den allgemeinen Vorstoß in das Land betrifft.
Das sind zwar Landverluste, aber wir reden halt immer darüber,
ob jetzt hier nochmal so ein total zerbombtes Kaff irgendwie ein paar hundert
Meter überrollt wurde oder nicht und auch nach Norden hin alte umkämpfte Gebiete
um Kremina und um die Schlüsselstadt Kupjansk,
also überall versuchen die Russen vorzustoßen, aber die Verluste sind einfach extrem groß,
sowohl bei den Russen als auch bei den Ukrainern, aber man kann schon davon ausgehen.
Da wird es natürlich jetzt wieder mit dem Einschätzen sehr schwierig,
weil je nachdem, wohin man schaut, wie man fragt, gibt es da unterschiedliche Einschätzungen.
Aber ich denke, man kann klar sagen, dass die Zahl der Verluste bei den Russen
deutlich höher ist als bei den Ukrainern.
Ob es sich im Verhältnis 3 zu 1, 4 zu 1, 5 zu 1 oder 10 zu 1 verhält im Einzelnen,
das lässt sich wirklich kaum festhalten.
Ja, auf jeden Fall und das fand ich auch bemerkenswert, scheint der Februar
der verlustreichste Monat für die Russen gewesen zu sein im gesamten Krieg.
Auch wenn das nicht so aussieht, nicht in den Schlagzeilen ist,
aber mindestens viele Zahlen legen das nahe, dass die Russen in keinem Monat
zuvor so viele Leute verloren haben wie im Februar. und das, ja.
Definitiv. Da fragt man sich natürlich auch immer wieder, okay,
wo holen sie diese ganzen Leute her?
Und man darf glaube ich generell nicht vergessen, dass Russland eigentlich so ein Double Genocide,
begeht, weil auf der einen Seite versuchen sie natürlich die Ukraine zu vernichten,
das kann man glaube ich mal so festhalten, weil das sagen sie auch im Fernsehen. Und.
Auf der anderen Seite sind sehr viele von diesen Kämpfern, die dort sterben,
zwar auf dem Papier Russen, aber jetzt so rein ethnisch nicht unbedingt Russen,
sondern es werden halt einfach sehr viele Rekruten in den asiatischen Regionen Russlands,
also der russischen Föderation herangezogen.
Arme Leute aus armen Landstrichen, die sich halt irgendwie, ja die eh kaum verlässliche
Informationen über diesen Krieg erhalten, in ihren Regionen wenig Geld haben
und dann halt einfach angelockt werden von den finanziellen Versprechungen.
Teilweise werden ja sogar Leute aus Nepal, Indien, Leute die nach Russland fahren,
um dort zu arbeiten oder auch nur Touristen werden teilweise einfach von der
Straße gegriffen und in irgendwelche Militärsegmente gesteckt und an die Front geschickt.
Also da gibt es sehr viele Berichte in dieser Hinsicht und da Russland ja auch
generell schon immer einen Kampf gegen seine Ostvölker geführt hat und sozusagen
diese Russifizierung des gesamten Gebietes vorantreibt,
dient der Krieg hier in beiderlei Hinsicht.
Während halt Russland und St. Petersburg als zentrale Region nach wie vor in
der Rekrutierung nicht so stark beteiligt sind an diesem Krieg.
Das macht es noch schlimmer.
Genau, aber sie haben halt jetzt tatsächlich das Erfolgsrezept gefunden für
die Rekrutierung, hatten wir auch schon erwähnt, nämlich Geld.
Einfach, sie sagen auch das Ganze irgendwie Hurra fürs Vaterland und so,
und hat nicht funktioniert und Druck ausüben, das hat dann doch die letzte...
Die Mobilisierung oder die Zwangsrekrutierung hat dann auch deutlich für geringere
Zustimmung für Putin gesorgt,
aber mit Geld jetzt scheinen sie Erfolg zu haben.
So das scheint zu funktionieren.
Zumindest was das Personal betrifft, bei den Fahrzeugen bin ich mir da nicht
ganz so sicher, ob sich das alles mit Geld lösen lässt, weil die Verluste,
also die Fahrzeugverluste, die Russland hat, die sind auch einfach enorm.
Ich wundere mich jetzt schon seit Tagen immer wieder, wenn ich ein Video von
einem zerstörten T-90 Panzer sehe, weil eigentlich müssten die jetzt bald zu Ende sein.
Also so viele Berichte wie es, also bestätigte Berichte von T-90 Zerstörung,
das ist der modernste Panzer, den Russland eigentlich hat auf dem Papier.
Und die Zahl, die vorher bekannt war oder von der man annahm,
dass das sozusagen der Bestand sei, wird langsam erreicht.
Es werden natürlich alle möglichen Fahrzeuge zerstört und es gibt auch Fahrzeugbereiche.
Da ist Russland so gut aufgestellt, also Artillerie haben sie immer noch extrem
viele Systeme in der Hinterhand.
Das wird noch sehr lange dauern, bis man davon sprechen kann,
dass die Vorräte aufgebraucht sind.
Aber im Bereich der Panzer kann man glaube ich heute schon davon ausgehen,
dass Russland ungefähr die Hälfte seines Panzerbestandes in diesem Krieg schon verballert hat.
Zumindest die Hälfte des gut funktionierenden Anteils dieser Bestände.
Ähnlich dürfte es sich bei anderen gepanzerten Fahrzeugen, Truppentransporter
haben sie glaube ich sehr viele, aber so genau lässt sich das ja immer nicht sagen.
Es gibt interessante Videos auf YouTube zum Beispiel hier von Kuwait Kabal,
die immer wieder die ganzen offenen Lagerstätten von Panzern und anderen Fahrzeugen
mit aktuellen Satellitenbildern abgrasen.
Und zählen, was da so rumsteht und da ergeben sich dann teilweise doch schon signifikante Lücken.
Ja, aber so was auch nach Experteneinschätzung Russland geglückt ist,
ist die Rüstungsproduktion schneller hochzufahren, als das der Westen getan hat.
Also die haben da ja signifikant jetzt umgestellt.
Allerdings so scheinen sie jetzt an einem Peak angekommen zu sein auch.
Also weitere größere Steigerungen sind nicht zu erwarten.
Außer sie würden dann jetzt radikal in die Wirtschaft eingreifen,
also tatsächlich dann komplett auf Kriegswirtschaft umstellen und quasi sämtliche
privaten Unternehmen direkt zu dirigieren.
Und davor schrecken sie aber zurück, weil das würde dann eben auch noch mal dann...
Das Warenangebot noch mal drastisch reduzieren für die Bevölkerung.
Und da scheinen sie eben auch im Moment vor, zurückzuschrecken.
Und sie scheinen jetzt an dem Punkt zu sein, dass sie das,
ja, also Peak Production jetzt ohne, jetzt komplett den Rest der Wirtschaft
in den Kriegsdienst zu stellen. So, das ist wohl die Situation.
Ja und die Produktion bei Panzern zum Beispiel, die fährt auf dem absoluten
Maximum und das Problem ist, dass sie das auch gar nicht mehr weiter steigern
können, dass sie definitiv höhere Verluste haben, als sie jetzt produzieren können.
Also der Bestand senkt sich, die Frage ist nur, senkt er sich schnell genug
und es gibt auch Bereiche, da hat Russland relativ wenig Probleme,
also auch die Artillerieproduktionskapazitäten Russlands sind riesig,
die fahren auf vollem Programm und die zwischenzeitlich drohende Verknappung
haben sie eben durch Lieferungen aus Nordkorea ausgleichen können,
Auch wenn die nordkoreanischen Artillerie-Shells nicht gerade im Ruf stehen,
besonders gut zu funktionieren.
Also teilweise funktionieren sie gar nicht und die ganzen Treibladungen sind wohl auch mal so, mal so.
Also sie sind auch nicht besonders präzise, aber Russland kann halt nach wie
vor, wenn vielleicht nicht aus
dem Vollen, dann doch zumindest aus einem ausreichenden Vorrat schöpfen.
Das sieht bei der Ukraine da schon ganz anders aus, da werden wir aber gleich
nochmal separat drauf eingehen.
Ja, das jetzt erstmal zu dieser Winterboden-Offensive.
Parallel dazu laufen natürlich weiterhin auch die Luftangriffe mit Drohnen und
Raketen auf die Ukraine weiter.
Also es gab gerade im Dezember dann die größten kombinierten Angriffe auf die Ukraine.
Also um den Jahreswechsel herum gab es dann quasi vor dem orthodoxen Weihnachten
und dann zum Jahreswechsel gab es riesige kombinierte Angriffe,
wo hunderte von Raketen und Drohnen gleichzeitig losgeschossen werden konnten oder wurden.
Und dann waren auch die Auswirkungen natürlich zu sehen.
Allerdings muss man auch sagen, im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr,
als wir eine ähnliche Kampagne gesehen haben, hat die Luftverteidigung der Ukraine
den Umständen entsprechend gut funktioniert.
Also man merkt, dass einfach sehr viele Patriot, Nasams,
RST und sonstige Systeme positioniert wurden und die ukrainische Armee auch
deren Handhabung wohl ganz gut integriert hat in ihr Gesamtsystem,
sodass also wirklich der vorwiegende Teil dieser Angriffe auch abgewehrt werden
konnte, aber trotzdem gab es natürlich immer wieder noch Einschläge und die gibt es auch weiterhin.
Ja, so, was so, weiß nicht, fünf Prozent oder also ein paar Prozent scheinen
dann doch durchzukommen, so,
und ja, das ist dann natürlich teilweise sehr tragisch, da kommen wir,
glaube ich, vielleicht auch nochmal später bei deinem Besuch noch drauf,
da warst du ja ziemlich nah dran, aber.
Genau, also man muss sich nur klar machen, Russland hat da einfach enorm viel Potenzial.
Dazu kommt auch, dass sie auch hier mittlerweile auch Raketen aus Nordkorea
zum Einsatz bringen, zusätzlich zu diesen iranischen Shahed-Drohnen,
die ja schon länger im Gespräch sind.
Bei den Shahed-Drohnen ist es wohl auch so, dass Russland mittlerweile eigene
Produktionskapazitäten aufgebaut hat, also sie importieren nicht einfach nur
fertiggebaute aus dem Iran,
sondern sie haben eine Fabrik aufgebaut oder eine Produktionsstraße aufgebaut,
um die auch selber herstellen zu können.
So eine Shahed Drohne ist so ein ziemlicher Klopper, wenn man so da direkt daneben
steht, ist das Ding so ein paar Meter lang,
hat halt hinten so einen Moped Motor, klingt ja auch entsprechend und liefert
im Prinzip langsam fliegend, man kann es relativ gut abschießen,
aber trotzdem, wenn halt viele kommen, du triffst nicht alle,
irgendeiner kommt dann halt durch und dann ist es halt so.
Aber noch viel schlimmer sind natürlich die großen Raketen, die dann aber auch sehr teuer sind.
Überhaupt muss man sagen, ist dieser ganze Krieg für Russland sehr,
sehr teuer und das, was sie allein da in diesen Dezemberangriffen abgeregnet
haben, Dezember, Januar,
das waren also viele Milliarden pro Tag, die da quasi zum Einsatz kamen,
ohne vor allem einen großen militärischen Sinn zu haben.
Also man muss das mal ein bisschen mit Vorbehalt sagen,
weil wir wissen natürlich nicht, ob einzelne Raketen, die durchgeflogen sind
in die Ukraine und nicht abgeschossen werden konnten, nicht auch nennenswerte
militärische Ziele vernichtet haben, weil darüber wird sich die Ukraine natürlich auch ausschweigen.
Trotzdem hält das sich in Grenzen.
Ja, allerdings, ich glaube, besonders unangenehm dürften auch die Gleitbombenangriffe gewesen sein,
weil die haben da so 1000 und 2000 Kilo Bomben aus 50 bis 70 Kilometern Entfernung
dann von Flugzeugen losgeschickt.
Und das sind schon ziemlich gewaltige Dinger.
Das ist, was man früher irgendwie Blockbuster nannte.
Also so eine 2000-Kilo-Bombe kann einen kompletten Häuserblock in Schutt und
Asche legen tatsächlich.
Und neulich gab es in England irgendwo eine Sprengung von einer Weltkriegsbombe
aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Und das war, glaube ich, eine deutsche 500-Kilo-Bombe.
Und die haben das mit Containern und allem zugestellt, weil die konnten die
nicht abtransportieren. Und bei der Sprengung sind noch in ein Kilometer Entfernung
die Scheiben geborsten in der Stadt.
Also es gab gewaltige Schäden. Das heißt, wenn ich mir dann vorstelle.
Dass sie und haben die auch in Avdivka halt diese Fabrik mit diesen Monstern-Dingern
bombardiert und das muss äußerst unangenehm gewesen sein für die Verteidiger.
Absolut. Also Gleitbombs sind ja auf beiden Seiten so ein bisschen die Halsbringer.
Also Russland hat halt diese großen, schweren Bomben.
Gleitbombs heißt, dass die quasi mit Flügeln ausgestattet werden und in dem
Fall von den Russen mit ihren Su-34-Kampfflugzeugen, vielleicht auch noch mit
anderen, abgeworfen werden.
Aber ich glaube vor allem mit diesen SO-34, das heißt die können sie darunter
befestigen und aus einer sehr großen Höhe,
aber dann eben auch aus einer relevanten Distanz von 10-20 Kilometern abwerfen
und dann segeln die sozusagen ins Ziel.
Und das ist in der Tat ein großes Problem gewesen, wobei die Ukraine hier ein
gutes Abwehrmittel gefunden hat.
Da kann man ja vielleicht auch gleich dann mal als nächstes drauf eingehen.
Ja, eine Sache noch zu den Gleitbomben. Was allerdings so ein bisschen ein Problem
auf russischer Seite war, dass manchmal die Tragflügel nicht ausgeklappt sind.
Und irgendwie waren die Dinger dann auch nicht so geschaltet,
dass wenn die Flügel nicht ausklappen,
die trotzdem scharf waren und dann eben so auf russischer Seite runtergegangen sind.
Also da gab es eben dann auch immer wieder Nachrichten, dass halt einige dieser
Bomben dann auf russischer Seite eingeschlagen sind und einige auch eben mitten in Städten.
Das hatten wir ja dann, also russischen Städten, Belgorod zum Beispiel,
sind zwei von den Dingern auf eine befahrene Straße gefallen.
Da hatten wir ja auch drüber berichtet und scheint aber ein bisschen besser geworden zu sein.
Oder sie wählen die Abwerfpunkte jetzt so, dass wenn die Dinger nicht ausklappen,
die wenigstens nicht mitten in der Stadt runterkommen.
Die lernen auch dazu, die Russen.
Ja, leider. Ja gut, das bringt uns dann zum Gegenkrieg sozusagen in der Luft.
Auch die Ukraine ist ja hier nicht faul und hat auch eine extrem hohe Vielfalt
an Drohnensystemen entwickelt in der letzten Zeit,
die sie jetzt in zunehmendem Maße zum Einsatz bringen.
Also das sind wirklich alle Arten von Drohnen, das sind Überwachungsdrohnen,
also solche Spotter-Drohns, die halt sozusagen...
Gebiete überfliegen, kartografieren, Erkenntnisse liefern, aber eben auch viele
Kamikaze-Drohnen, die also direkt in Ziele fliegen.
Am Anfang des Kriegs hatten wir ja den Einsatz der Bayraktar,
der türkischen Bayraktar-Drohne zum Beispiel gesehen, die auch selber Missiles abschießen konnte.
Die war allerdings im letzten Jahr nicht mehr so viel im Einsatz,
zumindest hat man davon relativ wenig gesehen, weil sie doch recht groß ist,
relativ langsam fliegt und sich die russische Luftabwehr mittlerweile da ganz
gut drauf eingestellt hat.
Diese ganzen neuen Drohnen, die die Ukraine zum Einsatz bringt,
die machen den Russen dann doch eine ganze Menge Ärger.
Es gab immer wieder solche Kampagnen mit kombinierten Drohnenangriffen,
die teilweise Decoys waren, also Drohnen, die sozusagen eigentlich gar keine Sprengköpfe haben,
sondern die einfach nur irgendwo lang geflogen sind, um überhaupt erstmal die
Luftabwehr zu aktivieren.
Dass halt Erkenntnisse darüber gewonnen werden konnten, wo gibt es denn überhaupt
noch eine funktionierende Luftabwehr, wo stehen diese Batterien,
die dann wiederum von anderen Drohnen angegriffen und zerstört wurden.
Beziehungsweise die dadurch, dass so eine Luftabwehrbatterie erstmal im Betrieb
ist und erstmal ihre Bestückung verfeuert, danach für einen bestimmten Zeitraum
nicht mehr aktiv sein kann, weil die muss ja auch erstmal nachgeladen werden.
Und das ist dann nicht so vollautomatisch, dass man auf den Knopf drückt und
dann kommen die Dinger irgendwie aus dem Bunker, sondern da müssen dann schon
mal Leute mit dem Lastwagen hinfahren und die Rohre wieder bestücken.
Je nach System ist es mehr oder weniger aufwendig. Also auch das ist dann sozusagen
Teil dieser kombinierten Angriffe gewesen,
dass man dadurch quasi Korridore frei bekommen hat, um dann mit größeren Waffen
wie zum Beispiel den Storm Shadow und Skuid Missiles durchzukommen.
Um dann eben größere taktische Ziele anzugreifen.
Und dabei ist dann doch einiges kaputt gegangen.
Unter anderem gab es einen sehr erfolgreichen Angriff auf die russische Kommandozentrale
der Krim, die offenbar komplett zerstört wurde, so ein größeres Gebäude.
Und dabei ist wohl eine größere Teilmenge der Führungsriege des russischen Militärs,
die für die Krim zuständig ist, ums Leben gekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob dieser Admiral Sokolow, der sozusagen da die Führung hat,
das wurde dann lange Zeit nicht bestätigt. Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist er offiziell
zurückgetreten, aber gesehen hat ihn bis heute noch keiner.
Es gab dann irgendeine ominöse Videokonferenz mit Putin,
wo sie ihn irgendwie so links oben eingeblendet haben, der aber irgendwie kein Wort gesagt hat,
sodass alle davon ausgingen, so, ja, okay, jetzt haben sie ihn mal gezeigt,
um so zu tun, dass er nicht umgekommen ist, weil ein bisschen peinlich war die
Nummer für Russland natürlich an der Stelle schon.
Bei diesem Belbeck Airfield ist auch in der Krim wichtiger Standort,
sind auch Kommandozentralen zerstört worden.
Also am laufenden Meter gab es in den letzten Monaten solche kombinierten Angriffe,
teilweise auf eben diese Kommandozentralen, teilweise auf die Luftabwehrsysteme,
die wohl enormen Schaden genommen haben.
Und dann auch in zunehmendem Maße gab es auch Angriffe auf Flugzeuge.
Und das ist vielleicht die größte Erfolgsgeschichte im Luftkampf zumindest,
die man der Ukraine so zugute halten kann.
Weil hier sind sie irgendwie offenbar richtig kreativ geworden.
Wir hatten ja gesagt, die SO-34-Kampfflugzeuge, davon hat Russland angeblich
zu Beginn dieses Krieges ungefähr 149 gehabt.
Das ist so ihre stärkste Waffe an der Stelle.
Es gibt noch andere Kampfflugzeuge, die andere Spezialisierungen haben.
Aber in diesem Feld sind vor allem diese SO-34 das große Problem,
weil die nämlich diese Gleitbombs tragen. Nicht nur, aber auch.
Und das hat halt in der letzten Zeit den Ukrainern doch schwer zu schaffen gemacht,
wegen dieser schon angesprochenen extremen Sprengkraft.
Und nun war es also ein Ziel der ukrainischen Luftabwehr, sich dieser Flugzeuge zu entledigen.
Und offenbar gab es dafür eine neue Taktik, die damit zu tun hat,
dass man ein Patriot-System überhatte, was man nicht fest stationieren musste oder wollte.
Paget ist ja dieses supermoderne Luftwehrabwehrsystem der Amerikaner,
was so aus verschiedensten Komponenten besteht.
Da gibt es dann halt Radare und Launcher und die müssen alle nicht am selben
Ort stehen, sondern kann man halt über so einen gewissen Bereich verteilen,
tut dies in der Regel auch.
Und es wird nun davon ausgegangen, wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht bestätigt,
aber es gibt zumindest keine plausible andere Erklärung für diese Erfolge,
die die Ukraine hier erzielt hat.
Unter Berücksichtigung der zur Anwendung kommenden Radar- und Raketenreichweiten.
Also es macht so den Eindruck, dass in dem Südostbereich des Frontverlaufs in
irgendeiner Form so ein mobiles Patriot-System unterwegs ist.
Das heißt, die Ukrainer deployen das irgendwo hin, relativ nah an den Frontverlauf.
Und wenn jetzt diese SO-34 angeflogen kommen mit ihren dicken Gleitbomben,
dann müssen sie die ja relativ hoch abwerfen, weil die ja gleiten.
So, können sie nicht bei tausend Metern Höhe abwerfen, dann würden die halt nicht weit kommen.
Dann müssten die Flugzeuge so nah an die Front heranfliegen,
dass sie dort von den normalen Luftwehrsystemen sofort gekillt werden.
Also wollen sie von weiter weg machen, dann müssen sie aber auch entsprechend höher steigen.
Und wenn sie so hoch fliegen, können sie wiederum aber auch auf sehr lange Distanz
von Radarsystemen erfasst werden. Und jetzt ist es natürlich so,
dass diese Flugzeuge alle einen Detektionsmechanismus haben.
Das heißt, wenn die von Fremdradar erfasst werden, merken die das auch und drehen
dann halt auch schnell wieder um.
So nach dem Motto Luftabwehr detektiert, auf mir ist sozusagen Radar herabgelegnet,
schnell mal weg, bevor ich jetzt hier abgeschossen werde.
Und der Trick, den Ukraine hier offensichtlich zum Einsatz gebracht hat, war der,
dass die Flugzeuge dann halt auf 10, 20 Kilometer rankamen, dort dann auch zwar
von Radar erfasst wurden, aber von einem Radar, was eigentlich relativ einen
kurzen Bereich hat. Das heißt erst.
Bei diesem Abstand haben die russischen Flugzeuge gemerkt, so oha,
jetzt sind wir erfasst worden.
Aber in dem Moment haben sie dann auf die Radarsysteme von den Patriot-Systemen
weiter im Hinterland umgeschaltet, die halt mal locker 200 Kilometer abdecken können.
Und obwohl die Flugzeuge dann umgedreht sind, vielleicht in dem Moment,
konnte das Patriot Radar die noch sehr viel länger erfassen und die Raketen die auch verfolgen.
Und das war dann so erfolgreich, dass gleich an einem Tag, damit ging es irgendwie
los, drei SO-34 auf einmal abgeschossen werden konnten über Kherson.
Und alle schon so, yeah, das war ja total krass. Und dann ging das irgendwie
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen am laufenden Meter so weiter.
SO34, es gab einen Zeitraum jetzt bis vor einer Woche,
wo das so krass angestiegen ist, dass glaube ich insgesamt in zwei Wochen 15
SO34 oder SO35 Flugzeuge abgeschossen wurden. Also fast einer pro Tag.
Also in zwei Wochen so ungefähr 10% des Bestands vernichtet wurden, des russischen.
Und ja, also ich weiß gar nicht, wo die Jahresproduktion liegt,
aber wahrscheinlich eine Jahresproduktion wurde in zwei Wochen vernichtet. Ja.
Jetzt gerade sieht es so aus, als ob derzeit so gut wie gar keine SU-34 unterwegs
sind, weil die Piloten alle so, habt ihr sie noch alle?
Man muss ja auch bedenken, Flugzeuge, das ist das eine, also 150 Flugzeuge im
Bestand zu haben, von denen natürlich auch nicht alle fliegen können,
weil manche werden in Wartung, Reparatur und so weiter sein oder was weiß ich,
in was für einem Zustand die gerade sind.
Aber du hast natürlich noch die andere knappe Ressource von Piloten.
SO34 hat einen Pilot, SO35 hat glaube ich zwei.
Die sind ja dann in der Regel auch weg und die kannst du jetzt auch nicht so
ohne weiteres wiederherstellen.
Zumal natürlich so ein Pilotenkorps, die kennen sich natürlich alle auch untereinander.
Das heißt, die wissen auch, dass die anderen irgendwie gerade gekillt wurden.
Ja, das ist wohl eine eher kleine Community,
also eine überschaubare Community von ein paar hundert Leuten,
die alle miteinander geflogen sind irgendwann und sich auch kennen und ja.
Und die auch so einen gewissen Elite-Status haben in der,
also das ist nicht einfach jetzt so Cannon-Futter wie in der Infanterie,
wo im Prinzip sich die militärische Führung scheiß um die kümmert und interessiert,
sondern wenn die Piloten halt sagen,
Leute, so geht das hier nicht weiter, können nicht jetzt hier jeden Tag ein
System verlieren und Piloten dazu.
So, also derzeit macht es gerade so den Eindruck, dass die Russen sehr darüber
nachdenken, wie sie denn jetzt hier weiterkommen.
Das hat auch noch einen zweiten Grund, weil gerade als man so das Gefühl hatte,
oh wow, was geht denn jetzt hier ab, die Ukraine ist aber mal voll erfolgreich
hier mit dem Abschießen von Kampfjets,
haben sie gleich noch ein oder zwei obendrauf gelegt,
weil dann wurde berichtet, dass über dem Asowschen Meer, Das ist diese Meeresenklave
zwischen Krim und Russland.
Die quasi nur über diese Kertschstraße befahren werden kann.
Darüber wurde ein weiteres Flugzeug abgeschossen, beziehungsweise zwei fast.
Und in dem Fall handelt es sich um eine sogenannte A50. Und die A-50 ist ein
sogenanntes AVEX-System. Man kennt das vielleicht.
Das sind diese großen, auf Basis von Passagierflugzeugen umgebauten Flugzeuge,
die so eine riesige runde Antenne oben auf dem Dach drauf haben.
Ja, wobei mittlerweile die neun von den Amerikanern haben keine runde Antenne mehr,
sondern die haben mittlerweile flaches Radar,
Phased Array Radar, aber grundsätzlich genau sind die bekannt geworden durch
diese riesigen rotierenden Radare.
Und das Problem ist, dass Russland die nicht nachbauen kann und wohl acht bis
zehn Stück davon hatte, die Hälfte davon einsatzfähig.
Und was man nun auch gehört hat,
achso ja, vielleicht, dann kam ja der zweite Abschuss noch irgendwann dazu.
Also vor allem, es war ja erstmal ein Doppelabschluss. Sie haben die A50 erwischt,
die ist ins Meer gestürzt und parallel dazu, so ein Flugzeug wird auch noch
von einem zweiten Flugzeug begleitet, der Ilyushin 22,
IL 22, die quasi komplementär ist.
Das eine ist sozusagen das Radarsystem, das andere ist das Kommunikationssystem
mit den Truppen und man muss auch sagen, das ist dann eben auch eine extrem
hoch ausgebildete Besatzung.
Also diese A-50 hat 15 Leute an Bord, das sind alles top ausgebildete Kommunikationsingenieure
und in dieser IL-22, die noch dazu fliegt,
da hast du dann das ganze Militär, Generalstabspersonal, die dann entsprechende
strategische Entscheidungen machen.
Weil diese A-50 kann halt den gesamten Flugverkehr über dem Kriegsgebiet überwachen
und sieht halt auch alle ukrainischen Flugzeuge, die eigenen und koordiniert
damit sozusagen die ganze Geschichte.
Diese IL-22 wurde dann auch getroffen, die konnte dann immerhin noch landen,
da gab es dann zwar ein paar Tote, aber die war komplett durchlöchert und ist
im Wesentlichen Schrott und das war schon ein riesiger Verlust,
weil so ein Ding kostet halt irgendwie 350 Millionen US-Dollar, so eine A-50,
also das war allein schon mal eine halbe Milliarde mit einem Schuss und dann eine Woche später...
Zwei Wochen später ist dann tatsächlich noch eine zweite A-50 zerstört worden,
die dann sogar schon über russischem Gebiet, die ist gerade gestartet gewesen
bei Rostov und ist dann über Krasnodar abgestürzt und das ist dann auch schon
sehr weit weg vom Frontverlauf gewesen.
Wo sich alle schon gefragt haben, was hat die Ukraine denn jetzt hinbekommen.
Bei der ersten A-50 glaubt man eigentlich auch dran, dass das mit diesem Patriot-Trick
in irgendeiner Form geklappt hat, kann aber auch anders gewesen sein,
weil die Patriots hätte jetzt nicht ausgereicht, um diese andere A-50 abzuschießen.
Und hier wird wohl gemunkelt, dass die Ukraine so modifizierte S-200-Raketen hat,
also alte russische Luftabwehr-Raketen, die sie in so Langstrecken-Drohnen umgebaut
bekommen haben und damit es geschafft haben,
diese A-50 zu zerstören.
Das heißt von vielleicht, und da weiß man es jetzt nicht so ganz genau,
die Schätzungen, die ich gelesen habe, ist von, es gibt nur zwei,
die wirklich gut funktionieren oder vielleicht sind es auch vier und insgesamt gab es mal 14,
aber davon sind vielleicht bestenfalls sieben noch benutzbar.
Also ich habe da alles gehört, sodass ich irgendwie keine Ahnung habe,
was davon stimmt, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine knappe Ressource und da kann
man auch davon ausgehen, dass mittlerweile keine mehr fliegt.
Also es ist wohl jetzt schon seit Wochen keine mehr im Einsatz gewesen.
Das beobachten ja die Amerikaner über dem Schwarzen Meer auch sehr genau, was da lang fliegt.
Mit anderen Worten, die Ukraine hat es jetzt geschafft,
sowohl alle Kampfjets mit Gleitbombs irgendwie auf Hold zu setzen,
als auch die komplette Luftüberwachungsinfrastruktur signifikant zu stören,
weil sozusagen das Top-Gerät, was sie überhaupt in ihrem Arsenal haben,
entweder schon komplett zerstört ist oder zumindest so weit in sich bedroht
sieht, dass sie sich derzeit noch nicht mal trauen, damit rauszufliegen.
Ja, also das Interessante ist, dass jetzt sowohl das russische System, also die S-200,
hat interessanterweise eine größere Reichweite als die neuen,
neueren S-300 und S-400 Systeme.
Und ähnlich ist es auch mit den Patriot-Systemen, dass die älteren, so Pac-2-Systeme.
Auch eine größere Reichweite haben, beziehungsweise geeigneter sind für den
Einsatzzweck als der modernste Kram, den die da haben.
Und ja, war schon bemerkenswert.
Wobei, was ich auch gehört habe jetzt von einer Analyse von dem Abschuss,
dass sich da auch bemerkbar macht,
dass offenbar Mangel an erfahrenem Personal auch dazu geführt hat,
dass die letzte A50 auch abgeschossen werden konnte.
Weil, was sie nämlich gemacht haben, als sie bemerkt haben, dass sie jetzt vom
Radar beleuchtet werden,
war, dass sie dann erst angefangen haben, so Täuschkörper auszuwerfen.
Also sowohl Infrarot als auch dann Flares.
Aber sind dann in den Steigflug übergegangen, um zu versuchen,
der Rakete zu entkommen.
Während ich hörte, eigentlich sollte man versuchen,
so tief wie möglich runterzugehen, um quasi unter den Radarhorizont zu kommen.
Aber sie sind stattdessen halt höher gegangen und das war wohl der Fehler und
haben wohl die Täuschkörper dann auch zu früh ausgestoßen.
Das waren wohl so ein bisschen so die Dinger, dass wohl offenbar sie ja auch
nicht optimal reagiert haben auf den Angriff.
So das kam wohl mit dazu, aber gut.
Ich war jetzt nicht dabei, aber das ist zumindest so eine Analyse gewesen,
dass sich Leute gewundert haben aus den Filmaufnahmen.
Da gab es ja dann welche von dem Abschluss von der zweiten Apex.
Das bestätigt das schon in etwa, ja.
Ja, und sie haben wohl jetzt tatsächlich nur noch im Moment eine einsatzfähige A10,
um sämtliche Landesgrenzen abzudecken.
Und die trauen sie sich auch nicht im Moment einzusetzen. Okay.
Eine. Ja, wie gesagt, verschiedene Schätzungen gehört.
Das ist halt so, die können halt nie alle wirklich gerade einsatzfähig sein,
weil man einfach Wartungsintervalle hat.
Ja, ich meine die andere Sache.
Eine ist ja auch schon mal auf dem Boden beschädigt worden bei so einem Guerilla-Angriff.
Ja, ich meine, eine Sache, weshalb aber die,
so, hat sie sich halt gewundert, warum doch noch so viel jetzt von der russischen
Luftwaffe unterwegs ist oder war vor den Abschüssen.
Jetzt, weil man eigentlich damit gerechnet hatte,
dass deutlich mehr von den russischen Flugzeugen eigentlich gewartet werden
müssten, so laut Handbuch.
Aber was dann dazu kam, dass die Russen sich einfach um die Handbücher dann
nicht wirklich geschert haben,
sondern klar, ist halt so beim Auto auch, wenn du eigentlich alle 30.000 Kilometer
einen Ölwechsel machen musst, dann geht der Motor auch nicht gleich kaputt.
Und so, wenn du jetzt einfach länger fährst und so, so ähnlich war das dann
auch bei den Fliegern, dass sie einfach gesagt haben, ja, wir haben jetzt keine
Zeit oder keine Möglichkeit,
wir fliegen jetzt einfach.
Was dann wiederum dazu geführt hat, auch zu einer deutlich gestiegenen Zahl
von Unfällen aufgrund von technischen Versagen. Also da sind auch...
Jetzt ich glaube im letzten Jahr knapp einen Dutzend Flugzeuge ohne Feindeinwirkung
abgestürzt auf russischer Seite und da geht man davon aus, dass das daran liegt,
dass sie eben einfach die Wartungsintervalle nicht mehr einhalten,
sondern die Dinger so lange fliegen, wie sie können. Genau.
Ein Problem, was auch die zivile Luftfahrt betrifft, da können wir noch drauf.
Einen Abschluss wollte ich dann auch nochmal erwähnen, weil der dann auch wieder
Teil dieser russischen Propaganda geworden ist auf eine ganz interessante Art und Weise.
Und man merkt auch immer wieder sehr schnell, wie in diesem Krieg,
wenn die Russen irgendeine krasse Behauptung machen,
dass das dann insbesondere von deutschen Medien, aber auch generell im Westen,
schnell als Narrativ in der ersten Meldung übernommen wird und es dann schwierig
ist, das noch in irgendeiner Form wieder klarzustellen.
Und zwar gab es einen Absturz einer IL-76, das ist so ein Transportflugzeug,
größerer Bauart, mit dem die Russen vor allem Waffen transportieren.
Bei Belgorod. Belgorod ist so eine russische Stadt nördlich der ukrainischen
Grenze, also dabei bei Kiv quasi grob zwischen Kiv und Kharkiv.
Auch ein wichtiger logistischer Hub für den Krieg,
ganz am Anfang sowieso, aber mittlerweile auch immer noch und naja,
dieses Flugzeug ist halt runtergefallen und wurde halt irgendwie zerstört und
offensichtlich wurde es irgendwie Irgendwie abgeschossen.
Und Russland war dann relativ schnell damit zu behaupten, ja in diesem Flugzeug
hätten sich ja die ukrainischen Gefangenen von ihnen aufgehalten,
die sie eigentlich gerade im Rahmen eines Gefangenenaustausches austauschen wollten.
Aber jetzt habt ihr ja leider unser Flugzeug abgeschossen, sorry,
tut uns sehr leid, sind jetzt alle tot.
Ja, stellt sich raus, die Story, naja, die hatte so ihre Mängel, sagen wir es mal so.
Einerseits hat Russland behauptet, sie hätten jetzt dieses Flugzeug,
wäre gerade auf dem Anflug nach Belgorod gewesen, um eben diesen Gefangenaustausch zu machen.
Tatsächlich befand sich aber das Flugzeug nach Auswertung von Bildmaterial genau
in die gegensätzliche Richtung unterwegs und war also eigentlich eher in Richtung
eines Airfields, wo man weiß,
dass von dort Flugzeuge starten, unterwegs.
Außerdem haben sie keine Beobachter hingelassen.
Es gab Fotos dann, die noch veröffentlicht wurden von der Absturzstelle.
Da war halt nirgendwo überhaupt irgendwelche Leichen zu sehen.
Wenn also wirklich hunderte von Gefangenen drin gewesen sein sollen,
dann hätte man die ja auch dann finden müssen und auch zeigen können.
Da gab es nie passende Bilder und es gab noch diverse andere Indizien,
also die vollkommen gegen diese These sprachen.
Und ganz unabhängig davon ist Russland für die Sicherheit der Gefangenen verantwortlich.
Also du kannst jetzt auch nicht einfach sagen, ja hier,
du kannst nicht einfach mit Gefangenen in der Nähe von der Front rumfliegen
und drauf warten, bis das Flugzeug abgeschossen wird und dann sagen, ah hier, hier, hier.
Also so funktioniert es halt auch nicht.
Und bei solchen Gefangenenaustauschen und so funktioniert es auch so,
dass man dann eben vorher vereinbart,
wann und wie sie jetzt da an den Austauschpunkt gebracht werden,
um eben genau zu verhindern, dass so etwas passiert.
Also selbst wenn es so gewesen wäre, dass dort sich Gefangene drin befunden
hätten, wäre es trotzdem ein russisches Kriegsverbrechen gewesen.
Ja, dazu kommt noch, dass sie dann, also vor allem bei solchen Gefangenaustauschen
ist es vollkommen unüblich, dass Gefangene überhaupt mit Flugzeugen transportiert
werden. Also sie sind dann bestenfalls mit dem Zug oder mit dem Bus unterwegs,
aber definitiv nicht mit dem Flugzeug.
Und die Absurditäten nahmen dann auch kein Ende.
Dann kam natürlich auch das russische Fernsehen dann zur Hilfe und hier diese,
wie heißt nochmal diese Troller, diese Chefin von Russia Today,
die hat dann halt auch noch so eine Liste veröffentlicht.
Ja, hier sind die Namen der ganzen ukrainischen Soldaten, die da an Bord waren.
Und schon dieser Zettel, den sie da veröffentlicht hatte, da stand dann nicht drauf...
Was weiß ich, offizielle Liste der Personen, die auf diesem Flug sind,
sondern da stand drüber, die bei diesem Flug ums Leben gekommen sind.
Also es war kein Dokument, was so vorher hätte existieren können,
sondern definitiv ein Dokument, was nachher erstellt wurde.
Das war sozusagen, das sah man dem Dokument schon selber an,
was sie veröffentlicht haben. Also vollkommen absurd, dass das für irgendetwas
irgendein Beleg sein soll.
Und dann gab es auch noch auch diverse Meldungen, da weiß ich aber nicht,
ob das bestätigt wurde, dass viele der Namen, die da drauf waren,
teilweise Gefangene waren, die schon längst wieder in die Ukraine zurückgekehrt sind.
Margareta Simonian, übrigens, die du meintest. Ja, genau.
Also die Propaganda ist auch teilweise wirklich so absurd und plump,
man fasst sich nur noch an den Kopf.
Aber das hat mich dann halt besonders geärgert, weil natürlich dann sofort Spiegel
und alle irgendwie in Deutschland so ja, Ukraine hat Flugzeug mit Gefangenen
abgeschossen, sagt Russland.
Aber das war dann so die Meldung und wenn das dann erstmal so raus ist,
also Leute, da berichtet man drüber und wenn man,
gesicherte Faktenlage hat, dass das, was Russland sagt, auch mal stimmt,
was meistens nicht der Fall ist, dann kann man das irgendwie bringen, aber das ist,
ja, ich mach das fertig.
Gut, also kurz gesagt, der Luftkrieg, den die Ukraine gegen die Russen führt,
war sehr erfolgreich in den letzten Monaten und befindet sich eigentlich gerade so an seinem Peak.
Wir haben also wirklich an der Stelle Erfolge des ukrainischen Militärs gesehen,
die dazu geführt haben, dass die Russen gerade sehr verstört sind.
Die wissen nicht, wie sie jetzt gerade ihre Kampfflugzeuge überhaupt noch sicher
an der Grenze operieren lassen können.
Sie haben keinen großen Überblick mehr durch ihre A-50-Systeme.
Also da ist gerade alles ganz schön in Tumäul und es ist nicht klar,
wie sie aus der Situation wieder rauskommen.
Man kann eigentlich feststellen, dass die russische Luftwaffe,
dass die im Moment weitgehend neutralisiert ist.
Die trauen sich nicht mehr in die Nähe der Front.
Aber sie ist auch nicht kriegsentscheidend. Das ist der andere Punkt.
Also auch bisher, selbst wenn sie am Fliegen waren, es war entscheidend zu dem
Zeitpunkt, als die Ukraine ihre Offensive versucht hat.
Da hätte man eigentlich die Situation gebraucht, die jetzt eingetreten ist.
Aber so nach Einschätzung von Justin Bronk ist es so, dass bei der Situation,
wie sie jetzt herrscht mit eben dichter Flugabwehr,
die Luftwaffe, weder die russische noch die ukrainische, wenn jetzt F-16 kommen,
ist in der Lage, einen kriegsentscheidenden Beitrag zu leisten.
Klar ist es ein Vor- oder gewisser Vorteil oder Nachteil, aber das bringt nicht
die Wende, sondern die passiert trotzdem am Boden,
weil keine Seite wirklich jetzt allzu viel Unterstützung für den direkten Bodenkampf liefern kann.
So, das ist zumindest Justin Broncs Einstellung, aber ja.
Also zumindest ist das derzeit so. Also F-16, da kommen wir ja noch drauf.
Also wenn dann von Flugzeugen entsprechende Missiles gestartet werden können,
die dann vielleicht dieser Kerchbrücke ein Ende bereiten, dann sieht das schon
wieder anders aus. Aber das schieben wir nochmal ein bisschen nach hinten.
Lass uns mal auf einen anderen Punkt kommen, über den auch immer wieder so am
Rande berichtet wurde, der aber tatsächlich im Rahmen des Kriegs eine interessante
Note ist und das ist der sogenannte Dnipro Bridgehead.
Das ist also ein Vorstoß der Ukraine, da hatten wir auch schon mehrfach von
berichtet, dass es den gibt und dass der irgendwie auch immer noch existiert.
Das ist so ein sanfter Vorstoß über den Fluss bei Kherson, bei der Stadt Kherson,
primär in einen kleinen Ort namens Krinki, wo die Ukrainer sich jetzt schon
seit Monaten festgesetzt haben.
Und das ist, sagen wir mal jetzt rein militärisch von der Dimension her sehr überschaubar.
Da sind vielleicht ein paar hundert Soldaten, die ein wenige Quadratkilometer
großes Gebiet kontrolliert bekommen.
Kommen, aber die ganze Geschichte ist da unten für die Russen mehr als ärgerlich,
weil auf der einen Seite wollen sie dort keine großen Ressourcen,
akkumulieren, weil sie die ja gerade wie blöde in Avtivka und an der Ostfront.
Zum Einsatz bringen.
Auf der anderen Seite haben sie mit den Truppen, mit denen sie versuchen, diesem Bridgehead.
Auszutreten, auch so ihre liebe Mühe, weil die Situation ja die Die ist,
dass das Nordufer, also die rechte Seite des Flusses, die ja ukrainisch jetzt
kontrolliert ist, deutlich höher liegt als eben dieses Südufer.
Und von daher die Ukraine das wunderbar mit ihrer Artillerie abdecken kann.
Dazu haben sie dort eine Drohnenarmee am Start, die extrem ausgeprägt ist,
sprich alle Vorstöße der Russen diesen Bridget zu bekämpfen werden sehr gut
beobachtet und können sehr gut bekämpft werden.
Und das geht jetzt eben schon seit längerem.
Jetzt im Winter haben sie gerade das schlechte Wetter auch benutzt,
um diesen Bridgehead zu stabilisieren, weil es dann sehr neblig ist über dem Fluss.
Das heißt, dort hatten auch dann die Russen wenig Chancen, die Ukrainer dabei
zu beobachten, wie sie mit Booten rübersetzten und das war dann sozusagen nochmal
die Möglichkeit, das zu verstärken.
Ja und da tobt einfach gerade ein extremer Drohnenkrieg und das ist halt einfach so ein Ding,
von dem man immer noch nicht genau weiß, ob die Ukraine in der Lage ist,
dort nochmal irgendwas draus zu machen oder ob das einfach nur gehalten wird,
um die Russen da unten busy zu halten.
Das ist ja auch so ein Teil der allgemeinen Taktik, keep your enemy busy,
dass sie nie so genau wissen, wo geht es jetzt als nächstes los und von daher
ist das ein interessantes militärisches Detail, dass sie in der Lage sind,
diesen Bereich immer noch zu halten.
Ja, ich glaube ja auch Fixing-Attacks, wenn man angreift, um die gegnerischen Truppen dort zu halten,
wo sie gerade sind und zu verhindern, dass sie an andere Teile der Front dann wechseln.
Und in jedem Fall ist es schon ein bisschen eine Blamage für die Russen an der
Stelle, dass es ihnen nicht gelingt,
da das Ufer wirklich frei von ukrainischen Truppen zu halten.
So, aber ja, trotz auch mehrerer Versuche dort die rauszukriegen,
aber die scheinen bisher alle gescheitert zu sein.
Das hat ja dann auch mindestens ein Kommandeur sein Kommando gekostet,
aber der neue Kommandeur konnte jetzt auch nicht viel ausrichten, offenbar.
Genau. Und auch hier spielen wieder die, der Luftkrieg eine Rolle.
Also zuletzt haben sie es halt auch wieder versucht mit Gleitbombs zu erledigen, das Thema.
Aber das waren ja diese ersten drei SU-34, die da drauf gegangen sind,
die waren halt genau da unten im Angriff.
Und ja, das war es dann mit diesen SU-34. Also auch an der Stelle ist so ein
Bridgehead dann eben auch so ein Magnet für eben diese Angriffe.
Also oft sind diese Präsenzen dann auch so, ja so,
Eine Falle einfach so nach dem Motto, ja hier,
das nervt euch, dann geht doch mal dagegen vor und dann gehen sie dagegen vor
und werden dann hinterrücks bestraft, weil sie halt einfach dort auf einmal
ihre Kampfflugzeuge zum Einsatz bringen wollen,
aber dann eben schon eine perfekt aufgestellte Radarfalle auf sie wartet und
dann war es das eben mit diesen Kampfflugzeugen.
Also es ist immer wieder interessant zu sehen, wie die Geschicke da hin und
her gehen und wie auf jede Falle mit einer anderen Falle reagiert wird.
Also die Strategien, die hier überall zum Einsatz kommen, sind schon wirklich
teilweise sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, aber man muss dann auch dazu sagen, dass auch die Russen nicht jetzt dumm
sind, sondern auch reagieren und sich anpassen und auch Dinge getan haben,
die man vor allem im Westen nicht erwartet hatte.
Also dass auch von westlicher Seite da Fehleinschätzungen waren,
wie zum Beispiel, dass man dachte,
die hören jetzt auf zu fliegen, wenn jetzt eigentlich die Flugzeuge gewartet
werden müssen oder andere Dinge, die man nicht erwartet hatte.
Also insofern bei, ja, also auch auf russischer Seite irgendwie Licht und Schatten.
Definitiv, also zum Beispiel Electronic Warfare spielt eine große Rolle,
viele der Fahrzeuge sind mittlerweile mit solchen,
EW-Doms ausgestattet das ist sozusagen so ein Störsender,
der auf den Fahrzeugen drauf ist und wenn dann Kamikaze Drohnen anfliegen und
die letzten Meter gehen wollen dann werden sie von diesem Distortion Field sozusagen
gekillt, kann ich nachher auch nochmal was zu sagen, was da gerade so im Busch ist,
aber Aber jetzt müssen wir nochmal auf einen anderen Bereich eingehen,
der auch ein großer Erfolg ist für die Ukraine,
wenn nicht vielleicht sogar abgesehen von den abgeschossenen Flugzeugen fast der größte.
Und das haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, aber das ist dann eben munter
weitergegangen, bis eben vor ein paar Tagen sogar auch, nämlich der Seekrieg
im Schwarzen Meer rund um die Krim.
Das Schwarze Meer ist ja für die Ukraine sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig,
um den Seeweg für ihr Getreide von Odessa und den ganzen anderen Schwarzen Meerhäfen sicherzustellen.
Und während es ja letztes Jahr noch diese Vereinbarung gab zwischen den Russen
und einer internationalen Gemeinschaft vermittelt durch die Türkei,
dass eben dort so ein Korridor aufrechterhalten wird für diese Getreideschiffe,
damit einfach Afrika versorgt werden kann.
Dann mit Getreide zum Beispiel aus der Ukraine hat Russland das dann ja nach
ein paar Niederlagen im Seekrieg aufgekündigt und jetzt hat die Ukraine einfach
Schritt für Schritt sich dort einfach einen Korridor freigekämpft,
dadurch dass sie eben den Russen einfach keinen Zugang mehr zum Meer gestattet haben,
weil sie schlicht und ergreifend alle ihre relevanten Schiffe in diesem Bereich zerstört haben.
Das fing ganz zu Beginn an mit der Moskwa, dem größten, wichtigsten Schiff der
Schwarzmeerflotte, sozusagen die Hauptkommandozentrale, die am Anfang versucht
hat, da diese Schlangeninsel zu nehmen,
wo es dann diesen schönen Russian Warship Go Fuck Yourself Ausruf gab des ukrainischen
Soldaten, der gesagt hat, so einen Scheiß werden wir machen und das Ergeben
hier irgendwie geht auch weg.
Das ist so ein geflügeltes Wort mittlerweile in der Ukraine.
Und so ging es dann ja auch munter weiter.
Und in den letzten Monaten gab es also so diverse große Erfolge.
Ich glaube, wir hatten zuletzt hier noch gesprochen von diesem Storm Shadow
Angriff auf den Hafen in Sevastopol, wo dann gleichzeitig ein Schiff und ein
U-Boot im Trockendock zerstört wurde.
Aber seitdem ging es halt munter weiter, vor allem weil die Ukraine ihre Armee
von Seedrohnen ausgebaut hat.
Es gibt dann mittlerweile schon verschiedenste Generationen,
wir sind mittlerweile schon bei der fünften Generation. Das sind im Prinzip
so kleine Sportboote, die eben sehr viel Sprengstoff an Bord haben und halt
einfach kamikaze mäßig in irgendwas reinfahren und dann explodieren.
Und während es am Anfang noch so eher Nadelstiche waren, ist es jetzt mittlerweile
eine ganze Armada, die dort unterwegs ist und in zunehmendem Maße den Russen da Probleme bereitet.
Mitte November wurden allein schon so zwei Landungsschiffe zerstört in einem
Krimhafen in Tschernomorskoye,
das ist da etwas im Nordwesten der Krim.
Dann Ende Dezember haben sie das Landungsschiff der Novo Charkassk mit Storm
Shadow Angriffen zerstört.
Das sind diese Strategien, die wir vorhin schon auch benannt haben,
dass sie also verschiedene Drohnenkombinationen losschicken,
die Luftabwehr ausspionieren bzw.
Leerschießen lassen, damit dann eben die dicken Missiles durchkommen.
Und da wurde dann halt unter anderem diese Novo Cherkassk im Hafen von Feodosia,
das ist so im Süden der Krim, zerstört.
Beziehungsweise an einem Hafen auch direkt neben der Krimbrücke.
Ne, ist das Feodosia? Ne, warte mal, jetzt komme ich glaube ich gerade durcheinander
mit den Namen. Ist Feodosia das Ding direkt bei der Kerchbrücke oder ist das der andere?
Ne, das ist der andere, genau. Also es gab einen direkt bei der Kerchbrücke
einen Angriff und es gab einen in Feodosia und auf jeden Fall größere Schiffe
der Schwarzmeerflotte wurden zerstört.
Das waren halt teilweise diese Landungsschiffe.
Landungsschiffe klingt jetzt so ein bisschen nach Soldaten landen am Strand
und übernehmen sozusagen das Land.
Dafür kann man sie auch benutzen, aber da das ja alles vermint ist,
ist das derzeit eh keine Option.
Aber das sind ganz wichtige Transportschiffe für die Russen,
also mit denen sie Waffen transportieren.
Und diese Nouveau Tchaikovsky, der wurde auch nachgesagt, dass sie wohl zu dem
Zeitpunkt der Zerstörung auch komplett mit Drohnen, mit Shahed-Drohnen vollgeladen war.
Kann man nicht bestätigen, aber das war sozusagen die Einschätzung der Beobachter
vor Ort. Auf jeden Fall ist das Schiff komplett zerstört worden.
Gleich noch zwei kleinere Schiffe, die daneben standen, gleich noch mit zerstört
wurden durch die sekundären Explosionen und noch ein paar Hallen.
Also da geht es richtig ab und diese Landesschiffe sind halt einfach für den
ganzen Transport von Munition zusätzlich zu den Zugverbindungen einfach extrem wichtig.
Ja, und dabei sind dann auch, das wurde jetzt bestätigt, eine ganze Menge von
diesen ADM-160 MOLs, also Miniatur-Air-Launch-Decoys zum Einsatz gekommen.
Das sind diese Drohnen, die gar keine Waffen an Bord haben,
sondern dann elektronische Signaturen ausstoßen und sagen können,
okay, tu jetzt so, als fährst du dieses Flugzeug oder diese Cruise Missile oder
so und in Wirklichkeit verschwendet dann die Abwehr das,
ihre Kapazitäten dann eben auf diese Decoys, auf diese Tosch-Flugkörper und
die waren da wohl massiv im Einsatz und ja, da kommen wir auch später drauf,
das war unter anderem eine Information,
die auch aus diesem geleakten Generalsgespräch dann man entnehmen konnte.
Genau, es ging dann munter weiter. Im Februar musste dann eine große Korvette,
die Ivano-Vets, dran glauben.
Das waren dann auch schon so die etwas spektakuläreren Bilder, weil mittlerweile,
also im Februar war es dann schon so, dass eben so wie so ein Wolfsrudel diese
Drohnenboote auf die großen Schiffe losgingen.
Das heißt, gleichzeitige Attacke mehrerer Boote von verschiedenen Seiten,
wo dann sozusagen eine es geschafft hat, schon mal ein Loch in die Seite reinzusprengen
und dann kommt gleich die nächste und fährt einfach nochmal in dasselbe Loch
auch nochmal mit rein, während andere das wiederum filmen, das Ganze bei Nacht.
Das heißt, man hat diese Videos gesehen, wie wirklich so bumm bumm eins nach
dem anderen in diese Schiffe reingefahren ist, das Loch immer größer wurde,
immer mehr sekundäre Explosionen waren, bis dann wirklich großes Tatar,
am Schluss wirklich das Schiff sich aufrichtete und blubber blubber blubb irgendwie
komplett im Meer versank.
Also das war schon irgendwie ziemlich krass,
das war dann Anfang Februar, dann wurden ein paar kleinere Missileboots zerstört
und man hat sich noch ausreichend über die bisherigen Erfolge gefreut,
dann Mitte Februar am 14.
Gab es dann wieder ein Landesschiff, die Cäsar Kurnikow.
Die auch wieder durch so eine Drohnenattacke zerstört wurde und jetzt gerade vor zwei Tagen am 5.
März eine weitere Korvette, die Sergej Kotov, wieder in Feodosia,
wieder versenkt worden auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise.
Das war jetzt übrigens einerseits das neueste Schiff überhaupt im Arsenal der Schwarzmeerflotte,
die glaube ich 2021 überhaupt erst zu Wasser gegangen ist und die im Übrigen
auch genau für die Verteidigung gegen viele kleine Boote optimiert war.
Das hat ja super funktioniert.
Und ich glaube, die war zur Verteidigung der Kerschbrücke eingesetzt.
Ja, gedacht.
Gedacht, ja, die war davor und deswegen gab es auch Vermutungen,
ob die Drohnen nicht eigentlich auf dem Weg zur Kerschbrücke waren und dann
eben auf dieses Schiff gestoßen und gesagt haben,
ach dann nehmen wir doch jetzt das Schiff erstmal aus dem Spiel hier und kommen dann später wieder so.
Also das ist natürlich dann auch ein Riesenproblem, wenn die Russen jetzt nicht
mal mehr in der Lage sind,
dort Schiffe einzusetzen, um die Brücke zu verteidigen, die dann versenkt werden.
Also ich glaube, das sind alles schon vorbereitende Maßnahmen.
Die Ukraine ist einfach dabei, diese Schwarzmeerflotte so weit zu reduzieren,
wie es nur irgendwie geht.
Es ist jetzt schon bereits ein Fünftel der gesamten Flotte.
Zerstört worden und ich glaube nach Tonnage ist es glaube ich sogar schon ein
bisschen mehr, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau.
Also signifikante Reduktion und außerdem ähnlich wie bei den Flugzeugen ist
es eben so, dass eben ein Großteil der Schiffe derzeit einfach überhaupt nicht im Einsatz ist.
Gerade weil sie eben befürchten, dass kaum dass sie auf dem Wasser sind,
dass sie dann eben von diesen aquatischen Wolfsrudeln weggemeuchelt werden.
Also das ist ein echtes Problem für die Russen. Das muss man einfach so sehen.
Die haben da gar nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, diesem asymmetrischen Krieg etwas entgegenzusetzen.
Während sie halt bei diesen Luftdrohnen mittlerweile auch gut in der Produktion
sind und da versuchen halt mitzuhalten und sicherlich auch von China hintenrum
ausreichend beliefert werden, ist das halt bei den Schiffen gar nicht so einfach.
Weil diese Drohnen, Bootsdrohnen, also Russland könnte vielleicht theoretisch
jetzt auch solche Bootsdrohnen entwickeln, nur die Ukraine hat ja überhaupt gar keine Navy mehr.
Also es gibt da sozusagen gar nichts, was sie angreifen können.
Sie haben einfach nur diese großen, super teuren, schweren Kriegsschiffe,
die theoretisch verhindern können, dass die Ukraine im Schwarzen Meer Handel treibt.
Nur kaum, dass sie die zu Wasser lassen, kommen halt diese Boote und ballern sie weg.
Und außerdem Verteidigung der Brücke wird jetzt in zunehmendem Maße immer schwerer.
Also ich denke mal, wir werden sehen, dass das noch so weitergeht und kann nur
hoffen, dass es der Ukraine gelingt im Prinzip alles platt zu machen, was irgendwie da ist.
Es müssen ja auch immer wieder Schiffe in die Trockendocks rein,
also wenn es dann gelingt mal wieder genug Missiles zusammen zu bekommen.
Dann ist also mit Storm Shadows kann man also die Dinger während der Wartung
problemlos niedermachen.
Die Russen haben keine Möglichkeit neue Schiffe ins Schwarze Meer zu bekommen.
Durch die Istanbul Strait geht das halt eh nicht und über ihre Flüsse können
sie nur kleinere Schiffe reinmachen.
Sie haben da sozusagen auch wenig, was sie da hinschicken könnten.
Also die Russen verlieren den Zugriff auf dieses Meer, das muss man einfach mal so sagen.
Durch die Schwächung der Luftverteidigung, durch die Schwächung der Schwarzmeerflotte
und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es durch irgendeinen kombinierten Angriff möglich wird,
vielleicht diese Kerchbrücke außer Betrieb zu nehmen, steigt.
Ist noch nicht, wir sind noch nicht da, aber sie steigt.
Ja, wobei mittlerweile das sozusagen durch die Landbrücke, das jetzt auch nicht
kriegsentscheidend wäre,
aber natürlich wieder, es ist natürlich, wir hatten das Thema Angriff auf die
Kertschbrücke ja auch in einer Sendung ausführlich behandelt,
das ist natürlich Putins ganzer Stolz.
Also das ist halt seine Brücke, er ist ja persönlich rübergefahren bei der Eröffnung und so und insofern.
Wenn die Brücke fällt, wäre das auch ein Moralboost in der Ukraine wie kaum irgendetwas anderes.
Und Landbrücke, ja meinetwegen, aber diese Landbrücke ist halt einfach mal trotzdem
viele tausende Kilometer länger, als mal eben darüber zu fahren.
Also die Versorgung der Krim und die Aufrechterhaltung der Krim,
die ja sich durch die Zerstörung des Niprodams auch sozusagen von der Wasserversorgung
abgetrennt hat, selber ohne Not,
die wird in zunehmendem Maße schwieriger.
Also das wird einfach schwierig sein, die Krim überhaupt am Leben zu erhalten.
Ich meine, da leben auch Menschen und die müssen irgendwie auch versorgt werden
und da gibt es halt im Norden nicht so viele Versorgungslinien und alles,
was an Versorgung da ist, geht eh in den Krieg.
Also das ist alles so einfach nicht, um das mit dem Seekrieg abzuschließen.
Russland versucht natürlich sich zu verteidigen, die Häfen werden mit entsprechenden
Absperrungen versehen, um diese Drohnen da irgendwie von ihren Häfen fernzuhalten,
aber das funktioniert alles nur so begrenzt.
Und solange die Schiffe auch nur in den Häfen sind, ist es der Ukraine vielleicht auch erstmal egal.
Also in den Häfen können sie sie mit Missiles zerstören und kaum dass sie rauskommen,
warten dann halt irgendwie diese Wolfsrudel.
Und dann hatte sich dann auch noch natürlich das Wetter gegen sie versporen
und hat dann einmal dieser Wintersturm,
hat da nicht nur diese Barrieren wurden ziemlich in Mitleidenschaft gezogen
oder teilweise weggeschwemmt,
Aber irgendwelche Leute sind auch auf die Idee gekommen,
an den ganzen Stränden Befestigungsstellungen auszuheben, weil sie wohl befürchteten,
dass, keine Ahnung, die Ukraine trotz keiner Schiffe dann dort irgendwelche
Landungsoperationen durchführen würde.
Und sie deswegen dort Gräben brauchen.
Die wurden natürlich auch alle dann weggespült, so jetzt im Winter.
Also da war so ein riesiger Wintersturm,
also es gab wirklich einen katastrophalen, superschweren Sturm im Schwarzen
Meer im Winter und das ging so parallel zu dieser größeren Schneefällen und
sehr niedrigen Temperaturen und das hat also die ganze Westflanke der Krim extrem
unter Beschlag genommen.
Ja, mit anderen Worten, die Getreideexportroute ist zwar vielleicht nicht super
sicher, aber zumindest existent.
Das Hauptproblem an der Stelle ist derzeit eigentlich gar kein militärisches Problem.
Also die Schiffe an sich sind sehr sicher, aber erzähl das mal den Redereien.
Also ich habe so aus Reda-Talk gehört, dass die halt einfach gerade alle Megaschiss
haben, da ihre Schiffe in irgendeiner Form zu verlieren.
Es ist auch wohl sehr, sehr schwierig nach wie vor überhaupt Mannschaften zusammenzustellen,
die bereit sind im Schwarzen Meer in den Einsatz zu gehen.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein Ding und dann hast du dann eben auch noch entsprechend
hohe Versicherungskosten, wenn du da wirklich was machen willst.
Also ist nicht alles super jetzt für die Ukraine,
aber sie arbeiten dran und mit jedem zerstörten Kriegsschiff der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte kommen sie ihrem Ziel dort wieder einen normalen Schiffsverkehr
aufrecht zu erhalten deutlich näher.
Und die Russen blockieren sich im Übrigen ihren Schiffsverkehr ins Asowsche
Meer natürlich dadurch, dass sie ihre Kehrsprücke so dicht machen,
weil sie müssen ja eigentlich auch noch Platz lassen für die eigenen Schiffe,
aber es wird ja dann auch nicht unbedingt einfacher.
Also diese ganze Logistik ist erschwert.
Ja, also insgesamt, unter dem Strich, führt das dazu, dass die eroberten Gebiete
für die Russen im Moment eher eine wirtschaftliche Last sind.
Also, dass sie bei Weitem die Kosten, die zu der Verteidigung aufgewendet werden
müssen, nicht einspielen können.
Und so sollte das auch bleiben, dass die Russen jetzt nicht auch noch allzu
viele Vorteile daraus ziehen, dass sie dort jetzt diese Gebiete besetzt halten.
Sondern da führt der Krieg eben dazu, dass sie auch Defizite produzieren dort.
Genau, gutes Stichwort. Defizite für die Russen erzeugen, das ist auch ein Teil
der weiteren Kriegsführung der Ukraine,
denn in den letzten Wochen und Monaten, insbesondere in den letzten Wochen,
sind die Angriffe auf russische Infrastruktur in Russland auch enorm angestiegen.
Das hat so verschiedene Ziele, unter anderem wurden immer mal wieder Flughäfen
angegriffen, die dann auch wegen dieser Drohnenangriffe teilweise geschlossen werden müssen.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht so eine unmittelbar große Auswirkung,
trägt aber immer mal wieder dazu bei, dass die Russen vielleicht auch mal merken,
dass sie sich gerade im Krieg befinden.
Dann gibt es diverse Angriffe auf Flugzeugfabriken,
Traktorfabriken, Waffen- und Munitionsfabriken mit Drohnen oder mit auch,
weiß man nicht so ganz genau, was dann immer so die Quelle ist dieser Explosionen,
die dort stattfinden und Brände, Heizkraftwerke, Stromumspannungswerke.
Also im Prinzip genau das, was Russland im letzten Winter mit der Ukraine veranstaltet hat.
Da schlägt die Ukraine jetzt zurück. Das haben sie auch ganz klar gesagt.
Wenn ihr unsere Infrastruktur angreift, dann ist eure auch nicht mehr so sicher.
Was aber wahrscheinlich noch viel problematischer ist, sind auf der einen Seite
Angriffe und Sabotageakte auf die russische Eisenbahninfrastruktur,
wobei da nicht immer ganz klar ist, ob das jetzt auch wirklich von der Ukraine
ausgelöste Aktionen sind im Hinterland oder ob hier vielleicht sogar inländische
Aktivitäten stattfinden von Widerstandsgruppen.
Bisschen schwer zu beurteilen natürlich.
Es gab eine Meldung eines Angriffs auf diesen Eisenbahntunnel in Severomysky.
Das ist ziemlich weit im Osten nahe der, also in Richtung China. China.
Das hat sich dann leider später als nicht so erfolgreich herausgestellt, wie es am Anfang klang.
Es gab wohl eine Explosion in einem Eisenbahntunnel und das Besondere an diesem
Eisenbahntunnel ist, dass er quasi ein Nadelöhr für die Versorgung mit Waren aus China ist.
Also das ist sozusagen die einzige Eisenbahnlinie, die schwere Lasten machen kann.
Es gibt noch eine zweite Route, die noch für den Personenverkehr genutzt wird,
aber für eine bestimmte Kategorie von Schwerlasten ist das wohl die einzige Eisenbahnroute.
Und wäre es zum Beispiel gelungen durch diese Explosion im Tunnel diesen Tunnel
zum Einsturz zu bringen oder so zu barrikadieren,
was weiß ich, wenn da irgendwie ein ganzer Zug vor sich hin schmilzt,
dann kriegst du den ja nicht von heute auf morgen wieder in Betrieb genommen.
Aber offensichtlich war die Explosion nicht so dramatisch, dass das für eine
längerfristige Sperrung gereicht hätte.
Ein paar Kilometer weiter ging es wohl auch nochmal gegen eine Brücke.
Ja, das war die auf der zweiten Strecke hatte man versucht, das war aber auch nicht so erfolgreich.
Diese Parallelstrecke, die du erwähnt hast.
War das wirklich die Parallelstrecke? Ich hatte das Gefühl, das wäre auf derselben
Linie gewesen. Ich hatte das mal so nachgeflogen.
Das erschien mir nur so 50 Kilometer weiter in die andere Richtung.
Also sie hatten sozusagen Tunnel und Brücke auf derselben Strecke gleichzeitig
getargetet und beides hat nicht so ganz so geklappt.
Ich glaube diese Parallelstrecke ist nicht so eine große Sorge,
weil es ging ja darum diese Waffenlieferungen aus Nordkorea damit zum Beispiel
auch in den Griff zu bekommen, weil da diese ganze Artillerie lang ging.
Also das war so die Vermutung, das hat nicht so funktioniert,
aber es gibt immer mal wieder kleinere Anschläge auf diese Umschaltboxen,
die sind wohl recht verwundbar im russischen Eisenbahnnetz.
Also es sind so Steuerkästen, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was die machen,
aber im Wesentlichen dafür die ganze Betriebslogistik erforderlich und wenn
man die in Brand setzt, dann kann das nachhaltige Probleme nach sich ziehen.
Ja, apropos fällt mir noch ein, was ich auch gehört hatte, ist,
dass jetzt aber die Lieferungen aus Nordkorea wohl zurückgegangen sein sollen.
Also entweder ist das Vereinbarte schon alles geliefert und es gibt nichts mehr
oder also jedenfalls ist es wohl nicht so,
dass das jetzt dort immer mehr geliefert wird,
sondern tendenziell wohl ist jetzt der Nachschub aus Nordkorea angeblich rückläufig.
Ja gut, also wir haben es zumindest probiert und...
Hat halt mal nicht so gut geklappt, aber insgesamt gibt es da schon krasse Auswirkungen.
In der letzten Zeit gab es auch noch ein anderes Ziel und da war die Ukraine
relativ erfolgreich und das hält auch nach wie vor an.
Es gibt nämlich diverse Drohnenangriffe auf Öl- und Gasproduktionsorte,
die vor allem für den Export wichtig sind.
Und so viele Exportstandorte hat Russland nämlich gar nicht,
weil obwohl ja Russland so ein riesiges Land ist, ist eigentlich ihr Zugang zum Meer sehr begrenzt.
Da gibt es den NATO Lake, also es gibt sozusagen die Möglichkeit über die Ostsee
was zu machen, das ist das eine.
Dann haben sie ihren Atom-U-Boot-Standort in Murmansk, der so der einzige eisfreie
Hafen da oben ist in der Polarregion.
Ja und Arkhangelsk ist glaube ich der Hauptumschlaghafen. Ein Freund von mir ist da öfter mal.
Ja ja auch da oben.
Arkhangelsk heißt das Ding glaube ich.
Da gab es jetzt noch keine Angriffe, aber es gibt zum Beispiel Gasproduktionsorte,
die wichtig sind bei St. Petersburg.
Da sind Drohnen hingekommen, was auch schon mal bemerkenswert ist,
weil das ja von der Ukraine aus sehr weit weg ist und man nicht genau weiß,
ob die jetzt wirklich aus der Ukraine kamen, weil die müssen ja dann sozusagen
einen Tag lang über die Russland geflogen sein, um dort einzuschlagen.
Dass die russische Luftabwehr da keine Antwort drauf hat, ist auch bemerkenswert.
Aber es gab auch noch Produktionsstätten direkt am Schwarzen Meer,
wo also auch noch verteilt wird.
Also all dieses ganze Öl und Gas, was aus dem Osten in den Westen geleitet wird,
muss ja dann auch irgendwo in Pipelines gehen, muss irgendwo auf Schiffe umgeladen
werden, wie es auch immer weiter transportiert wird.
Und genau diese neureigischen Punkte stehen derzeit im Mittelpunkt der Angriffe.
Ja und führen dann eben auch dazu teilweise, dass es an Diesel und Benzin fehlt
in manchen Gegenden von Russland.
Also dass die Tankstellen irgendwie leer sind, was man ja nur gerade bei Russland
erstmal nicht vermuten würde, dass sie eigentlich ja genug haben müssten.
Aber auch das wohl, gut, wahrscheinlich nicht in Moskau, aber so in anderen Gegenden, ja,
Ja, scheint sich das auch auszuwirken.
Genau. Ja, das bringt uns dann zu dem Thema der sonstigen Infrastrukturprobleme,
die Russland noch so hat.
Also selbst wenn die Ukraine keine Bombe drauf wirft, ist in den letzten Monaten
in Russland so einiges kaputt gegangen. Das hatte halt viele Gründe.
Ein Hauptgrund war ein super harter Winter in Russland.
Das war ja schon so ein bisschen absurd, wenn man so auf die Temperaturkartenverteilung geschaut hat.
Dann gab es so eine super heftige Zone von minus 20 Grad, die so mehr oder weniger
direkt an der russischen Grenze entlang und auch wirklich so an dem Frontverlauf lang lief.
Also überall wo Russen waren, war es einfach schweinekalt und überall sonst war es nur so okay kalt.
Und es gab also viele, viele, viele Orte, also fast ganz Russland lag wochenlang
unter so einer minus 20 Grad Kältefront.
Und naja, jetzt kann man ja sagen, gut, Russland hat ja genug von allem,
so Energie, Gas, Öl ist ja alles gar kein Problem.
Naja, das Problem ist nur, dass sie mittlerweile für diesen Krieg so viele Techniker,
Handwerker und Leute, die in der Lage sind, Panzer zu reparieren,
offenbar abgezogen haben,
dass ihnen einfach die Leute fehlen und dass die sonstige Infrastruktur auch
ohnehin schlecht gewartet wurde.
Und das führte dann dazu, dass also Wasserleitungen geplatzt sind,
dass einfach viele Russen auf einmal ohne Heizung dastanden,
weil einfach die Verteilungsinfrastruktur kaputt gegangen ist.
Es gab mehrere Städte, die also über Wochen bei minus 20 Grad einen Großteil
ihrer Einwohner überhaupt nicht mehr beheizen konnten.
Ja und da gab es dann auch so krasse Bilder aus Heizkraftwerken,
die dann eingefroren sind,
wo sie dann nicht nur, also nachdem sie es vielleicht geschafft haben,
dann die Leitung zu reparieren,
standen sie dann mit riesigen Heizlüftern oder Schweißgeräten und Brennern und
haben dann versucht, versucht, das Heizkraftwerk wieder aufzuhauen.
Und das Problem tatsächlich auch mit dem Fachkräftemangel, sag ich mal, liegt halt auch daran,
dass viele dieser qualifizierten Leute, die in der Lage sind,
Infrastruktur zu reparieren,
sehr lukrative Angebote gekriegt haben, haben das in den besetzten Gebieten,
in den neurussischen Gebieten, dort die Infrastruktur aufzubauen und zu reparieren,
die von Russland selbst überwiegend zerbombt wurde.
Und diese Leute fehlen natürlich jetzt überall.
Und dieser Winterschock, den haben sie offenbar nicht gut verkraftet. Und ja.
Besetzt ist.
Und bei jetzt dieses Wildberries, das ist ja dieses russische Amazon-Äquivalent
mit eben diesem riesen Lager, was da komplett abgebrannt ist,
da wurde kolportiert, dass das wahrscheinlich Brandstiftung durch Mitarbeiter gewesen ist.
Weil nämlich so, also üblich ist es so, dass so Firmen jetzt,
also an die Firmen wurde halt,
herangetreten und gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt Leute für die ROND,
gibt uns mal eine Liste von Leuten, die wir hier jetzt einziehen können und
was die Firmen dann aber üblicherweise machen ist, dass sie sich freikaufen
so, weil sie die Leute lieber Also weiter beschäftigen wollen.
Sie sagen dann, okay, aber irgendwie hier, nehmt lieber Geld,
aber wir brauchen die Leute.
Wildberries dagegen soll eben keinen solchen Deal gemacht haben,
sondern halt komplett die Leute an die Front geschickt haben und die eben nicht freigekauft.
Und das soll wohl dazu geführt haben, dass das bei einigen Mitarbeitern nicht
gut angekommen ist und die dann halt sich gesagt haben, naja,
dann brennen wir lieber hier alles ab,
wenn die sich sowieso nicht um uns kümmern.
Weiß man nicht genau, aber sowas habe ich auch gehört.
Komplett auf die Unterwäsche entkleiden müssen, um zu verhindern,
dass sie da jetzt irgendwie Dinge mitgehen lassen.
Wobei man sich dann fragt, warum eigentlich auch auf dem Weg dort rein.
Und ein Großteil sind auch weibliche Mitarbeiter.
Und da sagst du dann, wie die dann in Unterwäsche dort sitzen.
Und jetzt aber, als es gebrannt hat, wollte die Security die Leute erstmal nicht
rauslassen, ohne sie zu durchsuchen.
Während irgendwie das Ding in Flammen steht so, aber nicht, dass ihr irgendwie
jetzt noch irgendwas in der Tasche habt so und mitgeben lasst also,
das war irgendwie so eine ganz spezielle russische Geschichte das Land, ey.
Ja, so ganz nebenbei hat das Auswirkungen auf Lebensmittelpreise, die steigen.
Es gibt so eine Eierkrise, die Preise von Eiern sind wohl enorm gestiegen.
Da musste sogar schon Putin im Fernsehen sich zu äußern und versprechen, dass es besser wird.
Ist aber nicht besser geworden, soweit ich das weiß. Das hat einfach was damit
zu tun, dass in zunehmendem Maße einfach der Anteil der Importe für Lebensmittel
steigt, durch die Belastung, durch den Krieg.
Also auch das zählt hier noch mit rein.
Ja, da gibt es auch die These zu der Eierkrise, wie es dazu gekommen ist,
dass dadurch, dass alles sich verteuert hat.
Geflügelfleisch ist so die billigste Proteinquelle.
Und wenn jetzt die Reise anziehen,
stieg halt erst der Bedarf an Hühnerfleisch,
was dazu führte, dass dann wohl in größerer Zahl dann Geflügel eben auch geschlachtet wurde.
Was dann möglicherweise im Nachgang dann auch dazu geführt hat,
dass dann die Eier knapp wurden.
Und es soll wohl auch so sein, gut dazu ist es bisher nicht gekommen,
aber dass genau dieser Effekt, der ist wohl bekannt,
dass wenn plötzlich der Konsum an Geflügelfleisch in die Höhe geht,
dass das Vorboten von Nahrungsmittelknappheit und Krisen sind.
Das sind sozusagen so Frühindikatoren, dass da irgendwas nicht koscher ist und
dass da möglicherweise Schlimmeres nachkommen könnte.
Aber schauen wir mal. Ich meine, die Russen passen sich halt auch an. Aber ja.
Was auch nicht so gut funktioniert, ist wohl die Flugzeugindustrie.
Da wird schon gemunkelt, dass die auch ihrem Ende sich nähert.
Wir hatten ja schon zu Beginn des Krieges die Situation, dass Russland einen Großteil der,
eigentlich nur geleasten oder gemieteten Passagierflugzeuge von Airbus und Boeing
einfach so einbehalten hat, so nach dem Motto, uns doch egal,
dass ihr die jetzt zurückhaben wollt, einfach geklaut hat so,
aber es gibt ja nach wie vor keinen Service und es gibt keine Versorgung mit
entsprechenden Ersatzteilen.
Und naja, auch durch die sonstigen Belastungen kommt es also in zunehmendem
Maße zu Ausfällen und Zwischenfällen im Luftverkehr.
Es gab verschiedene Berichte, dass Flugzeuge einfach nirgendwo in Not landen
und weil sie dann auch nicht wieder wegkommen,
da seit Monaten rumstehen, weil man einfach keine Möglichkeiten hat,
die da wieder wegzubekommen, weil die halt einfach irgendwo auf irgendeiner
Landstraße gelandet sind und da keine Infrastruktur existiert,
um die wieder zu starten.
Ja, die eine A320, die da auf dem Feld notgelandet ist, wo sie dann erst meinten,
ja, die fliegen sie da wieder raus.
Aber das ist wohl nicht gelungen. Sie haben da einen Zaun drumherum gezogen,
damit da keine Plünderer jetzt Teile abmontieren. kennt Reifen und dies und das.
Also haben sie da Wachschutz und einen Zaun drum gebaut und dann haben sie nach
vier Monaten oder so festgestellt, dass sie niemanden haben oder dass es nicht
praktikabel ist, das Ding da,
rauszufliegen und wollen das jetzt zerlegen und dann in Einzelteilen davon tragen.
Ja, und ich meine, das wird ja auch nicht besser dadurch, dass es da irgendwie
vier Monate hätte ungewartet irgendwo in der Pampa steht.
Also es gab wohl allein im Januar so 185, also es gab so einen Hack von dem
ukrainischen Geheimdienst, wo sie bei der Luftfahrtbehörde wohl Berichte rausbekommen haben.
Da wurde dann gemeldet, dass wohl im Januar 23 allein 185 Zwischenfälle im Luftverkehr
gemeldet wurden, von denen 30% als schwerwiegend eingestuft wurden.
34 allein mit ihrem Sukhoi Superjet SSJ-100, also es betrifft definitiv jetzt
nicht nur die westlichen Flugzeuge, sondern auch die russischen Flugzeuge.
Wobei der Superjet auch jede Menge Westkomponenten drin hat.
Genau, man würde ja meinen, dass sie
da sozusagen eine eigene Ersatzteil Lagersituation haben, was weiß ich.
Naja, es gab irgendwie sehr viele technische Störungen, die die gemeldet wurden,
das ist also wohl deutlich angestiegen von 23 auf 22 Prozent.
Betrifft auch alles mögliche, Triebwerke, Hydrauliksysteme, Landeklappen und Software.
Also hat sich verdreifacht, ungefähr verdreifacht bis vervierfacht die Zahl
der Störungen im Gegensatz zu 2022, so 2023, so viermal so viele.
Genau, es wird auch nicht besser, weil sie sozusagen nur auf nicht zertifizierte
Reparatur- und Wartungsdienste zurückgreifen müssen.
Viele wohl so im Iran, weil sie halt einfach die Fachkräfte nicht haben und
einfach auch im Inland die Reparaturmöglichkeiten gar nicht besitzen.
Und Iran hat ja viel Erfahrung damit, weil sie ja schon länger sanktioniert
sind und sie gucken mussten, wie sie ihre Westflieger am Laufen halten.
Da kann jetzt Russland ein bisschen auf deren Erfahrung zurückgreifen,
wie man denn dann mit billigen Teilen das Ganze am Laufen hält irgendwie.
Ja, funktioniert aber wohl auch nur so begrenzt. Also es gibt wohl die Schätzung,
dass von den 820 zivilen Flugzeugen ausländischer Herkunft, die sie so sich da einverheimst haben,
mittlerweile so 70 Prozent diesen nicht zertifizierten Reparaturmaßnahmen unterzogen wurden.
Also das mag vielleicht noch funktionieren, aber wie lange das so noch weitergehen kann, das ist offen.
Und das wird auch dazu führen, dass all diese Flugzeuge, selbst wenn der Krieg
morgen zu Ende sein sollte,
so kriegen diese Flugzeuge nie wieder eine Zulassung, um in den Westen zu fliegen.
Weil einfach nicht nachvollziehbar ist, welche Teile dort ausgewechselt wurden und so.
Also die sind quasi jetzt für immer auch dazu verbannt, wenn überhaupt,
dann nur in Russland und zwischen Russland und Iran vielleicht zu verkehren. Aber ja.
Also wenn da überhaupt noch genug übrig bleiben, weil es gibt auch hier die
Einschätzung, dass so bis Mitte 2023, also das ist jetzt auch schon bald ein
Jahr her, 35 Prozent dieser Auslandsflotte äh,
quasi ausgeschlachtet wurde für Ersatzteile. Also wir haben ohnehin schon quasi
ein Drittel geopfert, um die anderen zwei Drittel halbwegs im Laufen zu halten.
Das wird dann einfach nicht so gut gehen.
Und die Flugzeuge aus der Sowjet-Ära haben sie auch teilweise gar nicht mehr
zum Einsatz gebracht, weil die Triebwerke
wiederum in Polen und anderen Nicht-Russland-Orten hergestellt wurden.
Ukraine.
Wahrscheinlich auch der Ukraine, genau. Und dann durch die Sanktionen und der
Weigerung natürlich der Ukraine keine Möglichkeit mehr haben, die noch zu retten.
Also das kann wohl nicht so lange halten.
Januar 23 haben angeblich 19 von 220 Airbus-Flugzeugen technische Ausfälle gehabt,
33 von 230 Boeing-Flugzeugen und 3 von 21 der brasilianischen Embraer-Flotte.
Naja, also läuft alles nicht so gut.
Kommen wir dann mal zum Problembereich der Aufrüstung oder überhaupt der Versorgung
der Ukraine mit Waffen und Munition.
Und das ist ja ein ziemlicher Zankapfel.
Die EU hatte vor einigen Monaten, ich weiß nicht genau wie lange das jetzt schon
her ist, halbes Jahr vielleicht, zugesagt, eine Million Artillerie-Shells zu liefern.
Also vor allem wahrscheinlich 155 Millimeter-Shells für die NATO-Standard-Artillerie-Systeme.
Auch wenn natürlich noch die russischen Systeme auch noch teilweise im Einsatz
sind, aber ich weiß nicht über wie viele Artilleriesysteme mit 152 Millimeter
der russischen Munition Ukraine überhaupt noch verfügt.
Aber das hat wohl nicht so gut funktioniert, weil Europa langsam ist.
Man kriegt einfach die Kapazitäten nicht an den Start. Das betrifft im Übrigen
auch nicht nur Europa, sondern auch die USA.
Also die Kapazitäten zum Bau von Munition für Artillerie sind so abgebaut worden
in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Dass man einfach auf diese Zahlen nicht kommt. Selbst wenn man da alles voll
in Betrieb setzt, man erreicht es einfach nicht und die Zusage konnte hier nicht eingehalten werden.
Was eben dazu geführt hat, dass diese ganze Artillerieversorgung der Ukraine
versiegt und auch so Kämpfe wie die Kämpfe um Avtivka stehen in dem Verdacht,
dass die Ukraine sich deshalb aus Avtivka zurückziehen musste am Schluss,
weil sie halt einfach nicht mehr genug Möglichkeiten hatte mit Artillerie dagegen zu halten.
Wobei man sagen muss, die Ukraine setzt Artillerie sehr erfolgreich ein,
weil sie hat die besseren Artilleriesysteme, die europäischen Systeme,
die französischen, die deutschen, Panzerhaubitze.
Cäsar und was sie aus den USA bekommen haben, sind alle mit sehr viel höheren
Reichweiten, mit sehr viel besserer Präzision ausgestattet.
Das heißt im Gegensatz zu den Russen, die eben nicht so weit schießen können
und auch nicht so eine hohe Trefferquote haben,
konnten sie dann eben einen gewissen relativen Munitionsmangel dadurch ausgleichen,
dass sie halt einfach bessere Ergebnisse erzielen.
Aber irgendwann ist dann halt auch der Vorrat ausgeblieben und wenn halt die
Fronten nicht mehr mit ausreichend Artillerie versorgt werden,
Dann beschränkt man sich dann eben nur noch auf die unmittelbare Direktverteidigung
und geht nicht mehr frühzeitig vor und so weiter.
Also das ist einfach ein riesiges Problem und da ist auch eine heftige politische
Debatte drum entbrannt. Und jetzt hat Tschechien gesagt, ja,
wir wüssten, wo wir vielleicht 800.000 Shells zukaufen können.
Aber die haben wir nicht in der EU, sondern die müssen wir uns von woanders holen.
Wobei bisher, glaube ich, noch keiner gesagt hat, wo dieses woanders sein soll.
Also das ist irgendwie ein Geheimnis.
Und...
Ich habe sehr viel Skepsis wahrgenommen bei Beobachtern, dass es die überhaupt gibt.
Aber mittlerweile sammeln sie so viel Geld ein innerhalb der EU,
also Frankreich, Deutschland hat sich jetzt auch beteiligt bei dieser Einkaufsaktion,
dass die Tschechen halt irgendwie mal ihr Blatt irgendwann auch mal zeigen müssen
und sagen müssen, wo das jetzt eigentlich herkommt.
Weil keiner so richtig genau weiß, wo diese Produktionskapazitäten auf der Welt
überhaupt existieren oder welche Lager hier aufgebaut sind. Ich will es nicht
ausschließen, dass es doch stimmt, bloß ich habe bisher keine gute Erklärung
gehört, wo es herkommen soll.
Ja, also ins Spiel gebracht wurden,
also ich würde ja, also wenn ich jetzt den Job hätte rumzufragen,
so würde ich auf der einen Seite würde ich Südkorea fragen.
Die haben große Kapazitäten, das weiß man,
und wahrscheinlich auch größere Lager und könnten vielleicht aufgrund der nordkoreanischen
Lieferung an die Sowjetunion möglicherweise auch politisch geneigt sein zu sagen, okay,
wir haben da noch was rumliegen.
Indien wurde gemunkelt, dass die wohl auch Kapazitäten haben und ich hab vergessen,
also ein paar also es gibt auf jeden Fall Länder Aber Indien hat doch russisches Militär Nee,
die haben beides Die setzen schon immer auf beides Okay So, Südafrika wäre noch
so, da würde ich auch noch mal nachfragen.
Und Pakistan könnte, ich sag mal, wenn Indien nicht, dann vielleicht Pakistan.
Also, ja, unklar und es ist halt auch klar,
dass niemand so richtig sich da outen möchte,
sondern dass man das dann schon irgendwie möglichst vertraulich irgendwo...
Und Südamerika ist so, Argentinien, Brasilien und so, die haben auch Kapazitäten.
Es ist nicht so, dass, ja.
Also sicherlich gibt es irgendwie genug, aber Waffen zu liefern ist ja gerade
für so Staaten, also nehmen wir mal Südamerika,
da sieht man ja wie Brasilien sich schwer tut im Verhältnis zu dem Krieg.
Ich meine, so ein Land, selbst der vom Westen immer so gefeierte Lula,
ist ja, wie soll ich sagen, in
seiner Haltung zum Ukraine-Konflikt so ein bisschen zwischen den Stühlen.
Also auf der einen Seite sind sie ja in dieser BRICS Wirtschaftsverbund mit
den Russen zusammen und das bedeutet ja auch immer Bezug von billiger Energie, Öl etc.
Aber eben teilweise vielleicht eben auch Waffenlieferungen. Und generell,
was haben wir mit Europa zu tun, wenn wir uns dann einmischen,
dann können wir nur von irgendjemand bestraft werden,
wir halten uns da mal raus und da sind natürlich dann auch Waffenlieferungen schnell etwas,
wo die Russen mal anfangen irgendwelche Daumenschrauben anzuziehen oder Wagner-Truppen
zu entsenden oder so und die wollen halt irgendwie alle keinen Ärger haben.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich eher die Schwierigkeit dabei, als dass jetzt nicht
genug Artillery Shells irgendwo rumliegen auf diesem Planeten,
nur die dann eben auch wirklich zu bekommen.
Das ist so eine Sache und ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen,
dass dieser Kauf dann so abläuft, dass niemand mitbekommt, wo die jetzt herkommen.
Am Ende des Tages kommt es raus. Steht drauf. Steht drauf, ja.
Es sei denn, ich meine, das ist jetzt nur halb ernst gemeint,
aber den Chinesen würde ich ja auch alles zutrauen, wenn man denen nur genug Geld gibt.
Meinst du?
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Das kann ich mir wirklich nicht vorstellen.
Die haben auch, die produzieren auch.
Die haben genug, das ist nicht die Frage.
Nein, ein NATO-Kaliber meine ich jetzt.
Ja, aber selbst wenn sie das haben, dann weiß sie ja, wie sie in diesem ganzen Konflikt stehen.
Naja, aber.
Okay, wie auch immer. Kommen wir lieber zu den etwas gesicherteren Fakten.
Also generell, es gibt die Frage der Aufrüstung und es gibt die Frage der Munitionsversorgung.
Im Bereich der Munitionsversorgung hatten wir ja hier auch in den letzten Sendungen
immer wieder drauf gewartet, wann denn nun diese GLS-DB.
Bomben denn endlich ankommen?
GLSDB sind modifizierte, einfache 155 Millimeter Munition, die man also auch...
Ne, das sind...
Was ist das?
Ja, das sind halt kleinere Bomben einfach, also die mit sagen Gleitkits auch versehen werden.
Ja klar, aber was ist denn der Small Diameter, also von welchem Durchmesser reden wir denn da?
Ähm,
Also, das waren, ich meine, wir sind das mal durchgegangen, ja auch in einer Sendung.
Ist ja eigentlich auch egal. Ich habe mich da gerade verrannt.
Also es geht hier primär um dieselben Launcher,
die die Highmass-Systeme, also es geht um die Launcher der Highmass-Systeme,
wo halt derzeit eine Munition verschickt wird,
die Gimlas genannt wird, also GLMRS.
Und diese GLSDB sind sozusagen ein Upgrade, wie diese Glidebombs,
über die wir schon gesprochen haben, der Russen.
Zwar jetzt nicht solche Megateile, aber eben größere Bombensysteme,
die in dieselben Launcher reinpassen,
sodass man eben eine sehr viel höhere Reichweite erzielen kann durch relativ
günstige Bombensysteme, die sozusagen durch diese Flugattachments eben verlängert
werden in ihrer Reichweite.
Und das war eine Zusage von Saab und amerikanischen Rüstungsunternehmen,
die das halt liefern wollten, irgendwie letzten September oder so und es kam halt nicht.
Aber es gibt jetzt wohl erste Berichte,
dass die jetzt tatsächlich auf dem Battleground auch angekommen sind.
Also die haben 190 Millimeter gegenüber 150 Millimetern und haben irgendwie
23 Kilo Sprengstoff und der Gefechtskopf ist 93 Kilo schwer,
also ein bisschen dickerer Wumms als Artilleriegranaten.
Und natürlich eine höhere Reichweite von bis zu 150 Kilometern, das ist so...
Ja, 100 Kilometer auf jeden Fall.
Ja, Storm Shadow und Skype Missiles, die ja sehr erfolgreich waren,
die werden wohl ein bisschen knapp.
Also die Briten und die Franzosen haben da relativ viel geliefert und sind jetzt
wohl so mit ihren Beständen so in diesem Bereich, wo sie sagen,
naja, wir brauchen jetzt vielleicht auch nochmal ein paar.
Können denn nicht mal die Deutschen was liefern?
Ich bin mir sicher, es wird auch gerade so viel produziert, wie nur geht,
aber das geht halt nicht so schnell.
Die Taurus-Missiles der Deutschen sind halt immer noch nicht zugesagt,
da kommen wir gleich nochmal dazu. dazu.
Interessanter ist, was halt jetzt im Bereich der Flugtechnik passieren wird.
Auf der einen Seite gibt es ja die Zusage von Dänemark, Niederlande und was
nicht gibt es noch andere, die halt F-16 Flugzeuge liefern wollen in größeren Mengen.
Die sind wohl auch schon teilweise geliefert worden, wenn auch nur in einem
sehr geringen Teil direkt in die Ukraine.
Also ein Flugzeug gibt es da mindestens, das weiß man, das haben sie sie selber
auch gezeigt, aber das ist wahrscheinlich eher zum Training für die Bodentruppen,
für Wartung und sozusagen überhaupt mal zu sehen, wie man mit diesen Flugzeugen umgeht.
Der Großteil dürfte sich gerade in Rumänien befinden und wird dort trainiert
mit ukrainischen Piloten.
Wann die F-16 dann tatsächlich in den.
Bestand der ukrainischen.
Streitkräfte Welche Kraftkräfte übergehen, weiß man nicht. Es wird von Sommer
oder Herbst ausgegangen, wo man vielleicht diese F-16 das erste Mal wirklich im Einsatz sehen kann.
Das ist nicht ganz unwichtig. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel wir über die F-16 hier
schon gesprochen haben, aber
das ist ja so ein bisschen das Universalflugzeug der westlichen Kräfte.
Das ist so der Fighter, mit dem man einfach am meisten Munition,
also am meisten unterschiedliche Arten von Munition transportieren kann.
Kann. Übrigens mit der Ausnahme der Taurus-Missiles. Aber so alles andere,
was hier in diesem Krieg insbesondere im Kampf gegen die russischen Flugzeuge helfen kann,
das passt da halt wunderbar dran.
Unter anderem auch diese Iris-T-Systeme, über die wir hier vor einigen Sendungen
mal ausführlicher berichtet haben, die ja derzeit eher in ihrer Variante als
Bodenluftraketen zum Einsatz kommen in der Luftabwehr,
aber die, wenn man sie dann halt auf F-16 montiert, eben auch eine wunderbare
Luft-Luftabwehr darstellen würde.
Also diese F-16 werden schon einiges an Luftverteidigung noch zusätzlich ermöglichen,
insbesondere im Kampf gegen große Raketen.
Also wenn man halt, wenn Iskander und Kahan 59 und wie sie heißen,
also diese größeren Raketen, die Russland immer wieder auf die Ukraine abschickt,
da hatte man also die Möglichkeit mit schnell aufsteigenden F-16 und RST-Systemen
irgendwie noch eine ganz andere Verteidigung hinzubekommen, als das derzeit
mit den bodengestützten Systemen möglich ist, weil man halt einfach näher ran fliegen kann.
Am 11. März, das ist jetzt in vier Tagen, wird ja dann Schweden auch der NATO
beitreten, wie gemunkelt wird und dann wird es sozusagen offiziell durch sein.
Und die Schweden haben auch angekündigt, dass sie bereit wären ihre,
wie sagt man das korrekt, Gripenflugzeuge auszuliefern.
Die Schweden haben ja eine sehr interessante Militärtechnik am Start und sind
ja für die NATO in vielen Bereichen eine interessante Verstärkung.
Nicht jetzt nur territorial, weil sie dann quasi die Ostsee zum NATO Lake machen
vollständig, sondern weil sie eben auch eine extrem gute Ausstattung mit Schiffen,
U-Booten und eben vor allem Flugzeugen haben.
Und dieser Saab Gripen, das steht also, schwedisch heißt das einfach der Greif sozusagen,
dieser mythische Vogel, ist so ein einstrahliges Mehrzweckkampfflugzeug und
das hat so ein paar Eigenschaften, die es für die Ukraine sehr interessant machen.
Also ich habe mir das auch mal angeguckt, so gibt es ja auch eine Menge Material.
Wie die Dinger dann gewartet oder dann wieder neu bewaffnet und betankt werden können.
Und das ist alles so auf Mobilität ausgelegt und super modular und kann halt von einer Truppe,
von einer mobilen Truppe mit fünf Leuten und drei Lastern oder so,
die können dann einfach irgendwo hinfahren und können dann das Flugzeug neu
bewaffnen, betanken und auch Wartungsarbeiten durchführen.
Und weil das eben auch so modular ist, so ist das auch von Wehrpflichtigen leistbar.
Du brauchst also da kein hoch ausgebildetes Personal zu, so wie bei der F-16.
Es ist halt doch ein anderes Kaliber.
Plus, dass die F-16 mit ihrem niedrigliegenden Lufteinlass auch Dreck und Trümmer oder so ansaugt.
Du brauchst also da für die F-16 dann schon Start- und Landebahnen,
die einigermaßen frei sind von Foreign Debris und so und ist auch nicht so modular.
Das heißt, du brauchst dann schon gut ausgebildete Experten, um das Ding zu warten.
Insofern wäre die Gripen ideal für die Ukraine,
vielleicht mit einer kleinen Ausnahme, weil die haben halt nicht so die super
Reichweite und eine geringere Reichweite, weil speziell für die schwedischen Verhältnisse halt da.
Aber insgesamt wäre das eigentlich das ideale Tool für die Ukraine unter den
gegenwärtigen Bedingungen und Verhältnissen.
Es gibt vor allem ein Feature, was natürlich für die Ukraine sehr interessant
ist in dieser Hinsicht, das ist nämlich das einzige Flugzeugsystem,
was jetzt geliefert wird, was eben diese Taurus-Missiles direkt versenden kann.
Mit anderen Worten, die Gripen wäre dann eben auch die Lösung, die technische Lösung,
Taurus Missiles abzusenden, ohne dass man jetzt noch irgendeinen technischen Aufwand treiben muss,
um das für andere Flugzeugsysteme, also entweder russischer Bauart oder eben der F-16 anzupassen.
Ja, wobei das eher eine Sache von Wochen bis Monaten ist, also kann man eigentlich
fast überall dran raten.
Ja, aber läuft schon, ist halt immer was anderes, als muss erst noch gemacht werden.
Genau, und es ist getestet und abgenommen und macht keine Probleme und so ist
sicherlich viel wert, aber ja, ist jetzt nicht die einzige Option,
aber da kommen wir später noch drauf.
Ja, um das mit der Aufrüstung noch abzuschließen, es werden halt auch diverse
neue Fabriken und Kollaborationen mit der Ukraine gestartet.
Ich habe da jetzt keinen kompletten Überblick, aber ich glaube Rheinmetall will
eine Produktionslinie in der Ukraine starten, auch für ihre Panzer,
auch für die neuen Panzer, die da langfristig gebaut werden sollen.
Kurzfristig geht es natürlich hier vor allem auch um Artillerieproduktionen,
andere Waffensysteme, ähnliches mit tschechischen Firmen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, Slowakei, wie es da gerade ist,
da ist es ja politisch auch gerade ein bisschen schwierig,
aber man wird eben mittelfristig auch neue Kooperationen sehen,
wo eben explizit westliche Militärtechnik auch selbst in der Ukraine gebaut werden wird.
Und es werden natürlich auch in Deutschland neue Fabriken gebaut für Munitionsproduktion
und wahrscheinlich sowieso demnächst überall in Europa,
weil wenn uns die USA als Verbündeter abspringt, dann wird Europa nicht drum herum kommen,
den Militärapparat mal wieder neu aufzubauen, weil er ist dann doch ziemlich
verkümmert durch diese lange Friedensphase.
Ja, ganz wichtig.
Ja, willst du noch was dazu sagen?
Nee, ich wollte nur, du wolltest was zur Drone Army noch sagen.
Genau, das ist ja dann sozusagen nochmal so die Initiative, die in der Ukraine
dann noch stark gerade ist.
Das ist so dieses Ausrufen der Drone-Army.
Es gibt da verschiedenste Behauptungen, wie hoch die Produktionszahlen jetzt
schon sind, dass sie da irgendwie eine Million Drohnen produzieren können pro Jahr.
Was da dran ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber es ist sehr auffällig,
dass die ganze Drohnenentwicklung in der Ukraine gerade einen Megaschub erfährt.
Kann ja auch gleich nochmal was zu sagen, ich habe mir das selber angeschaut,
aber das zeigt sich ja jetzt auch schon, wir hatten das ja hier schon mit den
Seedrohnen, mit Luftdrohnen,
es werden auch mittlerweile schon autarke Systeme eingesetzt für die Belieferung der Frontlinien.
Also es gibt solche selbstfahrenden Anhänger sozusagen.
Also einfach so Fahrzeuge, wo man Munitionskisten reinstellen kann,
die man also direkt an die Front bringen kann, ohne da jetzt noch mit Leute
zu gefährden, die das dann irgendwo hinbringen.
Weil ich meine, wenn du irgendwo einen Schützengraben versorgen willst,
die brauchen ja auch Munition.
Und wenn die Munition ausbleibt, dann war es das mit dem Schützengraben und
der Verteidigung der Frontlinie.
Und jetzt machen sie es so, dass sie ferngesteuerte Systeme haben,
die noch nicht so wirklich autonom sind, die auch noch nicht teilweise noch
nicht eigene Kameras haben, sondern die sie dann mit solchen Spotter-Drones kombinieren.
Das heißt, die fliegen oben mit den Drohnen entlang und beobachten sozusagen
und fahren dann quasi ferngesteuert diese Fahrzeuge an die Schützengräben ran,
wo dann eben jemand kurz hochspringt, die Munitionskästen rausholt und dann
fährt das Ding wieder zurück.
Und ähnliches gibt es für Minenverlegungen, für Minenräumungen weiß ich es nicht
genau, aber es gibt so automatische Minenverlegersysteme.
Also wir sehen einfach hier eine Entwicklung im Turbogang, die einfach eine
zunehmende Dronisierung der gesamten Frontlinie nach sich zieht.
Und es gibt jetzt auch schon erste Berichte, dass generell sich das ganze Kriegsgeschehen.
In die Nacht verlagert, weil tagsüber einfach so viele Spotter-Drones und Kamikaze-Drohnen
unterwegs sind, dass einfach niemand sich da mehr sicher fühlt.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie die Russen auch ihre Verteidigungslinien in
Saporischia und Kherson aufbauen, also nochmal weiter hinten ins Land eingezogen,
da wo sie sozusagen mehr oder weniger unbehelligt bauen können, wie sie wollen,
gehen sie weg von reinen Schützengräben bis hin zu kompletten Tunnelsystemen.
Die also oben sozusagen überhaupt gar nicht mehr zu beobachten sind und dann
eben von diesen Kamikaze-Drohnen auch geschützt sind in gewisser Hinsicht.
Also der Krieg ändert sich in hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Wobei, was ich sehr beeindruckend fand, war jetzt auch das Aufkommen zunehmend
von diesen First-Person-View-Drones,
so den FPV-Drohnen, weil mit denen kannst du dann nämlich wieder in jedes Loch
reinfliegen oder in eine offene Luke oder was auch immer.
Und wenn du siehst, mit welcher Kunstfertigkeit und Präzision die da unterwegs
sind, das ist schon sehr beeindruckend.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber das Problem ist, die Kamikaze-Drohnen haben nicht die Reichweite.
Und das ist immer die Kombination aus Spotter-Drones und Kamikaze-Drohnen.
Das heißt, du musst halt überhaupt erstmal deine Targets finden.
Du fliegst jetzt nicht stundenlang mit einer Kamikaze-Drohne durch die Gegend.
Das Stichwort Loitering Munition, das sind ja die, die rumfliegen und wenn sie
was sehen, dann schlagen sie zu.
Die Kamikaze-Drohnen sind halt auf maximalen Impact aus, das heißt sie sind schnell,
die haben möglichst viel von ihrer Payload, ist für Sprengkraft gedacht und
sollen halt nicht so mega schwere Batterien haben, weil dann teurer und bringt halt nicht so viel.
Sondern da geht es einfach darum, schnell ans Ziel zu kommen und dazu musst
du aber dein Ziel erstmal kennen.
Das heißt, Spotter-Drones schauen sich das alles von oben an,
haben hochauflösende Kameras, während
diese Kamikaze-Drohnen halt relativ schlechte, analoge Kameras haben,
mit denen du dann eben gerade noch so fliegen kannst,
aber damit kannst du nichts auskundschaften und dein Ziel erstmal überhaupt lokalisieren.
Ja, ja. Also diese Army of Drones ist auf jeden Fall eine große Sache und da
ist gerade sehr viel technische Mobilisierung in der Ukraine unterwegs.
Komme ich auch gleich nochmal dazu, wenn ich aus der Ukraine berichte. Ja,
vielleicht noch eine Sache ist halt der Umbau der Militärstruktur oder Umbau
auch des Militärpersonals in der Ukraine.
Da gab es ein paar interessante Ereignisse.
Allen voran, es wurde ja auch schon längere Zeit gemunkelt und mehrfach dann
auch dementiert, aber dann ist es dann doch passiert.
Präsident Zelensky hat nämlich den Oberbefehlshaber der ukrainischen Streitkräfte ausgetauscht.
Das war Valery Salushny und der wurde jetzt durch einen anderen Herrn ersetzt,
nämlich Oleksandr Zirsky.
Okay, und jetzt ist es nicht so ungewöhnlich, dass Führungspersonal ausgetauscht wird.
Russland macht das ja im Minutentakt, hat man so den Eindruck.
Aber dazu muss man wissen,
Valery Zalushny ist jetzt nicht einfach nur irgend so ein Militär in der Ukraine.
Sondern der ist derzeit vermutlich so die populärste Figur in der Ukraine überhaupt.
Also der wird da schon, ich will es nicht zu sehr übertreiben,
aber es hat schon so ein bisschen was von heiligen Verehrung hier und da.
Man sieht sein Gesicht an vielen Stellen in der Ukraine und der ist halt auch ein ganz charmanter,
ruhiger Typ gewesen und repräsentiert, sagen wir mal, für die Ukraine mehr als nur das Militär.
Sondern es ist halt auch in seiner sanften Art, ist ja sozusagen dem Land ans
Herz gewachsen und wird also einfach sehr verehrt.
Es gab dann Gerüchte, dass ihm auch politische Ambitionen nachgesagt werden.
Wie viel da dran ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen. Und dass Selenskyj gegebenenfalls
deshalb auch versucht hat, ihn auszutauschen.
Das ist alles ein bisschen Gerüchteküche. Es kann auch einfach nur damit zu tun haben.
Dass einfach dieser Krieg nach zwei Jahren in eine andere Phase übergegangen
ist und man sich einfach eine neue Ausrichtung mit neuen Ideen gewünscht hat
und dazu auch neue Akteure an den Start bringen wollte.
Weil so erfolgreich man sich auch verteidigt hat, man muss halt auch sagen,
die Ziele, die die Ukraine zum Beispiel mit der Sommeroffensive hatte,
sind halt nicht erreicht worden.
Und da sind sicherlich auch Fehler gemacht worden und nicht alles ist Gold.
Jetzt kommt also dieser Oleksandr Sirski,
der war halt bisher der Chef der Bodentruppen und hat vor allem den...
Kampf um Kiew geführt.
Also die Verteidigung Kiews gegen die Russen, die ja ein Riesenerfolg war,
das ist so im Wesentlichen auf seinem Mist gewachsen.
Also er hat dort die Streitkräfte kommandiert.
Also Oberbefehlshaber ist halt noch da drüber. Also sozusagen die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte teilen sich natürlich ganz klassisch Boden, Luft und Marine und
dann gibt es ja noch den den Oberbefehlshaber, der sozusagen alles koordiniert.
Jetzt ist also der Sirsky der neue Chef.
Der ist ein bisschen spröder in seinem Auftreten, ist also bei Lampen nicht
so populär wie Saluschny.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz gibt es niemanden, der ihm jetzt Inkompetenz nachsagt.
Also man hat jetzt keine Zweifel daran, dass er in der Lage ist, ein Militär zu führen.
Ja, und das ist jetzt ohnehin eine interessante Konstellation,
weil wir haben jetzt irgendwie einen in der Ukraine,
die Militärführung besteht ja im Prinzip aus dem Präsidenten,
so, Zelensky, der ist Jude,
dann haben wir den Verteidigungsminister, den Umjerov, der ist so Krimtatar
und muslimisch und jetzt der Sirski ist der Oberverfehlshaber der Streitkräfte,
der ist in Russland geboren.
Ja, aus dem Oblast Wladimir, ist dann in die Ukraine und dort irgendwie zum Ukrainer geworden.
Und das ist jetzt sozusagen diese Militärführung, es könnte diverser kaum laufen.
Ja, trotz alledem steht halt das Militär jetzt sozusagen vor der großen Frage, was tun wir jetzt.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt schon sehr viel darüber berichtet,
was gut gelaufen ist, was nicht so gut gelaufen ist.
Es gibt viele Erfolge, aber es gibt natürlich die Erwartung,
dass man in irgendeiner Form hier jetzt wieder vorankommt und einen neuen Weg
findet und eine neue Strategie ausarbeitet. Und das Ganze geht dann auch noch
so ein bisschen mit einer Mobilisierungsdebatte einher.
Denn in der Ukraine ist es ja so, es werden derzeit, also die Soldaten,
die herangezogen werden zum Krieg, sind 27 Jahre oder älter.
Und darunter werden die nicht automatisch eingezogen.
Man kann sich natürlich in jedem Alter freiwillig melden und in die Streitkräfte
eintreten und es gibt auch viele junge Leute, die dort kämpfen.
Aber während halt alle anderen, die Russen vor allem, halt auch sehr junge Leute
dort verbraten, ab 17, das weiß ich, wie jung die teilweise sind.
Auf jeden Fall 18-Jährige und halt quasi Rekruten wie frisch sofort nach ihrer
Wehrpflicht gleich an die Front schicken, ist das halt in der Ukraine explizit nicht so.
So, Zelensky hat halt eine Politik, dass er eben möchte, dass quasi die Jugend,
ihre Jugend auch noch leben kann.
Und dass Leute, die schon in gewisser Hinsicht was erlebt haben und eine gewisse
Erfahrung haben, in den Krieg gesendet werden.
Trotzdem dürfen ja die Jüngeren nicht ausreisen, sozusagen als Reserve.
Es gibt jetzt so eine Debatte darum, ob das Alter gesenkt werden sollte oder
es wurde jetzt sozusagen auch beschlossen, dass es gesenkt wird.
Also es gibt jetzt neue Mobilisierungsregelungen und da ist das Mindestalter
dann entsprechend gesenkt worden von,
ich glaube von 27 auf 25 wird es jetzt irgendwie gehen. Nein,
das haben wir jetzt gar nicht notiert.
Was immer noch außergewöhnlich ist, weil es halt einfach kein anderes Land gibt,
wo das irgendwie so gehandhabt wird.
Und das ist auch ein bisschen umstritten, auch was sozusagen die Verpflichtung
von Frauen betrifft. Das möchte er halt auch nicht.
Ja, also man ist sich nicht sicher, ob man das Militär weiter aufstocken sollte,
man ist sich auch nicht sicher, ob man es auch so ohne weiteres kann,
weil das ja auch Ressourcen nach sich zieht, jeder Soldat muss dann auch entsprechend
ausgerüstet werden und man merkt eben auch,
dass es mittlerweile bei denen, die jetzt kämpfen, das sind halt die,
die sich freiwillig gemeldet haben, Das sind die, die sowieso schon lange Soldaten
waren, aber viele sind eben jetzt auch gefallen, viele sind müde.
Es findet nicht in dem Maße eine Rotation statt, wie es halt sinnvoll wäre und
das ist natürlich für die Armee insgesamt eine Belastung.
Und auch hier, denke ich mal, muss es halt einen neuen politischen Prozess geben,
zusammen mit der Führung des Militärs, wie man das denn jetzt halten möchte.
Wie viele Truppen man jetzt wirklich aufbaut, wie groß die Gesamtstärke sein
soll und wie viel Reserve man sich noch ranholt, um irgendwie eine Rotation zu machen.
Man merkt auch, dass viele dann jetzt eben nicht mehr so die begeisterten Patrioten
sind, die sich dann irgendwie, ohne mit der Wimper zu zücken,
da mal eben in ihren sicheren Tod schmeißen wollen.
Und das kann man ja auch nachvollziehen, dass in dem Land die Gesamtgefühlslage schwierig ist.
Ja, und um die mal zu ergründen oder ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
habe ich dann auch vor ein paar Wochen beschlossen ich muss da jetzt mal hin und jetzt war ich da Ja.
Wie kam es denn jetzt überhaupt dazu, dass das jetzt möglich,
wurde so, ich meine Also ich weiß, dass du dich an Enno rangehängt hast,
der ja dort schon seit längerem unterstützend tätig ist, jetzt auch in der Ukraine,
so habe ich das zumindest mitbekommen.
Und dort mittlerweile auch verschiedenen Stellen Kontakte aufgebaut hat.
Und war das denn jetzt schwierig, irgendwie da reinzukommen?
Das wäre so meine erste Frage.
Nö, also es ist überhaupt nicht schwierig, in die Ukraine reinzukommen.
Man fährt da einfach hin und geht dann da rein.
Also.
Das ist überhaupt gar.
Kein… Braucht kein Visum oder so und Wartezeit an der Grenze?
Also die Wartezeit an der Grenze, es hieß, also es hätte sein können,
dass es auf der polnischen Seite Verzögerungen gibt.
Und es gab wohl auch schon Grenzübertritte in den letzten Monaten,
wo das dann mal zwei Stunden dauern kann, bis man dann wirklich vorkommt,
wenn halt der Andrang groß ist.
Der Grenzübergang, wo ich rüber bin, ist einer, der nur für PKWs ist.
Das heißt, es ist nicht für LKWs. Das hat den großen Vorteil,
dass er gerade nicht zu denen gehört, die von den polnischen Bauern bestreikt
werden, weil das ist sozusagen das andere Problem. leben.
Bestimmte Grenzübergänge sind zugeteilt für so bestimmte Grenzübertretungen.
Also du darfst zum Beispiel, wenn du ein Auto in die Ukraine lieferst und das
wird da am laufenden Meter gemacht, dann gibt es da eben entsprechende Grenzübergänge,
die du nutzen kannst und welche, die du nicht nutzen kannst.
Der, wo ich drüber bin, der war halt einfach für den normalen Pkw-Verkehr und
kleine Laster, aber nicht für große Lkws und keine Sondertransporte.
Motorrad? weißt du nicht, weißt du, ob man mit dem Motorrad rein kann?
Ja, man kann mit dem Motorrad rein und das ist auch kein Problem und ich glaube,
man hat dann auch den Vorteil, dass man selbst bei denen, wo die polnischen
Bauern blockieren kommen, die Motorräder trotzdem durch.
Weil sie da eh keine Chance haben, das groß zu verhindern und ich war jetzt
nicht im Motorrad unterwegs, aber das ist so das, was ich gehört habe.
Generell, das ist ein Land, da kann man einfach hinfahren,
So wie man woanders auch hinfährt, das ist halt nur nicht EU,
das heißt du hast halt Grenzkontrollen, sprich wenn man an der Grenze dann ist,
also polnische Grenze, die gucken nur kurz und wenn du raus willst und es fällt
nicht sonderlich was aus,
winken die dich einfach durch. Also das ist denen dann egal.
Zumindest wenn du jetzt ein Fahrzeug hast mit einem deutschen Nummernschild.
Keine Ahnung, wie das dann andere Fälle sind.
Und dann kommst du auf die ukrainische Seite.
Dort begrüßt einen erstmal ein
ukrainischer Grenzbeamter, fragt wie viele Personen in dem Fahrzeug sind.
Und man bekommt dann so einen Laufzettel. Und diesen Laufzettel muss man dann
an drei Stellen bestätigen lassen.
Das ist halt im Wesentlichen Passkontrolle, Zollkontrolle und dann nochmal so eine Nachkontrolle.
Und wenn man dann diese drei Stempel hat, dann kann man durchfahren und dann
guckt sich das hinten nochmal einer an und sagt irgendwie Slava Ukraini und
dann ist man irgendwie in der Ukraine.
Und dieser ganze Vorgang hat tatsächlich bei der Einfahrt 25 Minuten gedauert,
weil einfach nichts los war auf einen Sonntagabend.
Wir sind also über diese Achse Breslau, Krakau, die Autobahn nach Krakopetz
oder so und dort dann halt in die Ukraine,
weil erste Haltestelle war eben Lviv.
Und das ehemalige Lemberg und ja, da kam man dann an und stellt erstmal fest, dass,
Alles ganz normales Land. So eine Stadt mit Menschen und mit Infrastruktur.
Und abgesehen davon, dass man damit eine andere Währung bezahlt.
Und alles.
Kann man Geldautomaten abheben, Geld abheben?
Habe ich nicht probiert, aber wäre sicherlich gegangen.
Überhaupt ist eine erste Feststellung ist so ein bisschen, Das Land ist einfach
mal deutlich digitaler als Deutschland aufgestellt.
Also du hast so mitten in der Stadt gibt es zum Beispiel so Easy-Pay-Terminals,
wo man in Deutschland vielleicht einen Geldautomaten hat, hast du einen Pay-Automaten,
der so einen Gui hat und du kannst damit irgendwie alles bezahlen.
Also wenn du irgendwas bezahlen musst, ich weiß nicht, ob man da auch Geld,
das war glaube ich keine Geldentnahme, es war nur ein Zahlterminal.
Also wenn du irgendwas bezahlen musst, bei irgendeiner Behörde was bezahlen
musst, deine Miete überweisen willst oder so irgendwie, dann kannst du das an
diesem Pay-Terminal machen.
Dann gehst du einfach hin, wählst irgendwie aus, was du bezahlen willst,
wem du was bezahlen willst.
Du kannst auch dem ukrainischen Militär was spenden, kannst das dann von deiner
Telefonrechnung oder Kreditkarte abbuchen.
Lass uns einfach so ein Terminal, um irgendwas zu bezahlen.
Steht da einfach so rum. So neben der Bushaltestelle gibt es irgendwie an verschiedensten
Orten und überhaupt ist alles so digital.
Also du kannst einfach in jedem Restaurant, also ich habe nicht ein,
nicht eine Frirna Bargeld ausgegeben.
Ich habe überhaupt gar kein ukrainisches Geld bei mir gehabt.
Ich habe ausschließlich mit meiner Uhr alles bezahlt.
Egal wo ich war. In jedem Restaurant. In den Restaurants ist das sogar so.
Das ist so irre. Also du hast da so einen QR-Code am Tisch.
Ich dachte so, oh, jetzt sparen sie sich schon wieder dieses Menü.
So, weil das ist ja diese Corona-Nummer, weißt du, das ist jetzt irgendwie so,
Speisekarten sind dann irgendwie, dann musst du auf deinem Telefon und die Schrift
ist zu klein und du erkennst irgendwie nix. Und ich kotze dann immer so ein
bisschen ab und denke mir so, Leute, gebt mir eine Speisekarte.
Ich will sehen, was ist.
Und naja, da war ich dann erstmal so ein bisschen angemuffelt und hab dann aber
erst gecheckt, was dieser QR-Code eigentlich wirklich tut.
Gut, nämlich der QR-Code ist nicht einfach nur irgendeine URL auf eine Webseite,
wo du dann so ein PDF durchscrollen kannst,
sondern das ist eine URL auf eine Webseite, die aber den Tisch in diesem Restaurant
eindeutig identifiziert.
Du kriegst dann eine Speisekarte, wo du dann in der Regel nicht immer,
aber in der Regel nicht nur alle Speisen, die du bestellen kannst,
aufgelistet bekommst, sondern auch immer ein Foto dazu hast,
sodass du auch gleich weißt, was dich in etwa erwartet, wenn man mit der ukrainischen
Küche, auf die ich mich so spezialisiert hatte, meinem Interesse,
weil Pizza kann ich auch zu Hause essen,
war das sehr hilfreich und zu verstehen, was das jetzt eigentlich wirklich ist, was ich da bestelle.
Und du kannst dann auch gleich so eine Selection machen. Ich konnte nicht direkt bestellen.
Aber ich konnte mir halt so eine Merkliste machen und konnte mit so einem Knöpfchen
mir alles anzeigen, was ich ausgewählt hatte.
Und wenn dann halt die Bedienung kam und gefragt hat, was ich haben will,
habe ich einfach mein Telefon da hingelegt und gesagt, das.
Also ähnliches hatte ich jetzt neulich in Ungarn, aber aber auch sozusagen in
einem Restaurant sogar mit Bestellfunktionen.
Wo man dann einfach die Speisen anklicken konnte und Getränke.
Vielleicht gibt es das auch irgendwo mit Bestellfunktionen. Vielleicht gab es
auch die Funktionen und ich habe sie nicht gesehen.
Aber es gab auch damit gleichzeitig die Bezahlfunktion.
Weil ich könnte dann sozusagen für diesen Tisch auch direkt in der App irgendwie
bezahlen Apple Pay, zack, bumm und dann war bezahlt und ich konnte einfach das Restaurant verlassen.
Und das Besondere war, diese Funktionalität der Speisekartenauswahl und der
Merkliste und des Bezahlens war eine Dienstleistung der Monobank,
die eine der ukrainischen Banken ist.
Das heißt, das Restaurant hat dann sozusagen dort ein Konto und mit dem Konto
kriegst du dann als Restaurant auch gleich diese Funktionalität,
ach, du brauchst ja noch eine Speisekarte mit Bezahlfunktion, hier.
So, kannst dich einloggen, kannst deine Speisekarte eintragen,
zack, bumm, QR-Code auf den Tisch machen, fertig.
So, und das war so, weißt du, wo du gerade so aus Berlin kommst,
wo du dann jedes Mal, wenn du in so einem Restaurant bist, erstmal fragen musst,
so, nehmen sie überhaupt Kreditkarten?
Ja, oder ist das hier so ein Umsatzsteuersparmodell wieder?
Wobei ich bin da, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da irgendwie altmodisch bin,
aber so, ich, gut, wahrscheinlich hätte man auch bar zahlen können, wenn man wollte, oder?
Mit Sicherheit hätte ich auch bar bezahlen können, aber ich habe einfach Also.
Ich mag Bargeld einfach.
Das ist ja auch alles völlig in Ordnung Ich sage nur, die Ukraine ist komplett
durchdigitalisiert Also das LTE hatte auch mal hier und da seine Schwächen und
man war auch so in Edgeland,
aber ich kann das ehrlich gesagt so ein Land im Kriegszustand eher gut schreiben
als Deutschland Wo das sozusagen schon sofort passiert,
wenn du im Flughafen in die S-Bahn steigst.
Und das war auf jeden Fall einer meiner ersten Eindrücke.
Ansonsten war vor allem mein Eindruck, es war eine Menge los,
es waren sehr auffallend viele Menschen auf der Straße.
Also es war eine Präsenz der Bevölkerung in der Straße, die für mich größer war als in Berlin.
Da war also in der City da war so viel los da waren so viele Menschen unterwegs und da war Gewusel und,
alles ist voll mit Shops mit irgendwie Beautyprodukten das scheint da irgendwie
ein besonderes Ding zu sein also es herrscht wirklich kein Mangel an so Drogerien und,
Parfüm und keine Ahnung also so Selbstverschönerung ist in der Ukraine definitiv ein heißer Markt,
Und generell sind auch alle sehr gut gekleidet, würde ich sagen.
Naja, es war einfach eine Menge los, es gab viele Restaurants,
es gab unheimlich viele Bars, es war auch sehr auffallend, dass viele Bars und
Restaurants einfach, der Großteil war wirklich schön.
Also es ist einfach, die Inneneinrichtung war immer super aufwendig,
super nett dekoriert, sehr individuell.
Die Bars sahen einfach toll aus.
Alles sehr schick. Also das Letzte, woran du denken würdest,
ist irgendwie Land im Krieg.
Der Gedanke kommt ja einfach in Lviv einfach null.
So und naja gut, ich habe dann letztlich dort nur eine Nacht verbracht in einem Hotel,
was auch allen westlichen Anforderungen entsprach so und Hotelpreise sind natürlich
auch entsprechend gering im Vergleich zu uns.
Du kannst also locker auch für 30 Euro die Nacht unterkommen und hast einfach ein Top-Hotel.
Ja, und das war mein erster Eindruck nach Grenzübertritt.
Mhm. Das sind so von der Grenze, was? 50, 100 Kilometer? Stunde.
Ja, eine Stunde Fahrt ungefähr von der Grenze. Lviv ist relativ nah dran.
Ja, und es ist eine schöne Stadt. Es hat mich sehr an Berlin erinnert, so in den 90er Jahren.
Nicht ganz so verfallen, aber halt so von der ganzen Häuserstruktur her,
viele wunderbare Architektur.
Die ganze Stadt ist auch voll mit schönen Kirchen, die ganze Ukraine ist voll
mit schönen Kirchen und alle haben irgendwie goldglänzende Dächer,
also in den Kirchen geben sie sich richtig Mühe,
aber ich hatte dann auch in dem Hotel, gab es so ein Restaurant oben im siebten
Stock, wo man über die Stadt rüberschauen konnte und es war einfach korrekte
Skyline, es ist einfach ein wunderschönes europäisches Städtchen.
Also kann man mal machen und halt weitgehend verschont geblieben von diesem Krieg.
Ja, am nächsten Tag ging es dann aber direkt weiter nach Kiew.
Dann gibt es eine lange Autobahnstrecke von Lviv nach Kiew und die kann man so in sechs,
sieben Stunden befältigen, glaube ich, ja, in etwa.
Wie sind so die Straßen- und Verkehrsverhältnisse da auf der Strecke gewesen?
Also es gibt auf der Strecke keine durchgehend ausgebaute Doppelspur-Autobahnen.
Das ist stellenweise, umso näher du an Kiew rankommst, umso besser wird das.
Die beste Autobahnverbindung ist tatsächlich zwischen Kiew und Odessa.
Das ist sozusagen so, wie man das hier erwarten würde. So zwei Spuren auf jeder
Seite nahezu durchgehend.
Und auf der Strecke von Lviv nach Kiew ist es eher so ein bisschen,
wie es auch früher in Polen war.
Das heißt, du hast zwar eine relativ breite Straße, hast aber eigentlich auf
jeder Seite nur eine, wenn auch sehr breite Spur, die dann nochmal recht so eine Art Bremse.
Was man in Berlin Fahrradstreifen nennen würde, nochmal so eine Ausweichzone,
sodass wenn du überholen willst,
entweder auf die Gegenspur gehst oder im Idealfall die Vorfahren so ein bisschen
nach rechts fahren, um dich überholen zu lassen.
Das hat also alles eine gewisse Dynamik und da muss man schon mit einer anderen
Aufmerksamkeit unterwegs sein, als man das jetzt so auf einer Autobahn sein muss.
Hatte ich in Polen aber auch solche, also viel solche Strecken.
Genau, also im Prinzip diese typische osteuropäische Landstraßenkonfiguration.
Aber halt keine voll ausgebaute, mit separaten Richtungen getrennte Autobahnen.
Auch die Abfahrten sind teilweise etwas anders gebaut. Was zum Beispiel in der
Ukraine sehr populär ist, sind solche Wendebrücken.
Also du hast halt oft nicht solche Autobahnkreuzartigen Strukturen,
sondern du biegst halt direkt nach links ab und entweder hast du dann so in
der Mitte eine Wendespur.
Also wenn du wenden möchtest, dann wartest du erstmal, bis der Gegenverkehr
vorbei ist, dann fährst du über die Gegenfahrbahn rüber, wo dann nochmal an
der Seite so eine Ausbuchtung ist, sodass du da erstmal zum Stehen kommen kannst.
Wenn dann der andere Verkehr wieder an dir vorbeigezogen ist, dann fädelst du ein.
Oder eben eine richtige Wendebrücke, sodass du dann rechts rausfährst und dann
wirklich nur eine Spur einmal als Brücke über die Straße rüber geht und auf
der anderen Seite wieder zurückkommt.
Das sind so recht gängige Straßenstrukturen, die wir so bei uns nicht kennen.
Es ist halt einfach anders gewachsen und wir sind halt voll auf diesen Autobahnen
mit irgendwie Blumenkohlabfahrten gegangen und dort ist es halt eher so etwas meistens.
Und viel Verkehr?
Ja, normal. Also, ja.
So Mischung. Achso, das war dann, war das ein Werktag? Montag.
Ja, LKWs waren auch unterwegs.
Ja, eigentlich eine normale Mischung. Das kann man jetzt gar nicht,
das ist mir gar nichts anderes anzusehen.
Also unauffällig.
Genau, unauffällig. Also da ist Verkehr, wie man das so erwarten würde,
zwischen zwei großen Metropolen.
Umso näher man dann an Kiew rankam, umso mehr wurde dann aber auch der Krieg sichtbar.
Diese Straße, die von Lviv nach Kiew führt, war dann auch Teil der ersten Kampfhandlung.
Also bis dahin sind die Russen auch vorgedrungen aus dem Norden und es gab dann
auf dieser Strecke konkrete Auseinandersetzungen und das merkst du dann,
wenn du so auf 200 Kilometer an Kiew rangekommen bist oder vielleicht auch 150,
das weiß ich nicht ganz genau.
Genau, also auf einmal sind überall Einschusslöcher zu sehen und du hast dann
zerstörte Häuser, die links und rechts sind oder Häuser,
die ganz offensichtlich irgendwie nochmal gefixt wurden oder komplett zerschossene
Tankstellen tauchen dann auf einmal auf.
Aber immer schön im Wechsel mit brandneuen, glitzernden, voll auf Top-Standard
neu aufgebauten Tankstellen sich abwechseln.
Also das ist irre.
Gerade die Tankstellen sind da, also wirklich alles was da neu gebaut ist, da ist viel neu.
Das ist einfach top. So ein bisschen wie in Polen, das heißt du hast auch mal
Klos, für die du auch nicht bezahlen musst.
Und ähm,
Ja, das ist einfach super eingerichtet, alles super neu und zwischendurch hast
du aber dann ein paar ältere Tankstellen, die halt irgendwie komplett zerschossen sind.
Und dann eben auch Häuser, wo irgendwelche Raketen reingeflogen sind oder Panzer
reingeschossen haben oder was weiß ich.
Dann fährst du auf einmal an einer riesigen Lagerhalle vorbei,
die was weiß ich, 200 Meter lang ist, die komplett zerstört ist,
wo du also gemerkt hast, da ist richtig was reingeflogen, irgendeine fette Rakete oder so,
ja und umso mehr du dich halt der Stadt näherst umso urbaner wird es und dann
so die Einfahrt nach Kiew, das ist dann halt sowas, weiß ich wenn du nach Berlin
kommst, also du merkst halt einfach wie es immer urbaner wird,
die Straßen immer breiter werden, der Verkehr,
zunimmt, ja, und du bist dann irgendwann in Kiew.
Ja. Ja, und so Kiew, der erste Eindruck, wie eher wie Lviv oder anders?
Kiew ist viel größer als Lviv. Lviv ist so ein bisschen so wie wie so ein was
ist ein guter Vergleich? Ähm.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen, kleines Prag, weil es halt so ein bisschen eher
so wie Prag rüberkommt, aber ist halt nicht so groß.
Von der Stadtgröße her, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, Einwohnerzahl habe ich jetzt
gar nicht so genau geguckt, aber Kiew ist auch definitiv einfach die Metropole
und da wohnen irgendwie drei Millionen Leute, fast unter einer Million.
Also die Dimensionen sind anders und natürlich merkst du, dass es die Zentrale
des Landes ist, Das heißt,
du hast halt viel mehr Hochhäuser und irgendwie auch schon sehr viel mehr Industrie,
wenn du drauf zukommst, Gewerbegebiete, alles mögliche.
Das ist um Lviv natürlich nicht so stark.
Und ja, dann bist du halt irgendwann im Zentrum auf einer vier- oder achtspurigen Straße unterwegs.
Also so mit Radinfrastruktur und so weiter geht da auch noch so einiges.
Das ist definitiv alles für Autos gebaut, gar keine Frage.
Und in der City ist halt das historische Kief, das dann wiederum ganz cozy ist
und wo sich dann halt so ein paar Bausünden abwechseln mit sehr vielen alten Kirchen und Altbauten.
Und insgesamt ist Kiv sehr, sehr, sehr schön und wir sind dann irgendwie direkt bis in die City vor.
In der Nähe des Intercontinental Hotels, in so einem günstigen Apartmenthaus,
wo so im Wohnhaus so Wohnungen vermietet werden, alles gut bezahlbar,
alles top eingerichtet, alles richtig gut.
Also es ist einfach alles super da.
Und ja genau, dieses Intercontinental Hotel, das ist dann an so einem Platz.
Dieser Platz, wo die Ukraine diese ganzen abgeschossenen Panzer und,
Artilleriesysteme und so weiter, die rostigen Dinger dahin geschleppt hat,
damit irgendwie die internationalen Journalisten das dann auch gleich immer
sehen können, wie es ist und wo dann irgendwie alle Präsidenten anderer Länder
vorbeigeschleppt werden.
Dann gibt es dann noch so eine lange Mauer, wo irgendwie auf 100 Metern alle
im Krieg seit 10 Jahren getöteten Ukrainer mit Foto verewigt sind.
Das ist schon alles sehr beeindruckend an der Stelle.
Ja genau, bin dann am Abend da angekommen, es war halt schon spät und dann,
legst dich auch erstmal hin und dann ging es dann auch am nächsten Tag erstmal
gar nicht in Kiew weiter, sondern wieder ins Auto.
Gab es einen Ausflug nach Tschernihiv.
Tschernihiv ist eine kleinere Stadt im Norden von Kiew, relativ nah an der russischen
Grenze und, oder ist es Belarus noch? Ich weiß gerade gar nicht.
Auf jeden Fall da, wo die Russen heimgeschnitten sind.
Ich gucke gerade, es ist ein bisschen auf der Belarus-Seite,
aber auch nicht weit von Russland entfernt.
Also es ist fast an der Grenze zwischen Russland und,
Belarus, wenn ich das so richtig sehe. Und 282.000 Einwohner laut Wikipedia.
Und Lviv waren übrigens um die 700.000 nur so.
So hat es sich auch angefühlt. So ein bisschen wie Hannover.
Das ist vielleicht so die Dimension von Lviv.
Genau, Tscherniv war im Krieg,
Beim Angriff der Russen insofern ein besonderer Ort, als dass es ja den Russen
nicht gelungen ist, die Stadt einzunehmen.
Sie hatten sie so zu 90 Prozent umzingelt, aber es ist ihnen dann nicht gelungen,
wirklich die Verteidigung zu überwinden.
Was wohl mit diesem ersten Tankregiment von der ukrainischen Streitkraft zu tun hat,
die da wohl ganz gute Munitionslager hatte und zufällig gerade für eine Übung
irgendwie unterwegs war.
Sodass sie schnell diese Stadt sichern konnte und dann es eben den Russen versagt
haben dort einzuziehen, bis sie dann wieder abziehen mussten.
Ja und da begann dann sozusagen für mich jetzt auch so ein bisschen der Einstieg
in in so was dort so vorgefallen ist.
Achso, es ist übrigens auch nicht weit von Tschernobyl entfernt sehe ich gerade.
Tschernihiv? Ja, Tschernihiv ist sozusagen östlich von...
Das ist aber, Chernobyl ist ja nochmal so, da ist ja nochmal so eine Zunge Belarus,
die das nochmal trennt auf der anderen Seite des Dnepr.
Also ich würde das jetzt nicht der Zone zu, also rein von Kilometern her hast
du natürlich recht, aber das hat da später sozusagen keine Rolle.
Aber okay, ja es ist nicht so mega weit weg.
Genau. Und dann begann sozusagen so eine Kaskade. Ich muss sagen,
wir haben viel Glück gehabt auf dieser ganzen Reise.
Es haben sich am laufenden Meter neue Dinge ergeben, die sich zeitlich alle
wunderbar aneinander angereiht haben. Und so war ich dann sozusagen...
Und permanent eigentlich damit beschäftigt, mir irgendwas Interessantes anschauen zu können.
Und aus jeder Begegnung hat sich dann wieder was Neues ergeben und noch ein
paar andere Zufälle und Kontakte, die schon existiert haben.
Und dann wollt ihr euch das noch anschauen, dann gucken wir mal,
ob wir das noch hinbekommen.
Und es begann jetzt hier in Tschernihiv und wir waren dann in einem Vorort von
Tschernihiv namens Jahitne und der ist halt dafür bekannt,
dass dort die Russen sich in so eine Schule unter den Nagel gerissen haben als ihr Einsatzzentrum.
Und haben dann in dem Keller dieser Schule über 300 Ukrainer aus diesem Dorf,
ja Hidne, zusammengezogen und dort in den Keller gesperrt.
Und da haben dann irgendwie 300 Leute in einem dunklen Keller in dieser Schule,
quasi ohne richtige Essensversorgung,
ohne irgendeine Versorgung ausharren müssen.
Alte Leute, junge Leute, Babys, wo vom Platzangebot her quasi für jede Person
ungefähr ein halber Quadratmeter Bereich stand.
Und dort haben die dann irgendwie drei Wochen ausharren müssen,
bis die Russen dann aus diesem Gebiet vertrieben wurden.
Das war schon sehr beeindruckend. Es hat uns dann so ein älterer Mann,
der auch dort eingesperrt war für die Zeit, hat uns das dann irgendwie alles
gezeigt und diesen Ort angeschaut und mir das so schildern lassen, was passiert ist.
Alles so vorgefallen ist und das kann man sich irgendwie gar nicht so richtig
klar machen, wie furchtbar und grausam das gewesen sein muss.
Also, weißt du, die hatten dann noch nicht mal genug zu trinken und mussten
dann irgendwie ihren eigenen Schweiß,
der sich sozusagen an der Decke kondensiert hat, mit irgendwelchen.
Abdeckungen von Lampen wieder auffangen, um den dann zu trinken, um nicht zu verdursten.
Da sind Leute gestorben, die dann tagelang noch rumlagen, bevor irgendwie die
Russen bereit waren, dass man die zumindest beerdigen kann.
Also ein totales Materium und unfassbar und es war einfach,
ja und das war so ab dem Moment so ein wiederkehrendes Element,
was ich eigentlich die ganze Zeit in den Augen und Äußerungen von allen Ukrainer,
mit denen ich gesprochen habe, gesehen habe.
Aber dieses unglaubliche Kopfschütteln,
dieses Unverständnis über die unfassbare Grausamkeit, mit der die Russen in
diesem Krieg gegen die Zivilbevölkerung vorgehen.
Also das war immer wieder dieses so,
man kann es sich nicht vorstellen und was sind das für Menschen und die sind
den Ukrainern so fern, wie man sich nur irgendwas vorstellen kann.
Ich meine, sie nennen sie ja auch die Orks, bezugnehmend auf Herr der Ringe,
so wie die Orks sozusagen über Mittelerde und die Auenwälder einfallen irgendwie
in ihrer absoluten Grausamkeit,
so sehen die Ukrainer die Russen dort.
Und das ist so das alles bestimmende Bild.
Also wenn man irgendwie noch diesen Glauben hat,
dass die Ukraine und Russland irgendwie was Nennenswertes miteinander zu tun
haben, dann ist das irgendwie spätestens, weil das in dem Moment einfach auch
schon wieder alles vorbei ist.
Ich hatte diesen Glauben nicht und ich muss auch sagen, dass ich jetzt nicht
irgendwas entdeckt habe in der Ukraine, mit dem ich nicht schon gerechnet habe.
Mein Bild von der Ukraine, was ich jetzt von außen hatte, hat sich eigentlich
am laufenden Meter und auch von diesem Konflikt hat sich eigentlich am laufenden Meter bestätigt.
Aber auch das war natürlich eine interessante Erfahrung, weil ich natürlich
auch genauso damit gerechnet habe, Dinge zu entdecken, wo ich sagen würde,
ach so war das dann irgendwie so. Das hat sich mir ja bisher nicht so dargestellt.
Jetzt haben wir diesen ganzen Konflikt ja schon sehr intensiv begleitet die
ganze Zeit und es war auch eine große Hilfe, muss ich sagen,
weil ich natürlich jeden Ort, der irgendwie erwähnt wurde, jeden Kampfort,
jeden Vorgang zumindest schon mal irgendwie gehört habe und eine Vorstellung
hatte von den Richtungen, Distanzen, Größenordnung.
Und der Wichtigkeit der Vorfälle, die genannt wurden, dass ich das alles sehr
gut einordnen konnte, was an Gesprächen um mich herum so geführt wurde.
Ja, und trotzdem war das schon so ein Moment der Beklommenheit in gewisser Hinsicht,
weil du halt auch weißt, okay, jetzt kommst du da aus deinem reichen Deutschland und weißt du,
wo es alles in Hülle und Fülle gibt und wo sich keiner auch nur im Ansatz darüber
Gedanken macht, man könnte morgen mal von so einer Bombe zerstört werden.
Und dann bist du da und da ist irgendwie alles von Bomben zerstört,
überall kaputte Häuser und der Horror sitzt den Leuten halt da wirklich noch
im Nacken und sie wissen, es ist halt auch noch nicht vorbei.
Und entwickelt man schon so eine gewisse demut und natürlich auch so ein noch
gesteigertes unverständnis über jede perspektive auf diesen konflikt aus dem
westen wo dann immer so ein,
denken zum ausdruck kommen von ja ach die sollen sich doch mal einigen mit den russen,
Das ist einfach vollkommen unvorstellbar. Die werden sich mit diesen Russen auf gar nichts einigen.
Das Einzige, worauf die sich dort einigen können, ist, die müssen alle weg.
Und jeder Russe, der unsere Grenze übertreten hat, der muss entweder sofort
weg oder muss umgebracht werden, weil die killen uns halt hier alle.
Wenn die Russen nochmal in irgendeiner Form sich dieser Stadt nähern,
dann werden alle sterben.
Das ist einfach da die klare Überzeugung. Und ich denke, man muss sich nicht
lange dort aufhalten, um einfach zu merken, genau das ist das, was da stattfindet.
Was die Russen da einfach machen, ist einfach nichts anderes als ein Genozid
an der Ukraine und nichts anderes.
Wie waren denn so, also speziell in Jahidne, jetzt so Kriegsspuren in der Gegend noch präsent?
Du hast ja ganz viele zusammengeschossene Häuser.
Das eine oder andere ist vielleicht dann mal wieder repariert worden,
weil es sich noch reparieren ließ, aber du hast halt so diverse Häuser,
die halt einfach kaputt geschossen sind und dann noch im kaputt geschossenen Zustand rumliegen.
Und du hast halt vor allem überall irgendwo
liegt immer nochmal mal ein verrosterter Panzer rum und es gibt so,
aufgeschüttete Pkw-Friedhöfe, wo man auf irgendeinem Parkplatz alle kaputt geschossenen
Pkw in diesem Konflikt einfach zusammengeschoben und aufeinander gestapelt hat,
damit sie erstmal irgendwo rumstehen,
bevor man sie vielleicht irgendwann nochmal richtig verschrottet bekommt. Du siehst diese.
Folgen überall, du siehst aber auch, und das war dann besonders sichtbar,
als ich durch Bucha und Irpin gefahren
bin, was ja auch so ein Hotspot der Angriffe waren und der Gräuel,
dass eben überall, wo die Ukraine auch schon die Zeit gefunden hat,
das wieder richtig zu machen, Häuser dann teilweise halt auch wirklich perfekt
wieder aufgebaut wurden, was halt da auch natürlich ein Teil der,
Bewältigung ist.
Also dass man aber es ist mit Nichten alles schon wieder heile es ist viel repariert
worden, was auch immer man reparieren kann, ist repariert, aber viele Häuser
sind halt auch beyond repair müssen irgendwann abgerissen werden,
gerade größere Häuser und das ist natürlich jetzt mal nicht eben so gemacht
und ich glaube es hat so ein bisschen mindere Priorität große Häuser abzureißen
wir haben gerade andere Sachen zu tun und bauen lieber irgendwas also lieber
reparieren sie irgendwas oder Oder liegen Ihre Energie auf die Sicherung der Grenzen,
anstatt jetzt große Abreus-Aktionen zu starten?
Ja.
Ein anderes Thema, was mich natürlich interessieren würde, wie denn so die empfundene
Bedrohungssituation durch Luftangriffe bis dahin war.
Wie hast du dich gefühlt und wie gehen die Leute damit um?
Also ich muss sagen, also erstmal, ich bin in der Woche, wo ich da war,
war die Zahl der Luftangriffe insgesamt in den Regionen, wo ich war, überschaubar.
Also es war nicht sehr viel los.
Ja, das war die Zeit, nachdem, sagen die, auch die Luftwaffe so ein bisschen
schon in Not war, die russische.
Ja, das mag aber jetzt für die Drohnenangriffe und die Raketenangriffe ist das
ja nicht so relevant. Also das hat damit ja nicht so viel zu tun.
Es war immer so ein bisschen Glück bei mir, dass der erste Luftangriff auf Kiew,
der gemeldet wurde, da war ich gerade auf der Autobahn unterwegs. unterwegs.
Das heißt, da habe ich nichts von mitbekommen. Es gibt jeder,
man installiert sich so diese R-Alert-App.
Dann sagst du, für welche Region möchtest du gerne Warnungen erhalten? Wo bist du?
Und das kannst du dann entweder für eine komplette Region oder so einen kleinen
Distrikt runterbrechen und dann wird man halt gewarnt, wenn in irgendeiner Form
was detektiert worden ist, was vielleicht da runterkommen könnte.
So, das erste Mal war das auf der Autobahn auf dem Weg nach Kiew,
da hat man natürlich nichts gehört, auch nichts mitbekommen,
da fährst du einfach weiter und machst dir keine großen Gedanken.
In der ganzen Zeit in Kiew war nur ein Luftalarm, bei dem Luftalarm war ich
aber gerade in einer Bar und diese Bar war im Keller und diese Bar war selber
auch als Bunker freigegeben.
Das heißt, um mich zu sichern, hätte ich dann in diese Bar gehen können,
aber ich saß ja schon an der Bar und hab sozusagen den Luftalarm beim Cocktail irgendwie.
Das fühlte sich auch irgendwie total unwirklich an, weil das war wirklich eine sehr coole Bar.
Ja, da gab es irgendwie alles, so 20 Meter lange Alkoholika Auswahl für Cocktails und alles top designt.
Super nette Leute da und einfach kann ich sehr empfehlen, Kiefseid Barman Diktat heißt die.
Während des Luftalarms habe ich halt mit so einem jungen Ukrainer gesprochen,
der unter anderem an dieser App mitarbeitet, die heißt DIA.
DIA ist sozusagen diese universelle Aktion, wo Ukrainer mit den Behörden interagieren können.
Also du kannst quasi steuern und alles irgendwie über diese App machen.
Die ja heißt Aktion, heißt das.
Ja, und gut, ein Luftalarm, den du nicht hörst, weil du irgendwie zwei Etagen
tiefer im Keller sowieso schon sitzt und dir gerade irgendwie ein Whisky Sour
zur Gemüte führst, ist jetzt nicht besonderlich bedrohlich.
Das Bedrohliche kam dann erst später, das habe ich dann aber auch noch ausgesessen.
Ja, ja.
Und so gut, das war jetzt, ich sag mal, für dich natürlich eine Situation,
also erstens, wie du sagst, das ist jetzt Glück und so, du bist da natürlich
nicht die ganze Zeit jetzt.
Wie war denn, haben denn Leute irgendwas erzählt, wie sie sich so generell gefühlt
haben oder wie sie damit umgehen, also Stresslevel?
Meinst du jetzt mit den Luftalarmen konkret oder mit der Situation an sich?
Naja, also jetzt konkret erstmal die Luftalarme.
Weiß ich nicht so richtig, ob ich das beurteilen kann.
Es ist halt generell, ich würde sagen, es ist generell die Einstellung ist halt
die, der Krieg ist da, man versucht so sein Leben normal zu leben.
Ich meine, du läufst in Kiew rum, es ist einfach ein ganz normaler Hauptstadt.
Leute gehen shoppen, gehen einkaufen, fahren durch die Gegend,
alle machen das, was sie sonst auch machen vielleicht im Wesentlichen oder versuchen
es zumindest und diese Luftalarme sind Realität.
Was ich jetzt nicht erlebt habe, ist ein Luftalarm, während ich auf der Straße
war, wo die Sirenen losgehen, wo ich hätte jetzt schauen können,
wie die Leute reagieren.
Diese Erfahrung habe ich so nicht gehabt und deswegen kann ich dazu auch herzlich wenig sagen.
Ich kann also nur wiedergeben, was ich so aus Gesprächen mitgenommen habe und
es ist halt generell dieses.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du jetzt irgendwie von so einem Luftanschlag getroffen
wirst, ist halt ohnehin gering im Verhältnis zur Größe des Landes und der Bevölkerung und so weiter.
Das war wahrscheinlich in den ersten Wochen noch anders, als das auch den ganzen Tag so war.
Von daher glaube ich, werden jetzt auch nicht alle sofort irgendwie in die U-Bahn
rennen, wenn was ist. Aber vielleicht manche schon und manche nicht.
Grundsätzlich ist es halt dieses, ja wir haben alle die Schnauze voll von diesem
Krieg, wir finden es scheiße, aber wir werden jetzt nicht aufhören,
so dagegen anzukämpfen.
Wir müssen das halt einfach nehmen, weil alle sehnen sich danach,
dass es zu Ende ist. Aber diese Resilienz ist generell zu spüren.
Man gönnt den Russen einfach gar nichts mehr.
Das Verhältnis zwischen Russland und Ukraine ist beendet für die nächsten 50 Jahre.
Die werden dort kein positives Bild mehr abgeben können.
Für die ist Russland einfach Mordor und nichts anderes.
Verstehe. Ja, und also dann Tschernigiv waren wir jetzt und du hast es jetzt schon erwähnt.
Ihr seid dann auch noch auf die andere Seite von Kiew, also Butscha und Irpin
hattest du kurz erwähnt.
Ja, ich war ja dann noch in der Stadt Tschernigiv selber und da ging das dann
auch los mit diesem wunderbaren leckeren ukrainischen essen,
so Borscht und ist einfach alles so lecker da.
Ich habe dann Leute getroffen, die halt so Hilfe für die Front organisieren,
die so alles mögliche einkaufen und zusammenziehen, teilweise auch nach Deutschland
fahren, um Sachen einzusammeln, auch wenn sie das jetzt wahrscheinlich durch die Verschärfung der,
Regeln bald nicht mehr können oder zumindest ist das offen.
Die halt alles mögliche einsammeln, Drohnen, Spenden irgendwie und die fahren
das dann aber auch selber an die Front.
Das heißt, die sind da einfach in einem hohen Maße vernetzt und,
bevor man das in die offiziellen Kanäle einkippt, wo man immer ein bisschen
Angst haben muss, dass durch Korruption dann doch das eine oder andere aufgehalten
wird oder wo, sagen wir mal, vielleicht Lieferungen dann in irgendeinem Lagerhaus landen,
aber nicht genau da, wo sie jetzt gerade gebraucht werden.
Das ist einfach ein hoher Grad an Selbstorganisation, der da herrscht und es gibt halt so Leute,
die ich dann eben auch kennenlernen durfte, die dann einfach alles einsammeln,
Ins Auto packen und dann fahren die direkt runter nach Avdivka und liefern das
dann direkt bei Leuten ab,
die da konkret im Einsatz sind, die das dann auch sofort an die Front verteilen
und wo sozusagen hundertprozentige Effektivität dieser Spenden dann auch sichergestellt ist.
Bei der Gelegenheit gab es dann auch noch eine Begegnung mit einer Frau,
die dort als Medic direkt in Avtivka im Einsatz war.
Die kam gerade von der Front zurück und hat mal ein paar Tage Pause gemacht.
Die ist halt richtig beim Militär und versorgt dort halt die Verwundeten und
hat dann auch irgendwie Fotos gezeigt, die ich mir gar nicht alle angucken konnte,
weil ich ja so ein Weichei bin.
Das war alles ein bisschen zu grausam dann für mein Level von diesen ganzen
Verletzungen und so weiter, die sie da irgendwie aufgezählt hat.
Aber er hat so ein bisschen berichtet und ich habe halt gefragt,
wie schlimm es ist und wie man sich das so vorstellen muss.
Und es ist halt, glaube ich, gerade diese Bomben, die wir vorhin schon gesprochen
haben, die also ja nicht nur töten und laut sind, sondern die ja auch,
bei jeder Explosion so eine unglaubliche Druckwelle ausüben.
Du bist sozusagen als Soldat da an dieser Front permanent diesen Druckwellen auch ausgesetzt.
Das macht dich halt auch im Hirn irgendwie weich.
Ja, das erzeugt auch tatsächlich Hirnschäden.
Diese Druckwellen durch Mikroblutungen im Gehirn und so und das kann halt zu
dann schwersten auch auch neurologischen Symptomen und Erkrankungen führen.
Ja.
Ihr Einsatzgebiet war da halt einfach die Leute von der Front,
also die fährt halt wirklich da an die Front, zieht die Leute ins Auto und bringt
sie sozusagen zu den Erstversorger Stellen.
Also holst die Leute mal ab mit einfachen Fahrzeugen, bringst sie an diese Stabilisierungsstellen,
also holst sie erstmal ohne, erstmal nur holen, so.
Da vielleicht eine Sofortmaßnahme in irgendeiner Form, Blutungsstillen oder so etwas, zagt dann,
werden die bei diesen Stabilisierungsstellen abgeworfen,
Stabilisierung für einen Transport, um dann nochmal in ein anderes Auto geworfen
zu werden, um dann über eine Strecke von 100 Kilometern nochmal quer durch die
Ukraine transportiert zu werden bis zum nächsten Krankenhaus,
was nicht unmittelbar im Kriegsgebiet ist.
Also es ist halt auch bis du dann als verletzter Soldat da eine wirklich eine
stabile Versorgung im Krankenhaus bekommt, kann es halt auch noch mal einige Stunden dauern.
Das passiert da halt einfach am laufenden Meter. Also das war dann so ein bisschen dann die komplette.
Wahrnehmung, die ich dann in Tscherniv hatte. Dann ging es halt wieder zurück
nach Kiew und dann gab es einen lustigen Abend,
im, also da ja dieses Interkontinentalhotel ist sozusagen so der der Treffpunkt
für alle internationalen Helfer,
Journalisten, Pipapo, Politiker.
Und wir saßen dann irgendwie rum und hatten noch ein nettes Ausklangsgespräch.
Und auf einmal tauchte neben uns Vitali Klitschko auf.
Der Bürgermeister von Kiew und der ehemalige Schwergewichtsboxer.
Ich drehe mich so um und der Typ steht irgendwie so vor mir.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du dir vorstellen kannst, wie groß der Typ ist. Also das ist ein Koloss.
Ich meine, okay, er ist irgendwie x-maliger Schwergewichts- Boxweltmeister und
seitdem nicht nennenswert geschrumpft.
Der spricht ja auch fließend Deutsch. Und dann halt so in Begleitung vom,
Journalisten und hatte dann aber auch noch die Zeit, uns irgendwie alle nett
zu begrüßen und ein kurzes Gespräch zu führen und so weiter,
bevor er dann wieder weiterziehen musste.
Da habe ich dann jetzt irgendwie Vitali Klitschko auch nochmal die Hand geschüttelt.
Das war irgendwie ein schönes Highlight, so auf diesen Abend.
Und ich kann nur sagen, der Typ ist wirklich so nett, wie er immer rüberkommt.
Sehr cool. Coole Sau. Ja, das war so mein dritter Tag.
Nächsten Tag ging es dann zu zu einem Start-up,
im Drohnenproduktionsbereich. Da haben wir den Kontakt bekommen über jemanden,
der dort Drohnen einkauft.
Und das ist so eine Bude, die halt in irgendeinem Bürohaus in Kiew sitzt und
Kamikaze-Drohnen entwickelt.
Und die konnten wir dann besuchen und da ein, zwei Stunden abhängen,
ein paar Fragen stellen.
Das war natürlich auch ganz interessant, weil das halt alles so Nerds waren.
Also junge Leute, weitgehend nicht nur, aber vor allem sehr junge Leute,
also was weiß ich, so in ihren Twenties vielleicht, Early Thirties maximal,
mit ein, zwei Ausnahmen und die halt im Rahmen dieses Förderprogramms der Ukraine gearbeitet haben,
ähm.
Und so eine Art Freigabe erhalten.
Also die werden dann quasi lizenziert vom Staat, dass die sowas verkaufen dürfen.
Keine Ahnung, was da die konkreten Kriterien sind und wie die überprüft werden,
aber auf jeden Fall, die dürfen dann sozusagen in diesen Militärbereich reinverkaufen,
wenn sie jemanden finden, der das bezahlt sozusagen. sozusagen.
Und deren Drohnen dürfen dann eben auch eingesetzt werden.
Man kann es ja jetzt nicht einfach jeden irgendwelche Kriegswaffen erzeugen lassen.
Aber im Rahmen dieser Army of Drones-Initiative setzen sie dann eben auch sehr
auf individuelle, ja ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal so Startups,
so Gruppen von Leuten, die sie wahrscheinlich vor einem Jahr noch nicht kannten.
Und die dann eben da sitzen und intensiv dran arbeiten, wie man eben diese Quadrokopter
in so Bomben umbauen kann.
Und das haben sie uns da gezeigt, was da so ihr Design ist und was so ihre Design-Constraints,
sind, um diese Dinger möglichst günstig, möglichst schnell,
möglichst unter Verwendung aller ihren zur Verfügung stehenden Ressourcen auch
bauen zu können, weil ihre Ressourcen sind halt weder besonders vielfältig noch unbegrenzt.
Ja, und Und die produzieren dann aber viel und da laufen dann halt immer Leute
rein, laden sich ein paar Dinge in den Koffer und gehen dann wieder irgendwo anders hin damit.
Ja, also das ist im Wesentlichen so eine Integrationstätigkeit, die sie dort machen.
Die entwickeln jetzt nicht die komplette Steuersoftware selber,
aber müssen sich dann halt aus verschiedensten Quellen bedienen und versuchen
irgendwie genug zu bekommen und das dann halt zu machen und optimieren dann
sozusagen diese Drohnen dafür.
Und das ist ein Vorgang, der an vielen Stellen, glaube ich, stattfindet.
Habt ihr da auch über das Thema elektronische Kampfführung oder Störsender jetzt geredet?
Ja, weil mich hat natürlich interessiert, inwiefern dieses Thema Machine Learning
und AI da schon eine Rolle spielt bei den Drohnen, dass man die halt alle jetzt
so direkt fliegen kann, ferngesteuert mit so Standardkontrollern, das ist ja eh klar.
Man kann sagen ja, es ist ein großes Thema und da sitzen auch alle dran und das ist irgendwie,
gibt es schon verschiedene Versuche, aber derzeit findet das nur in sehr eingeschränktem
Maße, wenn überhaupt, statt.
Also jetzt bei diesen Kamikaze Drohnen geht es ja, wie ich vorhin schon gesagt
habe, geht es ja im Wesentlichen darum,
schnell ein vorher ausgewähltes Ziel dann auch zu erreichen und dann möglichst
punktgenau die Stelle zu treffen, wo du dann eben wirklich dem Fahrzeug auch
idealen Schaden zufügen kannst.
So ein Panzer ist meistens angreifbarer von hinten, weil er da weniger gepanzert
ist und solche Geschichten.
Und da eben jetzt so viele Fahrzeuge, wie ich vorhin schon gesagt habe,
mit so einem Electronic Warfare Shield ausgestattet werden, also quasi so ein lokaler Störsender,
der dann eben die Fernsteuerung der Drohne versucht zu kappen auf diesen letzten
entscheidenden Metern.
Was weiß ich wie viel, 50, 100 Meter, irgendwie sowas, ist das jetzt sozusagen die Herausforderung.
Was sie also jetzt gerne realisieren würden ist,
dass so eine Kamikaze Drohne quasi im Endanflug, in dem Moment,
wo das Objekt schon gesehen wird, in der Lage ist,
auch bei Kappung der Fernbedienungsverbindung noch eigenständig das Ziel zu erreichen.
Das sind so die Maßnahmen, die dort sind und diese Störsender,
Electronic Warfare Systeme finden wohl in zunehmendem Maße dort Verbreitungen
und sind so Teil dieser gegenseitigen technologischen Aufrüstung.
Ja, man kann das ja teilweise sehen in den Filmen von den Kamikaze-Drohnen,
dass je näher die kommen, umso mehr Bildstörungen siehst du halt.
Und ich habe angenommen, dass das wahrscheinlich genau mit eben Störsendern zu tun hat.
Und generell das Thema, die Störfestigkeit zu erhöhen oder so,
das war jetzt nicht das Thema.
Aber da ist natürlich das Problem mit einerseits Standardkomponenten,
die eher für den Zivilbereich sind und jetzt so militärische Funkverbindungen.
Die verwenden einfach die ganz normalen Standardcontroller und das ist halt das Problem.
Du musst halt dann zu diesem ganzen Standardkram kompatibel bleiben und damit
sind eigentlich die Frequenzen und wie du sie benutzt sind mehr oder weniger
vorgegeben. Weil du kannst jetzt nicht noch anfangen und diese Fernsteuersysteme
auch noch komplett neu zu ingenieren.
Das mag vielleicht für einzelne Military Drones der Fall sein,
die dann nochmal gehärtet sind,
aber wir reden ja hier wirklich von einem Markt, der eben versucht mit den billigstmöglichen
Komponenten so eine Kamikaze Drohne zu machen.
Also die Drohnen, die ich da gesehen habe, die kosten so 380 Dollar am Ende.
Da ist halt Batterie, also ohne Sprengladung natürlich.
Also Batterie, die ganze Drohne, Propeller und so weiter, alles dabei.
Ja, verstehe. Und die waren eher jetzt so auf Kamikaze-Drohnen oder auf kleine,
spezialisiert jetzt keine größeren Dinger, die man ja auch gesehen hat.
Nein, nein, das ist, größere Teile, das ist dann halt schon wirklich die Militärproduktion.
Das ist wirklich, ich kam da rein und es sah einfach da aus,
also Startup jetzt nicht im Sinne von, dass es alles so hip designed ist,
sondern ganz im Gegenteil, da war gar nichts designed.
Das war einfach so ein bland Büroraum, so langweilig, wie man sich das irgendwie
vorstellen kann. und alle saßen dann nur an ihren Tischen und waren irgendwie
am Basteln und am Machen und am Tun.
Also da legt man nicht groß Wert auf irgendeine, da ging es einfach nur um Machen,
Machen, Machen. Die wirkten alle sehr unausgeschlafen irgendwie.
Ich habe da noch mit so einem Typen, der diese Integration in Software macht,
der mir das mit dem AI noch näher erlegt hat, der musste dann auch noch kurz
geweckt werden, weil die da sozusagen auch im Schichtbetrieb,
die machen da nichts anderes. Also die sind,
24-7 irgendwie in diesem ganzen Produktionsding, weil sie auch sagen,
sie sind in einem permanenten technologischen Wettlauf.
Die Regeln auf dem Kriegsfeld werden alle drei Monate neu definiert.
Und wenn du nicht die ganze Zeit weiterentwickelst und auf die Entwicklung in
irgendeiner Form in deinem Development Einfluss nimmst, dann verlierst du diesen gegenseitigen Krieg.
Und die Produktion war überwiegend Handarbeit oder gab es da dann was?
Es war ein Entwicklungsstandort. Die Produktion war woanders.
Das war jetzt nur da, wo sie das Development machen, die Integration machen.
Und ich habe gefragt, wo produziert der mal denn nur woanders?
Also das ist auch so ein Ort, da gehst du hin, da schaltest du dann irgendwie
wie dein Geotagging bei den Fotos aus und so weiter.
Also da ist man dann schon so ein bisschen vorsichtiger, weil das halt alles
so potenzielle Ziele sind.
Die waren da jetzt nicht besonders gefährdet, aber man kann ja nie vorsichtiger sein.
Ja, verstehe.
Ja.
Ja, das war Kief jetzt.
Das war Kief, der erste richtige Kieftag, weil der Rest war jetzt nur Fahrerei
und Der erste richtige Besuchstag war ja Tscherniv.
Dann zweiter Tag war nochmal komplett Kiew.
Da hatten wir dann über einen Kontakt beim Militärhistorischen Museum.
Ennur ist ja selber der sehr bekannt durch diese Ausstellung von dem Panzer
vor der russischen Botschaft.
Damit hat er sich da auf jeden Fall einen Namen gemacht und hat ja mit seinem Berlin Story Museum,
mit seiner Hitler Ausstellung ohnehin Museumserfahrung und da auch gerade eine
Sonderausstellung zum Ukraine Krieg mit den Memes, also den Internet Memes rund um diesen Krieg.
Also man kann da jetzt hingehen, Berlin Story und sich das anschauen.
Und das Militärhistorische Museum in Kiew, das Militärhistorische Museum hat
einen Teil dieser Ausstellung wiederum übernommen.
Also sie haben sozusagen seine Memensammlung genommen, vom Deutschen wieder
ins Ukrainische übertragen und das war dann auch Teil der Ausstellung dort.
Und da herrschten also gute Beziehungen und über den Weg war es dann für uns
möglich, am nächsten Tag einen Besuch auf dem Hostomail Airport zu machen.
Also der Hostomail.
Flughafen, der eigentlich im Wesentlichen ein Entwicklungsstandort ist,
der Antonow Flugzeugproduktionsfirma und wo eben der Krieg begann.
Wo die ersten Hubschrauber reingeflogen sind und wo die russischen Spezialkräfte
versucht haben, die Ukrainer zu überwältigen und diesen Flughafen in Angriff zu nehmen,
als um dort dann sozusagen Flugzeuge landen zu können und dort den Einmarsch zu machen.
Und das wurde ja durch so eine Truppe von 150 Ukrainern, die dort stationiert wurden, verhindert.
Die haben den ja so hart zugesetzt und dann auch in schneller Zeit mit ihrer
eigenen Artillerie die Landebäume zerstört, sodass es den Russen nicht möglich
war, über diesen Flughafen einzudringen.
Das war vielleicht die wichtigste Schlacht überhaupt am Anfang.
Ja, wir hatten ja irgendwie, glaube ich, auch sieben Transportflugzeuge waren
schon im Anflug, die dann umdrehen mussten, von denen dann auch eins abgeschossen
wurde, glaube ich, so habe ich das zumindest in Erinnerung.
Wir haben da ja auch vor zwei Jahren irgendwie eine Sendung drüber gemacht und
ja, die Schlacht um Hostomel ist auf jeden Fall eine, die ja schon jetzt Eingang
in die Geschichtsbücher gefunden hat.
Und ja, wahrscheinlich eine der frühen, ich sag mal, Entscheidungsschlachten
war so, um Kiew zu retten.
Weil wenn die da jetzt dann die Truppen eingeflogen hätten, wer weiß, was dann passiert wäre.
Das war schon wirklich kriegsentscheidend. Es gab halt jemanden,
der uns die Story erzählt hat und sie hatten auch einen von der Truppe dabei,
also haben sie zumindest gesagt, der dann selber nochmal berichtet hat,
wie das da abgelaufen ist und das Ganze fand statt direkt neben dem Wrack der Miria, des größten.
Flugzeugs der Welt, was ja bei diesem Angriff zerstört wurde.
Dieser Antonov, wie heißt der, war in einer Zahl,
genannt Miria, also der Traum sozusagen und so auch so ein bisschen das Symbol
dieses Kriegs und das Ding steht da halt komplett zerschossen,
ausgebrannt, noch unter diesem Hangar.
Wird jetzt gerade so schrittweise dismantelt.
Die.
Flügel waren so zur Seite geräumt, die werden vielleicht dann nochmal,
es gibt noch eine zweite, die nie fertig gebaut wurde, dann sein,
dass sie sozusagen diese ganzen Teile, weil da besteht nur der Rumpf und dann,
vermute, dass sie die Flügel von der richtigen Maschine an die andere ran machen
und daraus nochmal so ein Modell machen, das irgendwo hinstellen.
Die wird wahrscheinlich nie fliegen, weil es macht jetzt einfach keinen Sinn,
so ein altes Flugzeug nochmal komplett zu ingenieren.
Ja, aber das war sehr interessant zu sehen, auch auf dem Flughafen ist noch
so einiges an Zerstörung,
zu sehen und Auswirkungen von diesen Kämpfen und auf dem Rückweg sind wir dann,
da das ja genau da ist, noch durch Butscha, wo es diese Massaker gab und Irpin,
zurückgefahren und haben halt gesehen wie eben diese, also ich bin auch diese
Straße lang gefahren, wo dieses berühmte Bild entstanden ist mit diesen ganzen
zusammengeschossenen Panzern da ist natürlich kein einziger mehr davon da du
fährst durch diese Straße und du merkst,
dass du in dieser Straße bist weil links und rechts alle Häuser perfekt restauriert
sind also sozusagen da wurde richtig viel Energie reingeschickt um sozusagen
dieses zerstörte Butcher um diese Zahnlücke sozusagen zu entfernen auch so als
Symbol für ihr könnt uns gar nichts Nichts.
Also wir werden hier auch immer wieder auferstehen.
Da habe ich jetzt nicht viel Zeit verbracht. Wir sind dann langsam durchgefahren,
einfach um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen.
Und ja, das war dann auch nochmal sehr...
Dann bin ich noch ein bisschen durch Kiew gezogen, habe mir halt alles mögliche angeschaut,
was da noch so an Museen und Parks und so weiter ist und für anderen war dann
auch Kiew wirklich umfangreich abgeklappert und abgegrast.
Rast. Genau und dann war so die Überlegung, was machen wir jetzt noch und dann
sind wir irgendwie am nächsten Tag weiter nach Odessa gefahren.
Auf dem Weg dahin, auf halber Strecke gibt es dann noch einen interessanten
Ort, wo wir nochmal Rast gemacht haben, nämlich das Museum für der strategischen
Raketenkräfte, wie es so schön heißt.
Und das ist ein alter Standort, wo die Atomraketen, die russischen oder sowjetischen
Atomraketen, die auf den Westen gerichtet waren, gelagert waren.
Aber nicht gelagert, sondern da waren sie sozusagen am Start.
So, riesige Raketen, die in den Boden in so einem Startplatz eingelassen wurden
und wo dann so unterirdische Kontrollsysteme, Tunnelsysteme und Kontrollräume waren.
Also Raketensilos. Raketen-Silos.
Ja und das ist halt in so ein Museum umgewandelt worden, da gab es also ganz
viele von diesen Silos, das ist dann halt hier reduziert worden auf zwei,
der Rest ist halt komplett zerstört worden im Rahmen des Abkommens,
was ja damals die Ukraine mit Russland gehabt hat, Budapester Mineralum,
hier Atomraketen, alles was hier an Atomraketeninfrastruktur ist und an Raketen
selber, wird jetzt hier mal schön zerstört.
Und fein säuberlich hier entweder per Explosion oder Zuschüttung und Betonierung
und so weiter unbrauchbar gemacht.
Und was übrig geblieben ist, ist halt nur dieses Museum, wo man dann eben noch
in diese alten Tunnel rein konnte.
Und wir sind dann da so rein und hatten riesiges Glück, weil es hat natürlich
dort keiner Englisch gesprochen, sondern alle nur irgendwie Russisch oder so.
Und gerade als wir reinkamen.
Das ist ja auch irgendwo im Nirgendwo, durch Zufall einen Berliner YouTuber gefunden,
der irgendwie halb Russe war und irgendwie perfekt Russisch sprach und sich
das auch gerade anschauen wollte, sodass wir dann sozusagen unseren persönlichen
Übersetzer noch mit dabei hatten.
Also eine Abfolge von Glücksmomenten war einfach unglaublich.
Naja, so konnten wir uns das alles ausführlich erläutern lassen,
sind dann irgendwie mit so einem.
Fahrstuhl auch irgendwie so, also erstmal kommst du runter in so einen Tunnel, ewig lange Gänge,
dicke Türen und dann fährst du nochmal mit dem Fahrstuhl sozusagen parallel
zu diesem Raketensilo nochmal ein paar sechs Etagen nach unten und es wirkt dann als wärst du auf der,
ISS oder auf der russischen Mir, so wirkte das weißt du, alles total eng für
drei Leute, die dann wirklich 24-7 so in Schichten da unten,
die ganze Zeit vor Ort waren für den Fall dass jetzt gleich in fünf Minuten
die Raketen gestartet werden müssen.
Mit den Original-Tastengeräten, computerartigen Installationen und so weiter,
um das alles irgendwie zu starten.
Als besonderes Highlight darfst du dann diese Launch-Sequenz auch mal durchführen irgendwie.
Aber flog dann nichts los.
Ja, das haben wir uns noch angeschaut. Das war auch ganz beeindruckend.
Und dann ging es weiter nach Odessa, in so einem Hotel einquartiert haben, schön am Meer.
Aber ich dachte, dann sieht man die Raketen zumindest ranfliegen.
Ich dachte nicht, dass man das dann wirklich sehen würde, aber so war es dann.
Denn in der Nacht gab es dann tatsächlich Luftalarm in Odessa.
Und Enno war dann pfiffig genug, in dem Moment auch gleich oben aufs Dach zu
steigen und hat dann tatsächlich, Tatsächlich, ich war, ich dachte so,
ja Luftalarm, ich muss schlafen.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich war nicht beunruhigt oder so. Ich dachte mir so, ach Luftalarm, Telefon wieder so laut.
War dann aber irgendwie geradezu dizzy, um in dem Moment so dieses so,
ich ziehe mich jetzt an, ich gucke mal, was da wirklich passiert ist.
Auf jeden Fall gab es dann tatsächlich einen Angriff mit Shahed-Drohnen auf
Odessa und die Luftabwehr war halt aktiv und aktiv.
Auch so ein Video gepostet, wo dann halt die ganze Zeit die Luftabwehr war und
wo dann eben mehrere von diesen Shahed-Drohnen abgeschossen wurden.
Aber erst am nächsten Morgen haben wir dann rausgefunden, dass dann doch zwei
wohl durchgekommen sind und eine davon ist halt in so einem Wohnhaus gelandet.
Und dann nach ein bisschen Recherchieren haben wir dann auch rausgefunden,
wo das war und sind dann da hingefahren und haben uns die Auswirkungen angeschaut.
Das war halt einfach so ein neunstöckiges Wohnhaus im Mitteln von so einer Wohnhaussiedlung.
So ein bisschen wie diese Hochhäuser da in Marzahn. Ist ein bisschen weiter
draußen von Odessa gewesen, nicht jetzt in der City.
City. Die Drohne hat das so in der Mitte getroffen und dann ist so die ganze,
Seitenfront von dem Haus eingefallen und da sind dann auch ein paar Leute bei
ums Leben gekommen, weitere Verletzte und,
du kommst dann halt so rein in diese Situation, wo halt die Rettungsmannschaften
da schon seit Stunden am Arbeiten waren und halt Stück für Stück,
Stein für Stein von diesem,
Müllhaufen, der von diesem Haus da an der Stelle übrig geblieben ist,
abgetrugen, um noch irgendwelche Verletzte und Überlebende zu finden.
Ja, ich hatte das halt nur dann in der Presse verfolgt.
Da war dann auch, ich glaube Klitschko ist dann auch hingefahren.
Selenskyj ist dann noch mit dem griechischen Minister dahin.
Achso, nee, aber sozusagen während, ich glaube während der Aufräumarbeiten,
noch, oder ich weiß nicht, wer es genau war, aber oder der Bürgermeister,
nee, ich glaube, der Bürgermeister von Odessa war dann irgendwie da und,
erzählte halt, was irgendwie passiert ist und ich glaube, dass unter den Opfern
auch eine große Zahl von Kindern gewesen ist.
Also ein dreijähriges Kind und dann sind Familien irgendwie umgekommen.
Ja, das war irgendwie auch,
unwirklich, irgendwie, dass ich das so live anzuschauen, weil wenn du dann so
dabei stehst, dann wirkt das auf so eine gewisse Art und Weise so,
wie soll ich denn das sagen?
Also klar ist das irgendwie schockierend und du siehst halt so.
Was da passiert ist.
Aber was mich wirklich in dem Moment eigentlich am meisten,
beeindruckt hat, also im Sinne von, oder am meisten Wirkung bei mir erzielt
hat, war nicht so sehr das, was ich, was alle gezeigt haben,
nämlich dieses Haus und diese Auswirkungen und die Rettungsarbeiten,
sondern was ich mir vor allem angeschaut
habe war so die leute die drumherum standen
das war natürlich da hunderte von menschen die diesen aufräumarbeiten zuschauten
aus sicherem abstand natürlich hinter den absperrung aber die halt alle so eine
ja also ich hab halt alles es gab Es gab halt einfach so Leute,
die einfach mit so einem leeren Blick das Ganze verfolgt haben.
Und du merkst es so, die wissen einfach, dass es dieser Krieg ist, wie seit zwei Jahren.
Wir wollen den loswerden und so ist es.
Andere, die halt völlig, je nachdem wie sehr sie vielleicht auch die Leute dort
kannten, die dort gewohnt haben, Dann auch entsprechend bestürzt waren und andere,
die sich auf die Rettungsarbeiten konzentriert haben.
Und da merkte ich halt auch nochmal dieses Gefühl,
dass man so fed up ist mit diesem Krieg, dass man das einfach alles nicht mehr
haben will, dass man jetzt irgendwie es bestürzt zur Kenntnis nimmt,
dass man jetzt wieder unmittelbar betroffen war, dass es einen morgen selber
erwischen kann und das alles.
Und ja, und so Wut oder Aggression war jetzt nicht zu sehen.
Die Wut ist eh allgegenwärtig.
Überall siehst du halt Graffitis mit Fuck Putin und irgendwie Russian Worship, Go Fuck Yourself.
Das ist halt einfach, das Land hat da einfach keine Karten mehr.
Das ist einfach jeder Standard.
Die Verachtung für Russland ist einfach maximal.
Trotzdem versucht jeder auch sein Leben einfach zu verleben.
Was willst du machen? Du musst auch eine gewisse Normalität versuchen beizubehalten,
damit du nicht durchdrehst.
Und deshalb merkte man die Kriegsfolgen schon sehr viel mehr an als in Kiew.
Kiew ist Groß Kief ist derzeit relativ sicher und Kief ist gut geschützt und
deshalb ist halt dann doch sehr nah eben noch in Reichweite eben dieser Shahed-Drohnen
immer wieder ein Ziel und man merkt auch, wenn man durch die Stadt fährt,
auch wenn es da auch eine lebendige Innenstadt gibt, aber du siehst halt einfach,
das ist eine Stadt, die normalerweise einen großen Tourismus-Andrang hat und
die daraufhin optimiert ist.
Und du siehst halt viele leerstehende Lagerhäuser, sehr viele leerstehende Geschäfte,
wo einfach so ein bisschen die Seele rausgeklopft ist.
Also du merkst einfach, dass diese Stadt vielleicht auf 10 oder 20 Prozent ihrer
Kapazität fährt und dass die einfach wirtschaftlich in jeder Hinsicht leidet.
So, ne, trotzdem hast du auch da wieder Bars und Leben und Kultur und bin mir
sicher in den Kellern laufen wahrscheinlich die die krassesten Partys irgendwie
aber da war ich noch nicht.
Ja und dann ging es wieder zurück und war dann nach acht Tagen wieder in der,
in unserem satten Westen dem das irgendwie alles manchmal nicht so richtig dich
zu kratzen scheint, hat man so den Eindruck.
Ja, und man hat halt auch gemerkt, so, ich hab mal Fernseher angemacht und mal
so geguckt, was so auf den Kanälen so läuft.
Und das war schon irgendwie, also abgesehen davon, dass du natürlich auch da
deine Mischung aus Fernsehserie, Filmchen, dieses und jenes anschaust,
aber wenn du, aber alle Nachrichtensendungen, es gab so ein,
zwei Sender, da hab ich irgendwie gar nichts anderes gefunden,
Fernseher an Scholz, Taurus, Taurus Scholz, Scholz, Deutschland,
Scholz was ist mit Scholz was erlaube Scholz Taurus also,
Die Ukrainer sind mit Sicherheit für jede Hilfe dankbar,
aber teilweise verzweifeln sie auch an der Ignoranz und dem geringen Verständnis für ihre Situation,
die sich leider in den Handlungen Einzelner immer wieder Bahn bricht.
Und bei Deutschland sind sie sich glaube ich auch irgendwie nicht so richtig sicher.
Das ist ein schwieriges Verhältnis und zu dem Zeitpunkt hat halt einfach gerade
diese Debatte um die Äußerung von Scholz offensichtlich so einen Höhepunkt erreicht gehabt.
Also ich habe ja nur so ein kleines Sample, was ich da nehmen konnte,
aber das ist definitiv etwas, was da schon alles irgendwie definiert hat.
Aber interessant, mit welcher Aufmerksamkeit dann dort wahrscheinlich verfolgt
wird, was im Ausland auch passiert.
Also du kannst davon ausgehen, dass die Ukraine den politischen Äußerungen in
Deutschland um diesen Krieg deutlich mehr Aufmerksamkeit geschickt wird als
Deutschland. Deutschland.
Und überhaupt haben die,
glaube ich, ich meine es ist ja immer so, die kleineren Länder schauen auf die
Großen immer sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit und dementsprechend weiß die USA
ja auch immer am wenigsten, was um sie herum passiert,
während wir immer denken, wir wissen ja alles über die USA und teilweise ist es vielleicht auch so.
Ja, andererseits haben andere Länder uns gegenüber dasselbe Verhältnis und sehen
Sachen, die wir vielleicht nicht
so sehen, weil wir dann doch lieber in unserem eigenen Saft schmoren.
Aber dieses, was da einfach keiner verstehen kann, und das ist ja auch das,
wo ich auch so ein bisschen dran verzweifle, ist, für die ist es nicht ein Konflikt in der Ukraine,
sondern für die Ukraine ist vollkommen klar,
dass erstens, wenn sie aufhören sich zu wehren, dann sind sie vernichtet als Volk, als Land.
Und danach sind die anderen dran.
Das ist kein Krieg gegen die Ukraine. Das ist ein Krieg gegen Europa.
Und Europa schnallt das nicht.
Also es geht langsam los und wir werden ja jetzt auch, glaube ich,
auch jetzt nochmal drüber reden, wie eigentlich die politische Situation sich
um die Ukraine herum entwickelt hat.
Ja
Bevor wir dann nochmal zu Scholz kommen.
Ja.
Also ich habe ja schon gesagt, gute Nachricht, am 11.
März in vier Tagen wird vermutlich Schweden offiziell in die NATO aufgenommen worden sein,
nachdem Türkei und Ungarn sich dann doch mal bequemt haben, dem zuzustimmen,
was ja eh eigentlich irgendwie immer klar war, weil es mussten halt noch tausend
Sachen raushandeln, die Wichser.
Und auch in der EU tut sich ja so einiges in den ganzen Debatten,
man merkt einfach bestimmte Länder,
gehen den nächsten Schritt zu Finnland, hat die Grenze zu Russland geschlossen,
bis vielleicht auf einen Übergang, weil die Russen ja die ganze Zeit irgendwelche,
Asylsuchende über die Grenze geschleppt haben, um da Druck zu erzeugen ähnliche
Situation bei den baltischen Staaten, den man eh nicht erklären muss was Russland ist.
Die haben jetzt unter anderem verfügt, ich glaube, Estland oder Litauen,
ich weiß es nicht, hat jetzt verfügt, dass sämtliche Fahrzeuge mit russischen
Kennzeichen das Land verlassen müssen.
Wenn du zu schnell fährst und dein Auto wird beschlagnahmt in Estland,
dann wird es auch gleich in die Ukraine geschickt.
Das ist sehr pragmatisch. Ja,
aber Aber Ungarn hatte ich nur jetzt eben auch mitbekommen, dass die jetzt auch
nicht nur den NATO-Beitritt zugestimmt haben,
sondern auch dem EU-Hilfspaket von, ich glaube, 52 Milliarden oder so.
Wobei das ja jetzt nicht für Waffen gedacht ist in erster Linie,
sondern für die Vorbereitung auf den EU-Beitritt, soweit ich das richtig verfolgt. habe.
Ja, jedes Geld hilft auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Also insofern ja,
geht es, also es ist zumindest die EU jetzt kein Totalausfall so und,
hat Das hat wahrscheinlich jetzt auch mit der Situation in den USA zu tun,
dass man in Europa jetzt ein bisschen wacher geworden ist.
Aber, ja, ich meine, gut, die Gesamtsituation oder den Folgen,
was passiert, wenn die Ukraine verlieren sollte,
in Anführungszeichen, was jetzt nicht unmittelbar passiert.
Aber da macht sich offenbar auch niemand oder unsere Regierung scheint sich
auch irgendwie keine Gedanken darum zu machen,
was das für uns bedeuten würde und zwar ganz unmittelbar.
Nämlich angefangen, also wenn jetzt plötzlich die Front zusammenbricht und die
Russen irgendwie den riesen Vormarsch starten, dann können wir damit rechnen,
dass wir wahrscheinlich 10 bis 20 Millionen Flüchtlinge erstmal hier aufnehmen können.
Dagegen ist das, was am Kriegsanfang war, so, also das ist, damit würde das
erstmal unmittelbar anfangen.
Bis hin, wo es dann endet, ist,
dass dann wahrscheinlich die verbleibende, weiß ich nicht, Hälfte der ukrainischen
Bevölkerung dann im Dienste Russlands dann irgendwann uns gegenüber steht.
Ja, das sagen die, dass dann Russland die Ukraine benutzt, um den Westen anzugreifen.
Zwar nicht nur militärisch, sondern auch wirtschaftlich mit den Ressourcen,
dem Getreide, mit allem.
Ja, mit den Rohstoffen, mit allem.
Also das wäre ein dermaßenes Desaster. Plus, dass natürlich jetzt auch die Chinesen
genau gucken, was macht der Westen. Also die gucken da ganz genau hin.
Und ich sage die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn...
Dort den Chinesen klar wird, ach, der Westen ist sowieso, also der,
macht nichts, dann ist als nächstes, ganz davon ausgehen, dann ist wahrscheinlich
Taiwan dran mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit und dann sind wir in einer,
Situation, wo wir dann wirklich uns in einem heißen Krieg plötzlich befinden.
Und dann haben wir tatsächlich den Dritten Weltkrieg.
Ja, und das scheinen sich viele Leute nicht vorzustellen, dass die Kriegsgefahr eigentlich steigt,
wenn wir nicht die Ukraine entsprechend ausreichend unterstützen,
sodass das in eine globale Katastrophe führen würde.
Wobei das natürlich, was wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal passiert,
aber das machen wir vielleicht am Ende, so die Erwartung für dieses Jahr.
Wir vielleicht dann am Ende nochmal sprechen. Aber eigentlich ist das,
ja, also ich verstehe es halt auch nicht.
Und gerade jetzt Scholz, weil wir dabei sind,
so kann ich wirklich nicht nachvollziehen, diese Angst oder diese Kurzsichtigkeit.
Und ich habe,
seit Jahrzehnten nicht rechts von der Mitte gewählt, also keine CDU.
Aber mittlerweile, so bin ich an dem Punkt, dass ich mir fast wünschen würde,
wir hätten irgendwie eine konservative Regierung und nicht irgendwie diese SPD, die, keine Ahnung,
kompromittiert oder in der Geschichte verfangen ist wegen Brandts Ostpolitik und so all das.
Da hängen sie offenbar noch dran.
Was auch immer der Grund ist, dass sie nicht reagieren.
Ja, plus bis hin zur Linken jetzt, was von der Linken jetzt mittlerweile teilweise
kommt, da dreht sich mir wirklich alles um,
was da kommt.
Also die Linke ist, ich meine, hatte für die Linke auch einiges an Sympathie
in meiner Zeit im Abgeordnetenhaus,
habe ich die da, was ist ich, Lederer und so, waren alles pragmatische,
intelligente Leute, die, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, ja, sie sind vernünftig.
Aber offensichtlich haben da jetzt auch zunehmend jetzt mehr irgendwelche Extremisten
entweder die Aufmerksamkeit.
Also ja, die Linke ist für mich jetzt absolut zum roten Tuch geworden.
Und ja, die kann meinetwegen, ja, kann man meinetwegen beerdigen.
Und zum Glück spielt sich, ja, egal, gut, aber das ist so kleiner, kleiner.
Ich verstehe deinen Ärger, mir geht es ähnlich.
Man fragt sich wirklich, was bitte hier die Marschrichtung ist und wo diese
Russland-Versteherei eigentlich herkommt.
Wir können auch so mal so ein Interview verlinken, was so mit so einem deutschen
Professor, der auch aus Ostdeutschland ist, der aber in den USA lehrt,
geführt wurde online, der meint, Ostdeutschland ist einfach da auch in dieser
speziellen Situation gefangen.
Auf der einen Seite ist es noch so ein bisschen so Stockholm-Syndrom,
man war halt von diesen Russen besetzt und auch in so eine Zwangsliebe verordnet.
Die einem irgendwie eine Nähe reingeimpft hat, von der man sich wahrscheinlich
jetzt nicht mehr so richtig trennen kann.
Deswegen kommt halt auch immer so dieses, ja, aber man muss ja auch mal die Russen verstehen.
Wo ich mich frage, was gibt es da zu verstehen? Ich meine, die fallen in ein
Land ein und bringen alle Leute um. Um irgendwie das dann einfach mal Schluss mit verstehen.
Und dann auch mit dieser merkwürdigen Identitätskrise des Ostens gepaart,
einfach eine Unfähigkeit entwickelt, hier in irgendeiner Form noch richtig zu reagieren.
Dazu kommt halt auch noch dieser auch oft etwas, wie soll ich sagen,
etwas dünn argumentierte paranoide Grundverhalten der USA gegenüber und diesem imperialen Denken.
Es ist ja auch so ein Denkmuster, die sich in den 80er Jahren natürlich verstärkt hat,
dass irgendwie ja die USA sozusagen die imperiale Bedrohung ist und sicherlich
kann man der USA eine Menge vorwerfen,
was sie sozusagen in den letzten Jahrzehnten alles so vergeigt haben von Vietnam
bis irgendwie Irakkrieg und was nicht alles.
Es gibt genug, was man dem Land vorwerfen kann,
aber das dann sozusagen gegeneinander aufzuwägen und da so eine Balance hinzustellen,
wo man einfach keine Balance herstellen kann.
Weil einfach so ein durchgeführter Genozid geht halt einfach nicht.
Da kann man nicht mit so einem Whataboutism, ja aber in den USA hat ja auch
jemand das und das gesagt.
Ja, scheiß drauf, wir müssen jetzt hier einfach mal verhindern,
dass ein Land komplett ausgelöscht wird und eine Kultur ausgelöscht wird.
Da sind dann alle Debatten so ein bisschen sinnlos in dieser Richtung.
Naja, also um es vielleicht kurz abzurunden, dieser Blick auf die Politik des
Westens, man ist sich nicht einig, aber die Sache kommt auch in Bewegung.
Langsam, aber in Bewegung. Gerade die jüngsten Äußerungen von Macron.
Die halt schon mal versucht haben zu formulieren, Leute, wir müssen jetzt hier
mit unseren Dogmen mal ein bisschen aufräumen und ich kann mir sehr wohl vorstellen,
dass wir auch in der Ukraine selbst mal aktiv werden.
Womit er ja nicht gesagt hat, wir müssen jetzt mit NATO-Truppen an die Front.
Das ist klar, dass das keine Option ist. Das würde auch die Ukraine nicht wollen im Übrigen.
Aber es gibt ja auch noch genug andere Optionen. Ob das nun Ausbildung mit Training
ist auf der einen Seite oder auch solche fortgeschrittenen Ideen.
Wie, was heißt fortgeschritten, also fortgeschritten im Sinne,
das wäre ein Fortschritt, wenn man sie umsetzen würde, aus meiner Perspektive,
zum Beispiel, dass die Nordgrenze zu Weißrussland durch,
Truppen von NATO-Ländern, nicht der NATO an sich, aber eben Westverbündeten
der Ukraine gesichert werden, um entsprechend Ressourcen freizumachen für den
Krieg oder was auch immer.
Es gibt genug Möglichkeiten der Unterstützung und das, was halt bisher geliefert
wird, ist im Vergleich zu dem, was die Länder liefern könnten oder was die Länder
leisten könnten. Sagen wir es mal so, es geht nicht ums Liefern primär, es geht ums Leisten.
Da ist noch viel zu holen und man muss sich halt einfach mal von diesem Bild trennen können,
dass wir jetzt in irgendeiner Form, dass es jetzt irgendwie eine Gefahr wäre,
durch irgendeine Maßnahme zur Kriegspartei gestempelt zu werden von Putin.
Für Putin sind wir sowieso der Feind.
Sie schaltet mal das Fernsehen ein. Die erzählen den ganzen Tag,
dass sie morgen gerne Atomraketen auf Berlin senden würden.
Das ist der Grad an Diskussionen, der da in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet.
So mit unserem kleinen, kleinen und hohen, weil wenn wir jetzt hier irgendwie
den kleinen Schritt 50 Zentimeter zu weit nach links machen,
dann könnte man uns ja vielleicht vorwerfen, wir wären irgendwie ein bisschen böse.
Das interessiert die überhaupt nicht.
Für Putin gibt es nur eine Sprache. Das ist halt einfach Macht und konkrete Handlung.
Das ist das Einzige, was den beeindruckt. Wenn man stark auftritt,
dann ist das für ihn relevant. Aber in dem Moment, wo man die ganze Zeit sich
nur rausredet und sagt, das können wir aber jetzt nicht machen,
das hat die falsche Farbe für mich.
Das interessiert ihn gar nicht und das ist genau das, was er eben auch beflügelt
durch die Propaganda, durch diese ganzen Talking Points, die hier durch solche
Russland-Versteher verbreitet werden.
Ob sie dafür bezahlt werden oder nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Jetzt macht man den Eindruck, aber ist auch egal.
Und das soll halt einfach nur unsere Debatte vernebeln und genau das geschieht
halt. Und so hat die russische Propaganda schon immer funktioniert.
Und was aber auch bemerkenswert ist, dass diese Russland-Verstehen oder Russland-Sympathien,
auf beiden politischen Extremen offenbar auf viel Resonanz stoßen.
Also sowohl jetzt, was so AfD angeht, gibt es da einen großen Teil von Russlandverstehern
und bei der Linken aber offenbar genauso.
Und gerade die Linken, natürlich, wenn man dort die Hufeisentheorie erwähnt,
Das ist so ein Reizwort, aber eigentlich bestätigt sich die immer wieder oder
zumindest an dieser Stelle jetzt, was das Verhältnis zu Ukraine angeht, ist,
dass Nazis und Linksextremisten mehr miteinander gemein haben,
als sie glauben oder als sie irgendwie wahrhaben wollen.
So, ja. Und ja, jeder, der irgendwie jetzt Linksympathien hat,
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich ins Essen kotzen, weil ich das gesagt habe.
Aber so nehme ich das wahr und ich finde, das ist auch keine unzulässige Vereinfachung an der Stelle.
Sondern da sind halt Leute, die irgendwie auf beiden Seiten gerne einerseits
von Demokratie und Beteiligung und die Leute reden,
aber eigentlich alle denen, ich sag mal,
doch auf der Suche nach irgendwie dann dem starken Mann oder Sympathien dann
für den starken Mann und Autokratie und einer gewissen Demokratieverachtung
in Wirklichkeit daherkommen.
Und ja.
Das ist am Ende genau das Appeasement, was irgendwie damals auch Hitler stark gemacht hat.
Hitler hat ein paar Länder überfallen und alle so, ja, das muss man sich nicht
so ernst nehmen und so weiter.
Da passiert schon nichts. Es ist ja nur das Sudetenland.
Und ja, haben wir ja dann gesehen, was dabei herauskommt. Mit Putin ist es halt genauso.
Ja, ich meine, was ich vielleicht noch ansatzweise nachvollziehen kann, so als Kalkül,
dass man jetzt also Russland
hat ja jetzt nicht den totalen Krieg erklärt sondern es ist nach wie vor ich
sag mal auch für Russland sagen die begrenzt die Ressourcen die es dort einsetzt
keine Generalmobilmachung und hatten wir ja vorhin auch schon das heißt.
Russland versucht es halt,
sagen, irgendwie sich zu arrangieren mit dem ganzen Ding und das nicht zu sehr,
nicht zu teuer werden zu lassen.
Und auf westlicher Seite habe ich das Gefühl, versucht man sich auch gerade damit zu arrangieren.
Also man versucht eigentlich nicht den Krieg zu beenden oder hätte es am liebsten
irgendwie, wenn das jetzt so weitergeht und sich möglichst nichts verändert und möchte nicht,
dass Russland dann irgendwie den nächsten Schritt geht.
Aber umgekehrt ist das, was Russland jetzt gerade tut, oder hatte William Spaniel
so schön gesagt, dass manche Erfolge halt selbst limitierend sind.
Das heißt, je erfolgreicher jetzt Russland, je mehr Erfolge Russland jetzt haben wird,
umso krasser wird dann die Reaktion im Westen ausfallen.
Nur die Frage ist, ob das dann rechtzeitig kommt.
Aber gut, da vielleicht später nochmal drauf. Aber gut.
Ja, ich finde das alles in weiten Teilen sehr unbefriedigend,
gerade was Deutschland macht und aber auch was die USA tun,
da möchte man auch irgendwie am liebsten nur weglaufen oder abschalten.
Ja, die Republikaner sind mittlerweile auch komplett einfach.
Ich meine, dass Trump irgendwie schon immer seine Liebe für Diktatoren hatte,
das hat er ja nun schon selber oft genug gesagt und ich habe keine Ahnung,
wie viel Kohle er von Putin schon bekommen hat und was er da noch irgendwie
alles meint, verdienen zu können.
Ihm geht es ja eh nur um sich selber und zieht halt mittlerweile die ganzen
Republikaner mit in den Orkus und das ist halt eine totale Katastrophe,
weil die Situation in den USA nicht verfolgt,
das hatten wir in der letzten Sendung auch schon angesprochen,
das hat sich auch nicht groß verändert,
dieser neue Sprecher des Hauses im Kongress, der Johnson tut halt alles dafür,
um eine Abstimmung über die Ukraine Hilfe zu verhindern.
Deswegen fehlt da jetzt seit Oktober die Mittel, den Russen noch was entgegenzusetzen
und das ist halt einfach mal so klar, eine Unterstützung der russischen Position,
das ist einfach unfassbar, wie die amerikanische Öffentlichkeit,
die über Jahrzehnte immer so diesen Kampf gegen den Kommunismus vorgeschoben
hat und Russland ist ja das Böse und so weiter.
Insbesondere die Republikaner immer vorneweg das jetzt alles über Bord schmeißen,
um so einen komischen Religionskult für so einen Vollidioten durchzuziehen.
Also man wundert sich manchmal über gar nichts mehr.
Aber die interessiert auch, in Wirklichkeit interessiert die auch Russland gar nicht.
Das ist alles nur eigentlich in erster Linie ein Mittel, um selber...
An die Macht zu kommen.
Genau.
Ja, auch wenn man bereit ist.
Dafür zu bezahlen.
Ja, ja. Und ich könnte mir genauso vorstellen, dass falls jetzt,
was ich nicht hoffe und auch nicht glaube, falls Trump irgendwie wieder Präsident
werden sollte, traue ich ihm auch zu,
wenn es opportun ist, einen Tag später, keine Ahnung, Russland bombardieren zu lassen.
Einfach so, weil aus irgendeinem Grund Und es jetzt plötzlich opportun ist,
weil irgendwie irgendwas passiert und er dann Dinge tun muss.
Und er war ja in vielerlei Hinsicht da ein bisschen wie Putin auch unterwegs
und auch mit Atomdrohungen gegen ihn auch ein bisschen leicht von der Zunge.
Im Gegensatz zu allen anderen Politikern, die mir untergekommen sind,
da über sowas redet man einfach nicht.
Aber ja, jetzt kann man nur hoffen, ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja diese Discharge-Petition,
wo dann möglicherweise bis April...
Bis April dann tatsächlich eine Abstimmung im Repräsentantenhaus stattfinden könnte.
Aber derzeit versucht er das halt auch zu torpedieren, indem er versucht,
dann die abtrünnigen Republikaner irgendwie unter Druck zu setzen oder auf seine
Seite zu ziehen mit jetzt einem angeblichen neuen eigenen Vorschlag.
Jetzt plötzlich die Situation an der Grenze wieder mit reinzubringen.
Aber es ist einfach...
Das sind alles so Spielchen. Also wer das nicht verfolgt in den USA,
dieser Sprecher versucht einfach alles, um es weiter rauszuzögern.
Man kann das nicht anders sagen.
Ein Typ, der irgendwie kein nachgewiesenes Bankkonto hat und auch im Verdacht
steht, irgendwie Geld von Russen zu bekommen.
Trump will halt irgendwie alles verhindern, dass es keinen Sieg für Biden gibt,
Egal was das für internationale Auswirkungen hat,
Hauptsache er steht als ich kann die Probleme nicht lösen da,
damit dann Trump sich sozusagen als der Große hält, der jetzt alle Probleme
lösen wird, obwohl er selber der Grund ist, warum sie nicht gelöst werden.
Das möchte er gerne und das ist sozusagen sein Plan und die ganzen Republikaner,
die alle nur vom Geld getrieben zu sein scheinen, jegliche Moral und jegliches
Verhältnis zu dem, was Amerika angeblich in der Welt sein soll, verloren haben,
tragen das halt mit, weil sie alle Schiss haben, ihren eigenen Posten zu verlieren.
Also das wird sich zeigen.
Wir müssen aber jetzt, weil wir jetzt hier auch schon bald vier Stunden voll
haben oder voll haben, ich weiß nicht, mal auch langsam zu unserer Schlussdebatte
kommen. Ja, vielleicht.
Zumindest den letzten großen Thema.
Ja, genau.
Lass uns das jetzt noch durchgehen und ja, das große Thema, das letzte Thema halt,
ja, Taurus-Debatte und Scholz-Isolation hatten wir schon mehrfach irgendwie
angesprochen und so die erste Frage wäre natürlich, weil du auch sagtest, in der Ukraine,
Taurus-Scholz, Taurus-Taurus, wieso eigentlich,
ich meine gut, die Debatte läuft ja auch schon länger.
Aber die Frage ist natürlich erstmal, was ist dieses Ding eigentlich und warum
ist das jetzt in der Debatte überhaupt so hochgekocht?
Und ja, und diese Taurus ist halt, schönes Militärdeutsch, eine modulare Abstandswaffe.
Und im Grunde genommen sehr ähnlich zu den wieder diskutierten Storm Shadow
slash Skalp von den Franzosen,
also auch ein Marschflugkörper,
der...
Im Tiefflug mit einer Geschwindigkeit von bis zu 1000 kmh eine Entfernung von
bis zu über 500 Kilometern zurücklegen und dann mit extremer Präzision Ziele anfliegen kann.
Und warum?
Es gibt mehrere Gründe, glaube ich, warum diese Debatte jetzt so hochgekocht ist.
Und einer davon ist, dass erwähnt den Briten und den Franzosen so langsam die
Storm Shadow und Skalp ausgehen.
Also das war auch ein Ding, was so ein bisschen aus dieser abgehörten Konferenz,
auf die wir auch noch kommen wollen,
rausgekommen ist, dass das zumindest ein Punkt zu sein scheint.
Aber was, und die,
ich sag mal, die Russen sind jetzt auch massiv drauf angesprungen und ich hab mich gefragt,
okay, wie viel davon ist eigentlich jetzt pure Propaganda oder haben die wirklich
jetzt Angst vor den Dingern?
Und ich meine, einerseits gibt es nicht so viele davon.
Also es wäre jetzt auch nicht direkt kriegsentscheidend, weil es wurden bisher
nur 600 Stück davon gebaut und die Bundeswehr behauptet,
sie hätten noch 150 davon einsatzbereit.
Das ist aber wahrscheinlich ein bisschen tief gestapelt. Wahrscheinlich in Wirklichkeit
sind es ungefähr 300, die die Bundeswehr hat.
Und so könnten Sie sich vorstellen, 100 Stück davon abzugeben.
So das weiß man jetzt nicht.
Und mit 100 Marschflugkörpern gewinnt man jetzt auch keinen Krieg,
aber die Dinger sind auch sehr
unangenehm und wenn man die jetzt mit Storm Shadow und Scalp vergleicht,
ist es ungefähr selbe Gewichtsklasse, so 1,4 Tonnen.
Die Reichweite scheint aber ein bisschen größer zu sein und die kosten wahrscheinlich
nur halb so viel wie die Storm Shadow Sculps.
Aber scheinen mir,
also wenn ich die Wahl hätte jetzt, ob ich eine Storm Shadow oder eine Taurus nehme,
würde ich zumindest von den Specs her und was ich irgendwie erfahren habe,
klingt für mich die Taurus doch ein bisschen mehr sophisticated.
Also es kostet zwar nur die Hälfte, aber kann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr.
Und da unterscheidet sie sich nicht so sehr von der Storm Shadow,
hat halt auch vier Navigationssysteme so mit GPS und Trägheitsnavigation.
Aber das Entscheidende ist eben auch Terrain Reference Navigation, TRN.
Das heißt, da wird ein Höhenprofil reingeladen, das macht Scalp Storm Shadow
auch, aber es gibt dann auch noch die sogenannte Image-Based Navigation.
Das heißt, es gibt auch noch eine Kamera und diese Kamera kann unterwegs und
auch am Ziel quasi Objekte identifizieren.
Wenn man entsprechend Modelle davon vorher hochlädt,
dann kann die einfach anhand bestimmter auffälliger Gebäude oder anderer Merkmale
anhand der Kamera einfach genau feststellen.
Zum Beispiel so eine Brücke, die nur so aussieht, wie eine Brücke aussieht.
Ja, und die Dinger können tiefer
fliegen, also sie können irgendwie bis unter 35 Meter Höhe so gehen,
das ist meines Wissens etwas tiefer als Storm Shadow kann und,
Und damit sind die extrem schwierig zu bekämpfen,
weil in 35 Metern Höhe mit Radar ist da nicht viel zu erfassen.
Und wenn die jetzt mit Mach 0,95, dann ist es ungefähr über 300 Metern pro Sekunde.
Das heißt, ganz praktisch ist es so, wenn du irgendwo stehst und da kommt so
eine Taurus angeflogen,
dann hast du ungefähr zwei Sekunden, bis die über dir ist und nochmal zwei Sekunden,
bis sie verschwunden ist.
Das heißt, du hast so vier Sekunden Zeit, das Ding zu erfassen und zu bekämpfen,
was halt extrem schwierig ist.
Das heißt, eigentlich brauchst du dann Kampfflugzeuge, aber wenn das Ding nicht
auf dem Radar ist, ist es halt schwierig. schwierig.
Außerdem gibt es auch noch Optionen, das Ding hat auch eine Option, eine,
Selbstverteidigungsoption, die man installieren kann, wie gesagt,
modulare Abstandswaffe.
Das heißt, wenn die merkt, dass sie selber bekämpft wird, also kann halt identifizieren, dass da eine,
Rakete auf sie zukommt, kann sie halt auch Täuschkörper wiederum ausstoßen.
Wie ein Kampfflugzeug. Kann sich dann also vor Radar und Infrarot auch noch schützen.
Und so ein weiteres Feature ist so der Zwei-Wege-Datenlink.
Damit kann man dann sogar auch bewegte Ziele bekämpfen.
Das geht dann auch.
Und Was meinst du mit bewegte Ziele bekämpfen? Also wenn jetzt eine Rakete auf
die Rakete zufliegt oder was?
Nein, jetzt Panzer oder am Boden irgendwelche Konvois. Also als Ziel sozusagen.
Also beweglich. Also du kannst damit halt Panzerkolonnen oder was weiß ich irgendwie
ein Auto oder so angreifen.
Aus 500 Kilometern Entfernung.
Dann Dann hat das Ding, ja,
gut, es ist eine ungefähr 100,
also hat einen 400 Kilo schweren Penetrator und eine 95 Kilo schwere Vorholladung, wie es so schön heißt.
Und also auch der...
Der Gefechtskopf ist so,
dass der einen speziellen Sensor drin hat,
der misst, wie tief er jetzt in das Ziel eingedrungen ist und welchen Widerstand
jetzt beim Eindringen in das Ziel er erlebt hat.
Der kann irgendwie 10.000 G Beschleunigung überleben und dem kannst du dann
sagen, ich möchte bitte, dass du jetzt drei Betondecken durchstößt,
bevor du dann explodierst.
Oder zehn Meter Erde und dann, weiß ich nicht, dann bitte drei Meter tief im Beton oder so.
Dann kannst du halt dann genau sagen, an welcher Stelle innerhalb des Ziels
die eigentliche Hauptladung detonieren soll.
Und wie gesagt, die erste Ladung macht halt ein Loch rein und die zweite macht
dann den Weg für den Penetrator auf.
Und ansonsten, ja, ist noch vielleicht letztes Feature, so fünf verschiedene
Angriffsmodi, so entweder Pop-Up, wo du dann hochgehst und von oben angreifst, Low-Level-Pop-Up,
dann Dive-Attack, wo du dann von oben kommst, dann gibt es noch die Airburst-Variante,
wo das Ding in der Luft explodiert.
Und dann gibt es auch noch den Horizontal Cave Attack als Modus,
wenn du irgendwie Höhlen in einem Berg angreifen willst oder Landebahnen,
wie die Schweizer sie mal hatten, so im Berg.
Die kannst du dann auch bekämpfen, da kannst du halt in irgendeinen Tunnel oder
Eingang oder so reinfliegen.
Also mit anderen Worten, das Ding ist schon also Also eine sehr unangenehme Waffe,
die mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ihr Ziel erreicht und eben auch in der Lage ist,
einen Brückenpfeiler anzusteuern,
und wahrscheinlich sogar genau in der Mitte zu treffen.
Aber die Ladung, naja, mit den 400 Kilo, so, ja, also...
Es reicht, um so ziemlich jedes freistehende Gebäude in Schutt und Asche zu legen.
Aber so bei der Brücke, also speziell bei der Kerschbrücke, ist man sich nicht so sicher.
Und die generelle auch Angst vor Blamage, dass sie nur ein Loch reinmachen und
die Brücke stehen bleibt.
Und ja, rechnen damit, dass man wahrscheinlich so 30 oder 40 Stück bräuchte,
um die Kerschbrücke zu zerstören.
Und wenn es halt nur 100 gibt...
Naja, also ist nicht kriegsentscheidend, aber kann halt,
ja, ist was, wo ich verstehen kann, dass die Ukraine das gerne hätte und dass
die Russen sehr daran interessiert sind, dass die Ukraine die Dinger nicht kriegt.
So, das kann man vielleicht mal festhalten.
Und die russische Reaktion kann man fast nur als hysterisch betrachten.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du es gesehen hast, dieses Propaganda-Video mit den deutschen Brücken.
Ne, das Video habe ich nicht gesehen, aber dass sie sozusagen jetzt die Diskussion
führen, welche Brücken man jetzt in Deutschland alles so abschießen könnte.
Ja, also sie haben ein Video dazu gemacht mit Bildern von der Fehmarn-Beltbrücke unter anderem,
so mit diversen Rheinbrücken, so in Köln und Düsseldorf und dann auch eine Brücke war da,
ich weiß nicht genau welcher Schifffahrtskanal das war,
aber sozusagen auch eine Schifffahrtsbrücke, wo dann der Kanal voller Wasser oben drin ist.
Da haben sie sich halt die Mühe gemacht, hübsche Bilder von haufenweise deutschen
Brücken rauszusuchen und zusammenzuschneiden. Zitterer.
Ich zitterer.
Ja, ja. Also ganz offensichtlich haben die Russen Angst vor Taurus.
Ob das gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht, aber ja, sie haben Angst.
Naja, was heißt Angst? Sie wollen halt die Debatte in Deutschland zerstören.
Und das, wie ich vorhin schon sagte, darum geht es der Propaganda immer.
Irgendwelche Ängste schüren auf irgendwelchen Seiten und dafür möglichst viele
davon, damit sich alle in den Haaren liegen und keiner so richtig weiß,
woran man ist oder was jetzt noch wahr ist und so weiter.
Also im Prinzip ist die russische Propaganda ja im Kern die Zerstörung der Wahrheitserzählung.
Und weil wenn es keine Wahrheit mehr gibt, keine gefühlte Wahrheit mehr gibt,
dann ist halt alles eine Lüge und dann wird halt gar nichts mehr geglaubt und
dann kannst du irgendwie auch erzählen, was du möchtest.
Ja, das ist genau der Punkt.
Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich eine Kehrseite von dem,
nämlich dass ein Großteil der Russen dann ihre eigene Propaganda glaubt.
So, also klar gibt es einen Haufen von Leuten, die wissen, dass das alles Quatsch ist,
aber es ist halt dann auch schwierig, für die Russen Wahrheit und Fiktion auseinanderzuhalten
und das hindert dich dann natürlich auch wieder an einer effektiven Kriegsführung.
Und das führt dann wahrscheinlich dazu, dass Russland oder hat dazu geführt,
dass Russland so viele Fehler gemacht hat aufgrund eben dieser Fehleinschätzung,
weil sie ihrer eigenen Propaganda geglaubt haben.
So das ist dann ein bisschen die, sagen die Kehrseite. Und deswegen sage ich,
die Russen haben Angst oder vielleicht nicht die Russen, aber ja, es gibt Angst.
Dort ist mein Gefühl.
Naja, können sie ja gerne haben. Jetzt wissen wir auf jeden Fall,
was Taurus kann oder könnte.
Und jetzt gibt es halt diese Debatte.
Es ist ja auch nicht die erste Ukraine-Krieg-spezifische typisch deutsche Debatte.
Oder sagen wir mal deutsche Debatte, nicht typisch deutsch, aber deutsche Debatte.
Vorher war es halt die Debatte um die Panzer Leopard.
Release the Leopards, das war dann sozusagen der Slogan und was hat dieses Land
rumgeeiert und irgendwie Erzählungen aufgemacht, warum man jetzt irgendwie die
Panzer nicht liefern könnte,
weil die sind ja viel zu kompliziert zu verstehen und so weiter.
Das können die Ukrainer ja gar nicht.
Was ist passiert? Hingeliefert, ein paar Wochen herumgefahren und in den Krieg
geführt und erfolgreich eingesetzt.
Hat sich alles als Quatsch rausgestellt, als kompletter Unsinn rausgestellt, muss man jetzt sagen.
Die Einschätzung gab es auch schon vorher. Genau und die Russen haben auch gedroht,
dass wenn ihr Leoparden liefert, legen wir euer Land in Schutt und Asche.
Also alles irgendwie wieder derselbe Quatsch und niemand scheint dazu gelernt
zu haben hier so richtig.
Genau und jetzt ist es halt die Debatte um Taurus.
Und wahrscheinlich werden uns auch noch ein paar andere Debatten derselben Art
bevorstehen, solange sich eben diese Grundhaltung nicht ändert.
Jetzt ist das Ganze natürlich nochmal hochgekocht, weil es eben diese von den
Russen abgehörte Telefonkonferenz gab von verschiedenen Soldaten der Bundeswehr.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du die Liste irgendwo nochmal, wer diese vier waren,
die daran teilgenommen haben? Ich habe es jetzt nicht vor mir.
Tut auch erstmal nichts zur Sache, sind auf jeden Fall alles Operative,
die in irgendeiner Form mit der Taurus-Waffentechnik näher bekannt sind.
Und die auch für organisatorische Abläufe in irgendeiner Form zuständig wären
oder zumindest an dieser Diskussion nah dran sind,
sollte sich Scholz doch noch dafür entscheiden, die zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Das Ganze war eine Konferenz, die eigentlich dazu diente,
sich abzustimmen im Vorfeld einer anstehenden Präsentation über Taurus mit dem
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius,
die anstand und vielleicht noch ansteht, weiß ich nicht genau,
wo in einer halben Stunde die Bundeswehr mal darlegen sollte,
Was würde denn überhaupt gehen, würde man sich sozusagen doch noch dafür entscheiden,
so in diese Richtung ging das oder zumindest ist das die Richtung,
die diese Bundeswehrteilnehmer dort besuchen?
Ja.
Anstreben. Und das war immer so ein bisschen geprägt von, wir wollen jetzt hier
auch nicht eine Erzählung starten, die sagt, das geht alles nicht.
Aber auch jetzt nicht unbedingt, es gibt keine Probleme, sondern wir wollten
das irgendwie abwägen. Und darüber haben sie sich unterhalten.
Der eine war in Singapur und hat offensichtlich an dieser eigentlich internetbasierten
Telefonkonferenz, die mit diesem Webex-System umgesetzt wurde,
per Telefon teilgenommen, weil da offensichtlich in Singapur gibt es kein Internet.
Habe ich noch nicht von gehört, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen stand wohl nur
ein Telefon zur Verfügung.
Ich vermute, er war halt irgendwo ohne Laptop oder so.
Wobei auch auf dem Handy hast du einen Webex-Client.
Ja, es gibt keine Entschuldigung dafür.
Also er hat sozusagen einen Telefonzugang vermutlich, einen Telefonzugang genutzt
und der wurde von den Russen abgehört.
Also es war General Gräfe, einer der ranghöchsten Teilnehmer,
der sich dann aus Singapur eingewählt hat und der, der ihn reingelassen hat, war halt ein Leutnant.
Also irgendwie fünf Dienstgrade niedriger, der die ganze Konferenz organisiert
hat und dann offensichtlich nicht irgendwie,
ja, sich nicht traute, irgendwie dem General zu sagen, irgendwie,
das geht so nicht, sondern irgendwie, ja.
Und dann waren die anderen beiden so, ich glaube, Oberstleutnant,
das ist sozusagen eins unter, ja, ist deutlich auch unter, ja,
dazwischen, da sind es dann noch Oberst und so,
also Colonel wäre es im Amerikanischen der entsprechende Dienstgrad,
Gerade die dann wiederum teilweise von den auch Cyber-Streitkräften der Bundeswehr
und der Generalinspektor der Luftwaffe,
also Luftwaffenchef,
war dabei.
Und es war alles so eine sehr kumpelhafte Debatte, wenn man dem zuhört.
Man hätte fast das Gefühl, dass sie sich duzen.
Haben sie auch teilweise. Also regelmäßig.
Am Anfang haben sie das getan, bevor der General glaube ich dabei war.
Ja, also.
Er kam recht früh dazu und wenn man sich das auch anhört, da war die Frage,
ist jetzt Webex unsicher, haben die Russen das gehackt, aber es sieht meiner
Sicht, es wurde zumindest auch von offizieller Seite bestätigt,
dass der Gräfe abgehört wurde.
Oder wenn du dir das anhörst, siehst du, dass das zumindest die Aufnahme auch
aus der Perspektive von Gräfe ist, wie er anruft. Und das Ganze beginnt sozusagen mit seiner Einwahl.
Und dann antwortet er, hallo Herr General, ich bringe Sie dann gleich rein in die Konferenz.
Und dann ging es halt los und alles.
Auch mit diesen typischen Telefontönen, die das begleiten.
Ja, wobei, ich sag mal, es ist jetzt nicht 100% ausgeschlossen,
weil wenn der Stream aufgezeichnet wird, wird auch das mit aufgezeichnet,
aber der Punkt, dass es genau dort beginnt und auch die, also ich würde sagen,
zu 99% war das halt im Rahmen der, sag mal, normalen Vorratsdatenspeicherung durch Geheimdienste.
Wurde das wahrscheinlich mitgeschnitten und dann hat man,
geguckt, man kennt wahrscheinlich die Einwahlnummer, also zumindest sagen das
Ende so auf deutscher Seite, diese Einwahlnummer ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo
dann bei den Russen auch im System,
sodass das getaggt wurde und dann Dann wurde es auf Schlüsselworte untersucht
und so ist man, glaube ich, zu dieser Aufnahme gekommen.
Also ich denke nicht, dass er jetzt dann von Agenten begleitet wurde oder so,
sondern das war halt normale Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also du kannst davon ausgehen.
Jede SMS, die irgendjemand schickt
in den Datenbanken von mindestens fünf Geheimdiensten weltweit, landet.
Und bei Telefongesprächen ist das Datenaufkommen ein bisschen größer.
Aber bei den heutigen Datenmengen kann man es sich einfach leisten,
erst mal unglaubliche Mengen aufzuzeichnen und dann auszufiltern und zu sortieren.
Und ich denke mal, das ist ungefähr so gelaufen, weil sie einfach eine bekannte
Einwahlnummer gewählt haben, ist dann bei den Russen die Lampe angegangen.
Ah, da ruft jemand aus Singapur in Deutschland bei der Bundeswehr Einwahlnummer an.
Hören wir mal, was die so zu sagen haben. Ja,
das Gespräch selber war aber, also sich dann viel echauffiert,
also speziell dann auch von der Linken, von wegen Kriegstreiber und wie kann man nur und so,
aber aus meiner Sicht war das und da muss ich sagen, da war,
da ist Pistorius, sagen, auch ein guter Verteidigungsminister an der Stelle,
Weil der hat dann genau das gesagt später, was ich mir auch beim Anhören gedacht habe.
Die haben halt einfach ihren Job gemacht, nämlich zu diskutieren,
was würde das bedeuten, wenn wir jetzt von der Politik den Auftrag bekommen,
das zu tun und was so sind die Restriktionen, was wären die Zeitpläne und so,
einfach um eine politische Entscheidung zu ermöglichen.
Und das war, ich würde sagen, eine relativ neutrale, sachliche Beziehung.
Ich meine, so ein paar Formulierungen kann man sagen,
so wie eine Brücke im Süden oder so, aber im Prinzip war da jetzt,
sag mal, fand ich da jetzt nichts Skandalöses dran, sondern genauso oder so
ähnlich hätte ich mir das vorgestellt, dass irgendwo genau so ein Gespräch stattfindet, wo man...
Absolut. Also inhaltlich stimme ich dir da vollkommen zu.
Was mich ein bisschen, nicht schockiert, aber wo ich so ein bisschen mit dem
Kopf schütteln musste ist, das waren ja nun alles Bundeswehrleute.
Und man würde ja meinen, dass wenn du jetzt Soldat bist und General und was
sie alles sind, dann sollten sie ja in einem auch wirklich gut geschult sein.
Nämlich klar zu kommunizieren, Fakten einfach mal darzulegen und klare Sprache
benutzen, damit es irgendwie unverfälscht rüberkommt.
Und das ist irgendwie meiner Wahrnehmung keinem dieser Teilnehmer auch nur ansatzweise gelungen.
Da wurde kein Satz richtig zu Ende gesprochen, da wurde rumgenuschelt,
da wurden komische Worte benutzt, also rein so sprachtechnisch fand ich das
unter aller Sau unklar, undeutlich.
Man musste also wirklich genau hinhören und sich nochmal die Transkription durchlesen,
um überhaupt zu verstehen, was diese Aussagen dann am Ende wirklich eigentlich sagen sollten.
Es war unstrukturiert, sie sind sich teilweise ins Wort gefallen und ja, das war eher so wie,
also formlos würde ich sagen.
Es war eine formlose Debatte, aber natürlich ermöglicht sie natürlich ein paar
durchaus interessante Einblicke.
Sie sagt einmal der Punkt, dass die Engländer und Franzosen praktisch Winchester
bei Storm Shadow Sculpt sind.
Also Winchester heißt halt irgendwie Munition alle.
Wo kommt dieser Begriff her? Ich kannte den noch nicht.
Achso, das ist eigentlich aus der Fliegerei, so ist das, sagen wir mal,
über Funkverkehr, wenn du so, I'm Winchester, heißt dann,
ich bin, ja,
munitionslos.
Aber wo kommt das her?
Ja.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber es ist halt einer dieser Begriffe.
Ja, so wie auch Bogi und für irgendwie fremde Kontakte, feindliche Kontakte. Ja, okay.
So, das war so ein bisschen ein Statement. Und dann war noch interessant aber,
was quasi an Support und an Daten benötigt wird, um das Ganze einzusetzen.
Und du brauchst halt dann auch spezielle Stationen oder Geräte,
um die Zielmodellierung durchzuführen.
Also du brauchst einmal Topografiedaten, die dann von der IABG zur Verfügung
gestellt werden sollten.
Das ist so eine deutsche Rüstungsforschungsgemeinschaft im Wesentlichen.
Und das erinnerte mich dann an meine vor 30 Jahren so an die SRTM,
die Shuttle Radar Topography Mission,
wo ein deutsches Instrument auf dem Space Shuttle mitgeflogen ist,
was halt ein sehr detailliertes Höhenprofil angelegt hat.
Und ich weiß das deshalb, weil Teile meiner Software sagen,
weil wir den Zuschlag gekriegt haben, damals diese Topografie-Datenbank zu verarbeiten,
weil wir Terravision hatten und hatten dann den Auftrag von der DLR.
Quasi die Daten zu bearbeiten und in eine Datenbank zu packen.
Aber deswegen, daran fühlte ich mich erinnert.
Und jedenfalls gibt es halt, braucht man diese hochauflösenden Topografiedaten,
damit die auch ihren Weg finden kann. Und ganz offensichtlich liegen die vor.
Also die Bundeswehr hat halt Höhlendaten von der Ukraine hoch aufgelöst.
Und das war halt überhaupt kein Problem.
Die müssen halt nur bereitgestellt werden. Ja.
Das andere Ding ist, sowohl für die Wegpunkte als auch dann für das Ziel kann
man dann noch eine Zielmodellierung durchführen.
Wenn man hohe Genauigkeit haben will, dann nimmt man Fotos und dann wird halt
ein Modell von dem Ziel auch in dem Flugkörper gespeichert,
sodass er eben genau in der Lage ist,
selbst wenn komplett Satellitenverbindung weg und GPS gestört und alles,
ist er dann trotzdem in der Lage, das richtige Fenster oder den richtigen Lüftungsschacht
anzufliegen oder eben den Brückenpfeiler in der Mitte zu treffen.
Sie sprachen zwar offiziell von kleiner 3 Meter, die Treffergenauigkeit.
Wahrscheinlich, ja, kleiner 3 Meter kann alles bedeuten, aber unter guten Verhältnissen
kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das Ding auf einen halben Meter genau wahrscheinlich
sein Ziel anfliegt, wenn das vernünftig modelliert ist.
Das heißt, du kannst mit dem Ding im Prinzip in einen größeren Lüftungsschacht reinfliegen.
Krass.
Oder in den Gulli.
Wow. Das ist ein Kanaldeckel ansteuern wahrscheinlich.
Wahnsinn. Und ja, und diese Zielmodellierung und so ist halt ein bisschen,
also ja, da braucht man halt die Software für und braucht Bilder vom Ziel und so.
Aber das war zumindest alles kein großes Problem.
Da haben sie noch drüber gesprochen. Man braucht natürlich auch ein Flugzeug,
wo man das Ding dran hängt.
Und da war dann die Debatte, ob man dann die Engländer fragt.
Es sprach dann übrigens auch von Engländern und nicht von Briten.
Aber das ist halt normal, Engländer. Gut, dass die ja schon Erfahrung haben,
die Franzosen eigentlich auch, aber wahrscheinlich haben die Engländer,
die Briten hatten da wahrscheinlich die Federführung bei der Anpassung.
Und die könnte man ja dann gegebenenfalls fragen, ob sie auch helfen könnten,
so dann die Taurus anzustellen.
Schön fand ich auch die Formulierung, da kommt dann so ein Bastler aus der Ukraine und macht das.
Also das war schon wirklich sehr salopp, aber um kurz zu machen vielleicht der Teil.
Also generell waren sie schon der Meinung,
ja da gibt es noch ein paar ungelöste Probleme, aber nichts davon ist unlösbar
und die Ukraine hat sowieso schon immer gezeigt, dass es am Ende schneller geht,
als man das vorher gedacht hat und daran soll es nicht scheitern.
Ja, und ich sage mal, eine Peinlichkeit, die dabei jetzt rauskam, war,
dass Scholz halt vorher behauptet hat, man könne keine Taurus liefern,
weil man sonst Bundeswehrsoldaten in die Ukraine schicken müsste.
Und da kam raus, das ist nicht die Meinung, nicht die Sicht der Experten bei
der Bundeswehr, sondern die haben dann verschiedene Szenarien auch diskutiert,
wie man das vermeiden könnte.
Und das sagen Bundes, also ich meine einige davon waren ein bisschen abstrus.
Dann meinten sie, naja, das könnte man vielleicht die Industrie irgendwie Experten
schicken lassen, stattdessen die das dann im Land machen.
Oder man könnte das von Polen aus machen.
Oder man könnte auch irgendwie ein paar von diesen Zivilisten in der Ukraine
fragen, die so einen auffallenden amerikanischen Akzent haben.
Genau, das war die andere Sache. Und ich meine, heutzutage, man könnte es einfach
auch übers Internet machen.
Braucht man aber eine schnelle Leitung.
Ja, ja.
Das könnte natürlich ein Problem werden in Deutschland. Diese Debatte über diese
Fernwartungsgeschichte, ich meine, sie kam ja dann noch so, ja,
oder wir machen das dann in Polen und dann fährt einer mit den Daten mit dem Auto rüber.
Festplatten verschicken irgendwie, okay, ja. Das geht auch besser.
Also das war ein bisschen absurd, aber unterm Strich kann man sagen, die Bewertung ist klar.
Für die ist es, wenn es den politischen Willen gibt, absolut technisch vorstellbar,
leistbar in wenigen Monaten.
Und ich würde mal sagen, der Zeitraum, der sich aus ihren Debatten so abgezeichnet
hat, ist irgendwas zwischen zwei,
drei bis sechs bis neun Monate, je nachdem wie genau man sein will,
wie viel Daten noch gesammelt werden muss, wie viel Personal entweder hingeschickt
wird oder erstmal aufwendig in Deutschland trainiert wird.
Mit anderen Worten, man könnte mit Goodwill und Scheiß drauf,
kann man in zwei, drei Monaten irgendwie loslegen und wenn es unbedingt sein
muss und man wählt den kompliziertesten Weg,
dann ist es auch noch innerhalb dieses Jahres leistbar.
Nur, und das war ja auch klar in der Debatte, das muss dann die Politik entscheiden
und die Politik hat halt derzeit ein paar Entscheidungsprobleme.
Ja, vor allen Dingen die Politik, glaube ich, in Form von Scholz, so dieser Person.
Und ja, das ist die Frage, ich sag mal, hattest du dich ja auch nochmal ein
bisschen genauer mit den Ursachen beschäftigt.
Ich meine, über die Angst hatten wir ja schon diskutiert, aber so, es riecht.
Das Ganze, also diese Vehemenz, mit der dort abgelehnt wird,
ist schon bemerkenswert, fand ich.
In diesem Interview wurden ja auch verschiedenste Ideen geliefert,
was so ein bisschen Treiber dieser Gedankengänge sein könnten bei Scholz.
Unter anderem halt auch die anstehenden wahlen in ostdeutschland und
der große widerstand sozusagen dort und
die potenzielle popularität der afd dass er sozusagen aus diesen gründen nicht
diesen weg gehen will also mit anderen worten es wird hier auch nicht unbedingt
jetzt das getan was das richtige wäre sondern was eben sozusagen die eigene
macht basis sichern kann das ist ja auch.
Ich finde, das ist ein legitimes Argument für so einen Kanzler,
auch immer zu beurteilen, ist vielleicht eine richtige Entscheidung in Anführungsstrichen falsch,
weil sie dann dazu führt, dass ich die Macht gar nicht mehr habe,
sie dann auch wirklich durchzusetzen, weil sich eine Öffentlichkeit so dagegen stimmt. gestimmt.
Gestern habe ich auch gerade gesehen, gab wieder irgendeine Umfrage,
wie denn so die deutsche Bevölkerung das sieht, mit einer klaren Mehrheit gegen die Taurus-Lieferung.
Was ich auch verstehen kann, dass so eine Meinung existiert,
wenn man sie eben sieht, wie sie öffentlich debattiert wird.
Wenn einfach die ganze Zeit so Angst geschürt wird, oh ja, aber was ist denn,
wenn wir eine Kriegspartei sind?
Also face it, wir sind schon lange eine Kriegspartei, weil wir wurden von der
anderen Seite als solche ausgerufen.
Und da können wir herzlich wenig dran machen und wir haben ja auch gesehen mit
den Panzern, du hast es schon benannt, das tut jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch alles
überhaupt nichts mehr zur Sache.
Also wir schaden uns einfach durch Zurückhaltung mehr als durch klare Positionierung
und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass Macron das zumindest verstanden hat und jetzt eben auch einfach mal,
mitspielt so ein bisschen im Brust raus Und ja, lieber Putin,
glaub mal nicht, dass du hier beliebig weit gehen kannst, weil Frankreich wird
auch irgendwann nervös.
Ja, und meine Vermutung ist, es ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es laufen wird wie mit den Leoparden.
Irgendwann wird der Punkt kommen, wo man dann sehen wird, okay, wir liefern jetzt doch.
Doch, das halte ich für sehr wahrscheinlich, dass man sich aber noch eine ganze Weile zieren wird.
Und was man eigentlich nur sagen kann, okay, in der jetzigen Situation wurde
die Entscheidung so getroffen, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass diese Entscheidung dauerhaft Bestand haben wird.
Auf der anderen Seite wird es eben genauso wie 100 Leoparden nicht kriegsentscheidend
sein, aber es könnte viele ukrainische Leben retten.
So, diese 100 Storm Shadows könnten ja wahrscheinlich hunderte oder tausenden
Ukrainern das davor bewahren,
Opfer dieses Kriegs zu werden. So sehe ich das Kalkül einfach.
Und Russland wird deswegen nicht verlieren, wenn wir Storm Shadow liefern.
Das ist jetzt keine Wunderwaffe.
Naja, also was heißt keine Wunderwaffe? Das lädt das Ding mir zu sehr auf.
Sagen wir mal so, angenommen es gäbe jetzt Taurus und Ukraine hätte jetzt 50
Stück zur Verfügung und es obliegt jetzt ganz ihrer eigenen Entscheidung,
wie die jetzt zum Einsatz kommen.
Und der Beschluss ist, okay...
Wir bereiten das jetzt irgendwie alles vor und dann machen wir so eine konzertierte Attacke.
So eine gestaffelte Angriffswelle, sagen wir mal, das geht dann irgendwie los.
Decoy-Drohnen, kleine Drohnen, Angriffe auf Luftabwehrsysteme auf der Krim,
das fliegt irgendwie alles los, damit geht's los.
Russland versucht zurückzuschlagen, einiges wird runtergeschossen,
manches wird vernichtet.
Kaum ist die erste Welle durch, kommt gleich die zweite Welle hinterher.
Also sozusagen mal so richtig schön angespart und in dem Fall geht man dann
auch schon mit anderen Waffen, die ein bisschen effektiver sind,
auch noch auf größere Ziele los.
Bestimmte S-400-Luftabwehrsysteme, die dann mal gezielt mit Storm Shadow oder
sowas bedient werden, um sozusagen richtig schön da einen Kanal frei zu schaufeln.
Parallel dazu geht eine größere Attacke los mit diesen Seedrohnen,
die alle irgendwie auf die Brücke zufahren. Und wir haben ja bisher nur diese Bootdrohnen gesehen.
Die nächste Generation sind ja Unterwasserdrohnen, die jetzt auch schon entwickelt werden.
Die werden sicherlich demnächst auch zum Einsatz kommen und ich kann mir auch
nicht vorstellen, dass die groß andere Ziele haben als diese Brücke und die
ganz großen Schiffe. So, das heißt, die fahren jetzt irgendwie alle los und dann geht's ab.
So, und dann wird diese Brücke attackiert, die Luftabwehr geht da auch schon
los, auf was auch immer da anfliegt und dann kommt erst die Taurus.
Und das Ziel ist, ich meine, wir reden jetzt über Brückenpfeiler,
aber es gibt nicht nur die Brückenpfeiler, es gibt die...
Also die Straße, also diese Verbindung zwischen Russland und der Krim ist ja
eine längere, ist ja nicht eine Brücke, sondern das ist ja eine längere Strecke, die,
ich weiß nicht wie lang ist die insgesamt,
ich gucke nochmal kurz, das ist so Luftlinie, sind das so 17 Kilometer.
Und das fängt halt irgendwie an mit so einem Damm.
Es läuft erst an so einem Damm entlang, gegen den kannst du nichts machen.
Dann hast du so ein Brückensegment mit Pfeilern, so wie es eben schon mal angegriffen wurde.
Dann hast du so eine Insel, da läuft es dann halt wieder auf dem Damm und dann
hast du nochmal ein Segment, das ist da, wo dieser Lastwagen dann explodiert
ist bei dem allerersten Angriff eben auch mit diesen Pfeilern.
Aber dann gibt es eine Stelle, das ist die Durchfahrtsektion für die Schiffe.
Und da hast du ja nicht nur die Betonplatten für die Bahnlinie und die Straßen,
die bisher angegriffen wurden, sondern du hast ja dann auch noch diese Stahlkonstruktion,
die diese Brücke eben dann stabil hält.
Und die erscheint mir schon sehr angriffsfähig also wenn du sozusagen auf diese,
Pfeiler dieser Trage Elemente losgehst und in der Lage bist mit 3,
4, 5 solchen Taurus Missiles die zu zerstören und nebenbei vielleicht dann noch
mit deinen Unterwasserdrohnen auch noch die Pfeiler angehst oder was weiß ich
was sie da noch alles in die Luft sprengen können dann hast du da multiple,
Schadenspunkte an so einem total kritischen Bereich.
Also man kann vielleicht festhalten, das war auch die Sicht der Bundeswehr,
dass man wahrscheinlich mit, wenn man 40 von diesen Dingern einsetzt auf die Brücke,
dass die dann sehr wahrscheinlich auch für längere Zeit unbrauchbar gemacht werden würde.
Also nicht nur irgendwie so wie bei den bisherigen Anschlägen, sondern ja,
also mit 40 von den Dingern, ja, wären sie tatsächlich in der Lage,
so die Brücke zu zerlegen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie 40 von den Dingern dafür einsetzen.
Nee, müssen ja auch nicht sein. Deswegen habe ich auch gesagt,
nimmst du irgendwie so ein paar. Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Brücken.
Diese Eisenbahnlinie lässt sich ja an jeder Stelle, wo eine Brücke ist, machen.
Du kannst auch andere Brücken komplett in Orkus schicken und das gleiche gilt
auch für die neue Eisenbahnlinie, die auf der derzeitigen Landbrücke,
die noch existiert, gebaut wird, da in Donetsk.
Also es gibt multiple Stellen, wo man im Prinzip den Zugverkehr in die Krim
komplett blockieren kann.
Und das ist schon ein signifikanter Beitrag zu diesem Krieg.
Beendet das den Krieg sofort? Nö. Aber schafft das sozusagen Luft für weitere Operationen?
Ja, vielleicht so. Und wenn nicht, dann probiert man halt was anderes.
Aber diese Möglichkeit komplett auszuschließen, nur unter diesem Argument,
naja, aber vielleicht könnte dann irgendjemand meinen, wir wären eine böse Kriegspartei
und was passiert denn dann?
Das ist halt dann eine Verlustangst, beziehungsweise eine Angst vor mehr Antworten
Russlands gegenüber Deutschland.
Und da wir uns aber das Zerstören der Fehmarnbrücke nicht so richtig vorstellen
können, das wäre zwar ein bisschen schade um die Fehmarnbrücke,
aber da geht Deutschland nicht von unter, nur die Brücke.
Ist halt die Frage, was ist denn eigentlich diese Angst und was ist denn eigentlich
der Grund, dass Deutschland mittlerweile in dieser europäischen Debatte zunehmenden
Maße sich auch isoliert.
Also über Scholz schütteln ja nicht nur die Ukrainer die Köpfe,
sondern das ist ja mittlerweile auch im europäischen Verbund ist es so irgendwie, was erlaube Scholz.
Und wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal diese Diskussion gerade anschaut,
die ja parallel noch läuft mit, sollen wir die eingefrorenen russischen Geldbeträge und Assets,
die hier so die jachten und was an Konten alles eingefroren wurde,
ein multipler Milliardenbetrag,
wo man sozusagen Staatsvermögen und privates Vermögen von einzelnen Russen beschlagnahmt hat.
Hat, sollen wir das jetzt in irgendeiner Form der Ukraine schenken?
Ja, da gibst du den soften Ansatz mit, naja, solange wir das Geld halten,
wirft das ja Zinsen ab, da können wir ja die ja schon mal verwenden,
was ich schon mal für vollkommen gerechtfertigt halten würde, so.
Oder nehmen wir das sozusagen komplett raus und schenken das einfach komplett,
kippen wir das komplett der Ukraine hinten rein.
So, ich meine, das ist irgendwie irgendwas wie, ich weiß nicht mehr die genaue
Zahl, 300 Milliarden oder so.
Also, Also das sind so nennenswerte Assets. Aber das wäre dann so ein richtiger Staatsraub.
Also man würde sagen so, ah das gehört jetzt Russland, das gehört euch jetzt
nicht mehr, weil ihr seid böse.
So, was könnte Russland dann tun, abgesehen von der Fehmarnbrücke? Naja.
Ich bin mir halt sicher, dass Deutschland auch noch eine ganze Menge Assets
in Russland hat, von denen sie noch nicht enteignet wurden und dass das eben
auch einen entsprechenden politischen Druck erzeugt, sozusagen.
Naja, die können uns ja auch noch eine ganze Menge wegnehmen.
Das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, aber ich kann mir langsam
kaum noch was anderes ausmalen, was hier noch der Grund sein sollte,
dass man sich da so zurückhält.
Also interessant ist ja auch noch, dass Russland nach wie vor noch Öl an Europa liefert und Gas.
Zwar nicht jetzt mehr direkt nach Deutschland, aber da fließt halt über die
Türkei unter anderem und das ist auch so ein bisschen absurd.
In Ungarn kriegt es auch noch ab. Auch wenn die Ukraine jetzt angekündigt hat,
auch die Gaspipelines, die durch die Ukraine laufen.
Also Gas wird nach Europa geliefert von Russland durch die Ukraine.
Aber 2025 soll damit Schluss sein.
Und Russland, irgendwer bezahlt die Ukraine auch dafür.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich bezahlt Russland die Ukraine.
Also es ist irre. Es ist einfach nur ein, ja,
ich meine, wenn ich jetzt versuche, maximales Verständnis für Scholz' Position
aufzubringen, jetzt sozusagen,
abgesehen von der Angst jetzt und Wahlkampf und Meinung der Bevölkerung,
wobei die zählt dann auch eigentlich immer nur, wenn es opportun ist.
Ist so, weil wir haben nun mal eine repräsentative Demokratie und egal.
Aber ich glaube, ein vielleicht legitimer Punkt ist, dass man etwas in der Hinterhand behalten will,
falls Russland eskaliert oder zu erfolgreich wird.
Dass man sozusagen noch das Abschreckungspotenzial einer Taurus-Lieferung nutzen möchte,
um Russland von einer weiteren Eskalation abzuhalten.
Und wie valide das ist, halte ich für fragwürdig, aber so zumindest vielleicht
funktioniert es wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und so, also das wäre quasi der einzig valide Punkt an der Stelle.
Und nur glaube ich, führt das eher dazu, dass irgendwann wir an den Punkt kommen werden,
wo es geliefert wird.
Und jetzt mit Ausblick, was wird wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr passieren.
Ist ein bisschen, natürlich niemand weiß es wirklich, aber dieses Jahr wird
hart werden, glaube ich, für die Ukraine.
Einfach so Opferzahlen könnten steigen, weil eben Munition zu spät kommt.
Viel hängt aber auch davon ab, jetzt Wahlen in Russland und was macht Putin
eigentlich dann nach der Wahl.
Viele erwarten, dass er vielleicht dann nach der Wahl nochmal einen Zacken höher schaltet.
Also sprich nochmal den Aufbau der Armee, des Militärs nochmal um den ganzen Schritt steigert.
So weiß man nicht.
Also würde ich sagen 50-50 die Chancen.
Aber wenn das passiert, also wenn die Russen noch einen drauflegen oder auch
so zu erfolgreich sein werden, wird man plötzlich,
werden wir halt Bilder haben von, wenn nicht, wieder größeren ukrainischen Opfern
und Vormarsch und plötzlich,
und wenn die Russen dann plötzlich wieder.
Vorrücken irgendwo in größerem Maße, dann kann das wieder leicht sein,
dass die öffentliche Meinung umschwenkt und man sich dann einig ist,
wir müssen jetzt dringend unbedingt was tun.
Und dann wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht nur Taurus kommen,
weil das wird dann nicht reichen, sondern wenn Russland zu erfolgreich sein
wird, werden wir auch als NATO direkter in den Krieg mit hineingezogen werden, weil irgendwann,
also weil das Russland gewinnt so, das können wir uns nicht leisten.
Ja. Und.
Ja, und deswegen wird dieses Jahr, glaube ich, wird kritisch werden und.
Ja, wann sind die Wahlen in Russland jetzt auch? auch im März noch.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich April, Mai wird sich dann zeigen, welche Richtung das
Ganze nimmt, weil dann wird man auch genauer sehen,
was die USA macht, ob dort die
Gelder freigegeben werden oder nicht und ob Putin dann quasi auch nochmal,
einen Gang hochschaltet und davon hängt dann sehr stark ab, wie sehr das Ganze eskaliert.
Oder ob Putin dann,
Er beschränkt sich jetzt auf die Verteidigung dessen,
was er jetzt hat und versucht das eben dann möglichst mit begrenzten Mitteln zu tun.
Das halte ich fast für wahrscheinlicher, dass das Ganze sich weiter festfahren
wird und dass uns, das wir ja oft schon befürchtet hatten,
uns noch Jahre beschäftigen wird, dieser Krieg.
Ja, gutes Schlusswort eigentlich. Jetzt haben wir fünf Stunden hier schon durchdiskutiert. diskutiert.
Das ist, glaube ich, der absolute Rekord. Ja, sicher. Ja, ja.
Von unserem Podcast.
Von unserem Podcast, ja. Ja. Ganz, ganz, genau. Ganz ohne KI.
Ja, man muss nur lang genug warten, bis man eine Fortsetzung macht.
Das war jetzt auch wieder eine etwas längere Pause als ursprünglich gedacht.
Aber naja, man muss das ja alles nicht in einem Stück hören.
Hauptsache ihr hört es überhaupt und findet es auch interessant und hilfreich,
was wir hier erzählen. Jetzt ist halt ein bisschen viel aufgelaufen.
Na gut, dann denke ich können wir es dabei auch erstmal belassen.
Wir werden natürlich die Situation weiter verfolgen und insbesondere jetzt hier
auch diese politische Diskussion und wenn wir wieder das Gefühl haben,
jetzt ist mal Zeit, mal wieder alles zusammenzufassen, dann werden wir das auch tun.
Aber so oder so sind wir glaube ich beide noch in einem mehr oder weniger täglichen
Rhythmus, alle Nachrichten in irgendeiner Form abzulegen und dann wiederkeulen
wir das dann hier für euch.
Und vermutlich wird ein interessanter Punkt sein, eben spätestens im April,
so wenn sowohl in den USA als auch in Russland sich Dinge abzeichnen oder wenn
militärisch jetzt Dinge passieren.
Und ein Problem natürlich bei der ganzen Situation ist, dass wenn heute eine
politische Entscheidung getroffen wird,
dass sechs Monate vergehen, bis sich an der Front irgendwelche Auswirkungen zeigen.
Das heißt, so die nächsten sechs Monate sind eigentlich mehr oder weniger gesetzt, was so.
Also da können wir nicht mehr viel dran ändern, was dort jetzt passieren wird.
Weil selbst die Ukrainer sind jetzt die nächsten sechs Monate wahrscheinlich
darauf angewiesen, mit dem klarzukommen,
was eben vor Monaten geplant, beschlossen und eingetütet wurde.
Das ist das Tragische und das Gefährliche an der Situation ist,
es gibt halt auch militärischen Konflikten Kipppunkte.
Es sieht zwar nicht so aus, dass irgendwie einer erreicht wird jetzt,
dass plötzlich die ukrainische Front zusammenbricht und die Russen plötzlich
wieder vormarschieren.
Das ist eher unwahrscheinlich, aber nichtsdestotrotz, das kündigt sich nicht
an. Also man weiß es meistens erst immer hinterher.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das Dilemma und das Unschöne,
dass jetzt wieder sechs Monate verschwendet wurden und dadurch die Ukraine in
eine unnötig schlimme Situation geraten wird.
So sieht es aus. Okay, jetzt aber Schluss. Wir sagen Tschüss,
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir hören uns dann bald wieder. Bis bald.
Ja, mach's gut. Ciao.